THE. OKAY THE SENATE BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW SUB COMMITTEE WILL
COME TO ORDER GOOD MORNING. WHEN
IS THE S. AS WE CONTINUE TO TAKE
SOME PRECAUTIONS TO MANAGE
ONGOING COVERT NINETEEN RISKS
THE SENATE CONTINUES TO WELCOME
THE PUBLIC AND HAS PROVIDED
ACCESS TO BOTH IN PERSON AND
TELECONFERENCE BURKE DISSIPATION
IN PUBLIC FOR PUBLIC COMMENT.
FOR INTO IS WISHING TO PROVIDE A
COMMON THE TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
OF TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. 877-226-8163 AN ACCESS CODE.
SEVEN THREE SIX TWO EIGHT THREE
THREE. WE WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM
DURING THE AS IS CUSTOMARY
ALTHOUGH WE DON'T EXPECT ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTIVE MAY
BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE. OTHER
CONNECTIONS MUTED. IN ARKHAM
MANY HEARINGS HERE IN THE-
STREET BUILDING ASK ALL MEMBERS
THE WE ARE READY HERE OF THOSE
PROVIDING TESTIMONY BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE TODAY ARE ALSO
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY FOR OUR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS. THIS
WILL GREATLY HELP IN ELIMINATING
THE ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK I ASK THAT
EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED THAT YOU USE THE
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING. WOULD
LIKE IT PLEASE DO BEFORE YOU
BEGIN SPEAKING OUR- HIGHLY
TRAINED I THE PERSONNEL WILL PUT
YOU BACK ON MUTE WHEN YOU ARE
DONE. WAS RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK
PLEASE MAKE SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN
ON THE SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME
AND THEN YOU ARE READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW
THE PUBLIC ACCESS WITH ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
HEARING ROOM TO THE EXTENT THAT
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW. AND WE WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE RIVERS FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. PUBLIC COMMENT WILL BE
HEARD AFTER ALL DISCUSSION ITEMS
HAVE BEEN PUT UP PRESENTED.
BEFORE WE BEGIN- DR FRANCIS
LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM. HE'S
CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR DRAWS ALL
HERE SENATOR ALSO HERE SENATOR
CORTEZ HE SENATOR CORTEZ THE
HERE SENATOR NEWMAN SENATOR
NEWMAN HERE AND CENTER GROVE IS
ABSENT. SO WE HAVE ONE. WE HAVE
QUORUM THANK YOU. OF THE
CONSULTANT- THE CORN HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED IN TODAY'S HEARING
WE WILL HAVE EIGHT DISCUSSION
ITEMS FOR THE EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS AND THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF HUMAN
SERVICES. AGAIN WE WILL BE
DISCUSSING ALL THE ISSUES LISTED
IN THE DISCUSSION SESSION
SECTION OF THE AGENDA FIRST THEN
TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT AND FINALLY
TAKE OUR VOTES ON THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS THAT WE DISCUSSED IN
OUR MARCH FIRST. TWENTY TWO FEB
HEARINGS. WE WILL NOW BEGIN WITH
ISSUE SIXTEEN THE SENATE
DEMOCRATS PUTTING WEALTH TO WORK
PROPOSALS FOR RETURNING CARE
GIVERS TO WORK. WE WILL BEGIN
WITH A CASE ALAMO FROM THE-
BELIAU THEN MOVE ON TO CHRISTINE
SCHUMACHER CALIFORNIA BUDGET AND
POLICY CENTER AND THEN CATHERINE
WHICH IT FROM LEGAL AID AT WORK
. MISTER ELEMENT. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS HAS ALOE WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE I'M
AS YOU SIXTEEN IS A COMPONENT OF
THE SENATE BUDGET PLAN AND SOME
OF THE WRITERS THE
PREFABRICATION SCRIPTURE OF THE
PROPOSAL- BEFORE TURNING IT OVER
TO YOUR OTHER PANELISTS- THE
PROPOSAL HAS TO DO WITH WAYS
REPLACEMENT RATES FOR THE
STATE'S SUPPOSED ABILITY
INSURANCE AND PAID FAMILY LEAVE
PROGRAM FOR. AN INDIVIDUAL'S
BECOME DISABLED FOR TAKE LEAVE
FOR- REASONS ELIGIBLE UNDER THE
PAID FAMILY THE MOST AND ONE TO
ONE WITH. A NEW CHILD- THERE
ALWAYS WILL RECEIVE A CURRENT
LAW SIX OR SO PER. OF THEIR-
DIFFICULT WAGES ARE FOR PERIOD
OF EIGHT TO SEE WEEKS DEPENDING
ON PUBLIC. THE PROPOSAL THE
SENATE FORTY IN THE WAIT REPLACE
RATES SIXTY AND 70% AS I
MENTIONED I TWO SEVENTY EIGHT
AND NINETY PERCENT- THE
DIFFERENCE BEING THAT WAITER
BOYS RACE WOULD BE SET AT 70%
FOR. MIDDLE AND UPPER WAGE
EARNERS AND WILL BE SAID IF 90%
WAGE REPLACEMENT FOR LOW
ANSWERED LOW MIDDLE RANGE-
INCOME WORKERS YOU'RE A WAITER
PLACEMENT RATES WOULD GO INTO
EFFECT BEGINNING IN. TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. IT IS. FINALLY
EIGHT AT THE SAME TIME THE
PROPOSAL WOULD IN THE WAY
REPLACE RATES IT WOULD ALSO
ELIMINATE A CAP ON IN STATE LAW-
ON THE TAXABLE WAGE BASE- SO
THAT PAID FAMILY LEAVE AND
DISABILITY INSURANCE PROGRAM IS
FUNDED. BY A LEAD PAINT PAYROLL
THOSE TAXES ARE ONLY DO UNDER
CURRENT LAW ON THE FIRST A
HUNDRED FORTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN WAGES SO ANY MONEY
THAT WORKERS ARE IN ADDITION A
SORT OF AN ACTUAL FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS IS NOT SUCH TO
THIS WORLD. THAT. WOULD BE
SUBJECT TO THE TAX. IN THE END
DEVELOPMENT FOR APART- DAY ON
THE- IT APPEARS ABOUT TWENTY PER
OF WE- CURRENTLY OR ABOUT THAT
CAP SO BY. HOW THE EXISTING
PAYROLL. WOULD DISTRICT GENERATE
ADDITIONAL HUNDRED TO FUND THESE
INCREASED BENEFITS BEGINNING IN
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE I HAVE TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS BUT OTHERWISE
I'LL TURN IT OVER TO YOUR OTHER
PANELISTS THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- SHOE MACHER. SHARE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS KRISTEN SURE HER
NUMBER THE CALIFORNIA BUDGET
POLICY CENTER APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY I'VE
BEEN ASKED TO REVIEW KEY POINTS
FROM TWO ANALYSES RELEASED BY
THE BUDGET CENTER. JUST THIS
YEAR. THE VAST MAJORITY OF
WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA
CONTRIBUTED TO THE STATE'S PAID
FAMILY LEAVE AND DISABILITY
INSURANCE PROGRAMS. AND THEY'RE
ELIGIBLE FOR PAID TIME OFF AS
CARE NEEDS ARE RICE. BUT LOW
PAYMENT RATES BLOCK WORKERS FROM
USING THESE PROGRAMS IN TIMES OF
NEED. BECAUSE MANY WORKERS CAN'T
PAY THE BILLS WITH A FRACTION OF
THEIR ATTORNEYS. OUR RECORDS
WITH LOW WAGE. WHO AND HEALTH
ARE JUST. WOMEN BLACK AND WHITE
NEXT WORKERS THIS IS
PARTICULARLY TRUE BECAUSE
THEY'RE ALREADY STRUGGLING TO
GET BY ON 1100% OF THIRTY. SO
THIS FIRST CHART SHOWS THAT 37%
OF THE WORKERS ELIGIBLE FOR PAID
TIME OFF OUR WORKERS PAID LESS
THAN TWENTY THOUSAND ANNUALLY.
YES THE SAME WORKERS ARE UNDER
REPRESENTED IN THOSE UTILIZING
PAID FAMILY LEAVE THEY COMPRISE
JUST 40% OF THOSE WHO TOOK PAID
LEAVE IN TWENTY TWENTY. ONE NOT
SHOWN HERE IN THIS CHART WORKERS
PAID THE WAGES ARE ALSO UNDER
REPRESENTED AMONG THOSE USING
THE STATE'S DISABILITY INSURANCE
PROGRAM. FOR THEIR OWN HEALTH
CONCERNS. THE GRAPHIC
ILLUSTRATES THE BENEFIT TO
CALIFORNIA'S PAID FAMILY LEAVE
AND DISABILITY INSURANCE
PROGRAMS ARE LOWER THAN
BENEFITS. IN MOST OTHER STATES
WITH SIMILAR PROGRAMS. SO
CALIFORNIA WORKERS WITH VERY LOW
WAGES FOR C. PANT REYES EQUAL
270% OF THEIR EARNINGS. AND ALL
OTHER WORKERS EARN 60% OF
EARNINGS. EVEN FULL TIME WORKERS
EIGHT THE STATEWIDE MINIMUM WAGE
TO FIFTEEN DOLLARS PER HOUR TOO
MUCH. TO QUALIFY FOR THE HIGHER
PAY RATE. OTHER STATES HEALTH.
REPRESENT ON THE SHIRT WITH THE
ORANGE BAR HAS THE SECOND LOWEST
PAYMENT RATE FOR WORKERS MAKING
FIFTEEN DOLLARS PER HOUR. STATE
AND THE DISTRICT OF COLUMBIA
WOULD PROVIDE AT LEAST 90% WE
JUST WELL TAKING TIME OFF AN
OREGON HAS THE HIGHEST PAYMENT
RATES FOR WORKERS WITH LOW WAGES
PROVIDING 1100% OF WAGES WHEN
TAKING LIFE. AND WITHOUT
ACTUALLY THIS YEAR OUR PAYMENT
RATES FOR THESE PROGRAMS WILL
REVERT TO JUST 55% OF EARNINGS
AT THE END OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO
. AS YOU HURT CALIFORNIA'S PAID
FAMILY LEAVE AND STATE
DISABILITY INSURANCE PROGRAMS
ARE FUNDED ENTIRELY WITH WORKERS
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE DISABILITY
INSURANCE FUND. AND IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT THIS FUND REMAINS
SOLVENT TO ENSURE WORKERS
RECEIVE THE BENEFITS THAT
THEY'VE PAID FOR. CURRENTLY
WORKERS DO NOT CONTRIBUTE ONCE A
FINE ON EARNINGS OVER CERTAIN
AMOUNT AGAIN REFER TO AS THE
WEEKS ON. SET AT ABOUT A HUNDRED
FORTY FIVE THOUSAND PER YEAR.
THE CURRENT PROPOSAL TO INCREASE
PAYMENT RATES WILL ENSURE THAT
DISABILITY INSURANCE FUND REMAIN
SOLVENT REMOVING THIS WEEK
CEILING. AS ILLUSTRATED IN THE
FINAL TURN- DATA. INVESTITORI OF
HEALTH BURKE WOULD BE HONEST. BY
THE CHANGE. JUST 9% OF HIGH
INCOME WORKERS HAD. ABOUT THAT
WE SILLY. TWENTY TWENTY. BUT I
DO SEE PAYMENT RTES
PARTICULARLY FOR LOWER WAGE
WORKERS. WE WOULD ELIMINATE A
KEY BARRIER TO ACCESS YOU NEED
TO PROGRAMS. AND A LOT MORE
CALIFORNIANS TAKE PAID TIME OFF
PAID TIME OFF THAT THEY PAY FOR
THE CARE FOR THEMSELVES. AND
THEIR FAMILIES. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS MY CONTACT
INFORMATIONS ON THE SLIDE IF YOU
WERE TO GET IN TOUCH AFTER THE
HEARING AS WELL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISS US YOU. AND NOW WE
WILL CONTINUE WITH MISS WHICH IS. GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME MY NAME IS KATHERINE
WHICH AND I'M A STAFF ATTORNEY
FOR LEGAL AID AT WORKS WORK AND
FAMILY PROGRAM WHICH EMPOWERS
WORKERS WHO ARE PREGNANT PARENTS
FAMILY CARE GIVERS OR WITH THEIR
OWN SERIOUS HEALTH CONDITIONS.
TIME OFF FROM WORK AND GET OTHER
WORK PLACE TO COMMONSENSE AND AS
A PART OF THAT WORK WE OPERATE A
FREE WORKING FAMILY HEALTH LINE
WHERE WE OFFER LEGAL ADVICE AND
INFORMATION ABOUT CARE GIVING
AND PARENTING WORKPLACE RIGHT.
EVERY YEAR WE RECEIVE OVER
THOUSAND CALLS FROM FOLKS
WORKING IN INDUSTRIES ALL ACROSS
THE STATE STRUGGLING TO SEE HOW
THEY CAN MEET THEIR FAMILY CARE
NEEDS WITHOUT RISKING ECONOMIC
RUIN. AND ONE ISSUE THAT WE'VE
SEEN COME UP FREQUENTLY FOR
YEARS IS THE INACCESSIBILITY OF
PAID FAMILY LEAVE AND STATE
DISABILITY INSURANCE TO
CALIFORNIANS WITH LOW INCOMES.
ALMOST ALL WORKERS ACROSS THE
STATE PAYS ALL FRACTION OF THEIR
I'M INTO THE FIND. THE IDEA
BEING THAT THIS WILL WHEN THEY
RECEIVE INCOME FROM THE FUNDS
FOR FAMILY CAREGIVING FUNDING OR
THEIR OWN HEALTH IT WILL ALLOW
THEM TO TAKE TIME OFF FROM WORK
AND SURVIVE WITHOUT THEIR
REGULAR WAGES. MOST WORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA RECEIVE 60% OF THEIR
REGULAR INCOME ON STI OR PAID
FAMILY LEAVE AND ONLY THOSE
MAKING UNDER ABOUT TWENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS ANNUALLY WILL
RECEIVE 70% OF THEIR INCOME. SO
NOT ONLY DOES THIS NOT PROVIDE
ENOUGH INCOME BECAUSE IT ASSUMES
THAT THE LOWEST WAGE
CALIFORNIANS CAN AFFORD TO GET
30% OF THEIR INCOME. EIGHT FOUR
DO YOU LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS
QUALIFY THAT COMPARATIVELY
HIGHER WAGE REPLACEMENT. RATE
THE- WORKERS. ENFOLDS MINIMUM
WAGE WORKERS IT DRAWS THE LINE
ADDED IN LEVELS LOW THAT IN A
TWO INCOME HOUSEHOLD TO PARENTS
RECEIVING BENEFITS COULD NOT
EVEN COVER THE BASIC COSTS OF
LIVING FOR TWO ADULTS AND AN
INFANT AND MODOC COUNTY MUCH
LESS LOS ANGELES OR THE BAY AREA
AND WE'VE SEEN THIS BORN OUT IN
OUR WORK WE'VE HEARD FROM NEW
MOTHER FAR MORE. FIRST WORKWEEKS
HAVING THEIR BABY THEY COULDN'T
AFFORD TO LIVE ON THE REST YEAH
I BENEFITS SOME HAVE LATER HAD
TO RE APPLY FOR STI BECAUSE THEY
WERE INJURED FROM RETURNING TO
WORK EARLY WE'VE HEARD FROM TWO
PARENT COLLEGE GRADUATE
HOUSEHOLDS WERE NEITHER PARENT
BABY BONDING LEAVE BECAUSE THEY
COULD NOT AFFORD TO LIVE OFF 60%
OF THEIR INCOME AS WELL AS THE
DAD WHO WAS ONLY ABLE TO SPEND
TWO HOURS WITH HIS NEW BABY AND
THE NEXT YEAR BECAUSE HE
COULDN'T AFFORD. MORE TIME UP.
AND DOCTORS HAVE SHARED WITH US
HOW LOW WAGE REPLACEMENT RATES
HAVE INTERFERED WITH THEIR
PATIENT CARE. A HUSBAND AND
FATHER WHO WAS DIAGNOSED WITH
CANCER AND KEPT WORKING IN
DELAYING TREATMENT FOR TOO LONG.
BECAUSE HE COULDN'T AFFORD
LEAVES WHO THEN DIED TUESDAY. TO
ADULT CHILDREN WHO HAD TO TAKE
WHO COULDN'T AFFORD TO TAKE
LEAVE CELL LEFT THEIR MOTHER WHO
HAD DEMENTIA HOME ALONE HAVING
NO OTHER CHOICE. AND IT RESULTED
IN AVOIDABLE EMERGENCY CARE.
I'VE SPOKEN WITH NEW MOTHERS FOR
WHOM THE IDEA THAT THEY COULD
LIVE OFF OF 60% OF THEIR INCOME
WAS SO ABSURD THAT THEY DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND HOW THIS COULD BE HOW
THE PROGRAM WAS ACTUALLY
DESIGNED. CALIFORNIA NEEDS A
PROGRAM THAT PROVIDES 90% OF
INCOME TO LOWER WAGE WORKERS.
AND DEFINES LOWER WAGE WORKERS
REALISTICALLY. THANK YOU FOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. SOME WE HAVE WILL
COME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
SENATORS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
GOOD GOOD GOOD THANK YOU YEAH
WELL OF I WANT TO THANK YOU ALL
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT- YOU KNOW
MANY OF US HAVE ENCOUNTERED IN
OUR WORK- AS FAR AS YOUR LOW
WAGE. YOUR LOW WAGE WORKER
YOU'RE TRYING TO SPEND TIME WITH
YOUR FAMILY WHETHER IT'S A AN
ELDERLY. PERSON WHO MAY BE ILL
OR YOUR NEWBORN BABY- THESE ARE
ALL SORT OF THINGS THAT WE SAY
WE KNOW MAKE YOUR- MONGER UP.
MAKE IT POSSIBLE FOR YOU TO HAVE
THE KIND OF RELATIONSHIP WITH
YOUR FAMILY THAT THAT
STRENGTHENS IT LEADS TO A
STRONGER COMMUNITY- SO I THINK
THERE ARE SO MANY THINGS THAT
ARE IMPACTED BY THIS THAT IT'S-
KIND OF EMBARRASSING THAT
CALIFORNIA'S THE LOW COMPARED
TO- COMPARED TO OTHER STATES AS
FAR AS WHAT WE ACTUALLY-
PROVIDE. AND I THINK THE LAST
POINT IS THAT THIS IS A BENEFIT
THAT'S PAID FOR BY THE WORKERS
THEMSELVES. LAWYERS DO NOT
CONTRIBUTE BUT SO BEING ABLE TO
UTILIZE SOMETHING THAT YOU'RE
PAYING INTO I THINK IS THE MOST
FAIR THING THAT WE CAN DO
BESIDES THE STRENGTH THAT IT
PROVIDES FOR OUR- FAMILY. OF I'M
REALLY PROUD OF THIS AS-
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE GOING TO-
URGE THE- GOVERNOR TO ACCEPT IN
HIS BUDGET SO- THANK YOU ALL
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU TO THE
MEMBERS OF THE PANEL WHO ARE
HERE TODAY YOU SHOULD YOU'RE
VERY MUCH AND THANKS FOR THE
SPECIFIC. EXAMPLES THAT YOU GAVE
ABOUT THE IMPACT THAT THIS HAS
ON ON PEOPLE. OKAY WE MOVE ON
NOW TO ISSUE. SEVENTEEN NINE.
ISSUE SEVENTEEN IS OUR-
STATEWIDE RE ENTRY EMPLOYMENT-
FUND WE WILL BEGIN AGAIN WITH MR
ALAMO FROM THE L. A. O. AND MOVE
ON TO SAM LEWIS THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION OF MR ALAMO PLEASE.
THANK YOU JAZZ ALMOST THE L. A.
L. DON JUST BRIEFLY- THIS ISSUE
ANOTHER COMPONENT OF THE SENATE
BUDGET PLANS ARE TO PROVIDE
FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR GENERAL
FUND ONE TIME PER WORKFORCE
PROGRAMS- FOUR FOUR ONE
WORKFORCE OUR REENTRY SERVICES
SPECIFICALLY- JUST BY WAY OF
CONTEXT BEFORE TURNING IT OVER
TO YOUR PANELISTS ON. THE STATE
HAS OPERATED A WORKFORCE PROGRAM
KNOWN AS THE PRISON TO
EMPLOYMENT PROGRAM OUT OF THE
CALIFORNIA. WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD FOR THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS. SO THIS PROPOSAL
WOULD SEE. RUN ALONG SIDE- ON GO
STATE- AND SAN MARINO THANK YOU
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- AND NOW
MR LEWIS GREAT TO SEE YOU MISTER
LEWIS THANK YOU FOR ALL OF US
YOUR WORK AND- LOOK FORWARD TO
YOUR COMMENTS. ONE OF THANK YOU
SO MUCH OF A. OF THE ONE OF MY
NAME IS SAYS NO SECOND THOUGHT
OF A C. THAT TIME CITY WHEN THE
COALITION. RIGHT HOME FROM A CAR
RACING FACE TO. MORE TRIGGERS A
WHEN IT COMES TO THE MARK. TOO
MANY CAR PEOPLE REMAIN OUT OF OR
DON'T HAVE A CHANCE TO GAINES
ARE. THE BILL LASTING SAY CAREER
. THERE'S ALWAYS BEEN A DISK
BETWEEN THE REENTRY POPULATION
EQUALITY CAREERS. WHATEVER
SERVICES HAVE BEEN AVAILABLE
WERE STRAINED IMMENSELY DOLLAR
CALL WITHIN HAVE BECOME
CHALLENGING FOR PROTEST THIS
HOST AND THEN. I CANNOT STRESS
ENOUGH THE IMPORTANCE OF OUR
ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS THEY ARE
SEEN THE PROVIDE QUALITY WORK
FOR SERVICES. REENTRY PROVIDERS
HAVE A SPECIFIC EXPERTISE IN
PROGRAMMING THAT INCLUDES
WRAPAROUND SERVICES EMPLOYER
NETWORKS THAT'S SUPPORT
INDIVIDUALS THAT OPPOSED. OCEANS
INCARCERATIONS. WE AGREE THE
COMING DESIRE TO PRIVATE WHAT TO
FOR BETTER FOR ORGAN SPECIAL.
BETTER WHO ABILITY TO ASSIST
PEOPLE BUYING GAMES ONE POINT
SIX. VERY BACK INTO. THIS ONE
TIME INVESTMENT ONE DOLLARS IN
WORK FOR INVESTMENT. AND
CALIFORNIA WAS FOURTH FOR MORE
WILL PROVIDE DEDICATED MULTI
YEARS STATE FARM COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND RESEARCH
INSTITUTIONS CAPACITY OPENED.
SUCCESSFUL CAREER TRACKS SUCH AS
THE MULTI CRAFT CORE CURRICULUM
. INSTANT RELIEF TRAINING
PROGRAMS FOR PROGRAMS THAT OFFER
UNSUBSIDIZED JOBS IN THE
COMMUNITY AND SKILL PROGRAM
PROSTATE THE SERVER MORE JUSTICE
IMPACTED AN. INDIVIDUAL WE HOPE
TO STATE ADMINISTERED STATE
MANAGED BONTA OUR ROUTE. OTHER
CAL WORK FOR BOARDS IN THIS.
RAMPANT HELP EXPAND BEEN
STABILIZED BASED ON THE- SUCH AS
THEY ARE C. ONE MULTI CRAFT
CURRICULUM AND TRY PROGRAMS FOR
THE COUNTRY TO WERE.
INSTRUCTIONS TRADE SUCH AS
PLUMBERS BRICKLAYERS ELECTRIC.
MANY OTHER TRADES THE STATE.
THEY ARE C. RUNS A ECORD OF
COURSE RATED. WE HAVE SIR OVER
HER AND FORTY MEMBERS BUSCA
SEVENTY FIVE BUT WITH A 75% RATE
71% UNION JOB PLACEMENT RATE.
HUNDREDS OF FORMER COURSE REMOTE
PEOPLE ARE NOW. EARNING UNION
WAGES AND ARE ABLE. TO SAY THE
FAMILY IN OF THE THERE COULD.
SIMPLY WE KNOW GO WILL NEVER
BACK TO PRISON LAW PATHWAY TO
THE GYM BECOMING. THERE EARNING
A LIVING WAGE WITH JOB SECURITY
AN OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE A FOOD
LOCAL CAREER THIS IN ADDITION
ENHANCES PUBLIC SAFETY.
PERFORMANCE PARTIALLY PEOPLE TO
SUCCEED IN THE WORKFORCE THEY
NEED TO BE SUPPORTABLE BY
ORGANIZATION THAT CAN PROVIDE
ROBUST HUMAN CENTERED WRAPAROUND
SERVICES WHEN PEOPLE COME HOME
IT WE STILL STRUGGLE. AND
GRAPPLE WITH THE TRANSITION TO
SOCIETY FROM INCARCERATIONS
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES INCLUDING
LIFE COACHING THERAPY IN HOUSING
MENTORING. ALL VITALLY IMPORTANT
. DOES NOT SAY THIS THIS
SUPPORTS AND AVERAGE. COST PER
OF SEVEN POWER SEVEN HUNDRED
BEFORE DOLLARS PER PER. ALLOW TO
ORGANIZE SYSTEM ROUGHLY SO FOUR
THOUSAND HUNDRED SUPPORT ALSO
HUNDRED. THE COST SUCCESSFULLY
SUPPORT ONE PERSON COURT. IS
SIGNIFICANTLY LOWER THAN A
HUNDRED AND SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS
ACOSTA INCARCERATED PERSON FOR
ONE YEAR. THIS INVESTMENT WILL
SAVE TAXPAYERS NINE EIGHT
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN
DOLLARS A YEAR FOR EVERY ONE
PERSON SUCCESSFULLY COMPLETE THE
COR PERSON CORPORATE PROGRAM. A
FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT
COULD TRANSFORM EMPLOYMENT
LANDSCAPE. BUT JUST AS INVOLVED
INDIVIDUALS. I WAS JUST LET WEEK
ONE OF OUR MAIN ACT HAVE THE
ARE. GOOGLE FOR AWHILE HOUSE AND
- THIS SUCCESS A VETERAN. AND
NOW HE'S BEEN INVITED TO THE
WHITE HOUSE THIS GERMAN SERVE
TWENTY FOUR YEARS AND WILL BE
SERVED WILL BE SHARING THAT
VIDEO OF THE ROUNDHOUSE TABLE
WITH MISTER MORGAN ARE
PRESENTED. THIS IS SIMPLY THE
EASIEST WAY FOR US TO LET THE
MOST MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES
AND BY LIFTING THE MOST
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES LET US
ALL THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY.
AND COMMITTEE. THANK YOU MISTER
WITH. WE SEE WITH NEW. HUACHUCA
OKAY. LATER OF OKAY OKAY OKAY I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
LEWIS- THE MIGLIOR WITH YOUR
WORK AND- VERY PROUD THAT THAT
YOU'RE HERE SHARING YOUR YOUR
TESTIMONY COULD YOU TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT. A WHAT'S THE
CONNECTION DOES THIS PROGRAM
START- ONCE- THE INDIVIDUAL IS
RELEASED OR PRIOR TO THAT WHAT'S
THE CONNECTION TO. OF
PREPARATION BEFORE THE
INDIVIDUALS ARE RELEASED- TO GO
INTO THESE PROGRAMS OF GETTING
THE JOB AFTER THEY'RE RELEASED.
YES MA'AM SO THIS PARTICULAR ONE
WAS SUPPORT PEOPLE THAT ARE
RELEASED UPON THEIR RELEASE- THE
WAY IT WORKS IS THEY'RE PAID A
STIPEND OR FIFTEEN DOLLARS AN
HOUR SPECIFICALLY TO TRAIN IN A
PRE APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM. OR
ANOTHER TRACK THE PANEL WITH THE
WITH THE APPOINTMENT FOR OUR PRE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM IS
FIFTEEN DOLLARS AN HOUR. BUT
THIRTEEN WEEKS. YOU'RE GOING TO
A YOUNG. AND SO I'VE THAT
THIRTEEN WEEK WHEN THEY SHOW UP
ON TO DO EVERYTHING CORRECTLY
THEY'RE ABLE TO GOING TO THE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM WHICH IS
THE FIRST STEP INTO A UNION
PROGRAM. WITHIN THREE TO FIVE
YEARS THE JOURNEY OUT AND SOLD
THIS ALLOWS THE INDIVIDUALS HAS
BEEN RELEASED FROM INCARCERATION
TO NOT HAVE TO STRUGGLE WITH
BOTH. PURSUANT EDUCATION OR
TRAINING AND WORKING. BY
ALLOWING THEM TO COMBINE THE TWO
TRAINING AND BE IN A WORD ABOUT
EARNS SOME MONEY SO THAT THEY
CAN SURVIVE WHILE THE WILD WILD.
IN SOCIETY. I LIKE TO SHOW UP ON
A ON A- HIGH NOTE WHEN YOU THINK
THAT SOME OF OUR MEMBERS SHARE
WITH ME. EVERY A JOURNEY OUT
BETWEEN THREE AND FIVE YEARS
EARNS EASILY SIX FIGURES IN THE
MORNING. THAT'S VERY GOOD TO
KNOW. THAT'S VERY GOOD THAT'S
CERTAINLY SOMETHING TO LOOK
FORWARD TO. ANYONE YEAH THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
SENATORS COMMENTS QUESTIONS.
SOMEWHAT TIMELY I GUESS I WAS AT
THE TENTH ANNIVERSARY OF THE
REENTRY CENTER IN SANTA CLARA
COUNTY- JUST- TEN DAYS TEN DAYS
AGO. IN HERE YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY
THE WORK IS THE- REALIGNMENT-
I GUESS NO PUN INTENDED BUT- THE
HOUSING IN THE EMPLOYMENT
BARRIERS ARE STILL- THE TWO
BIGGEST THINGS THAT THAT YOU SEE
THE PROGRAM'S WORKING THE- YOU
KNOW THE- SORT OF THE BUILT IN
WRAPAROUND SERVICES IN. THE
RECEPTION AND EVERYTHING THAT
GOES ALONG WITH RE ENTRY PROCESS
THAT I COULD SEE AT LEAST OUR
OWN COUNTY IS. WONDERFUL BUT THE
- INTERSECTION BETWEEN- ADEQUATE
INCOME TO AFFORD HOUSING IS-
THIS IS STILL A HUGE ISSUE SO
IT'S GREAT TO SEE THIS. THIS
EFFORT. THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND
FINALLY MR LEWIS COULD YOU
EXPLAIN A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE-
WHAT US SENATOR CORTESE JUST
MENTIONED THE WRAPAROUND
SERVICES HOW THEY FIT INTO THIS
OF OPPORTUNITY FOR. PRE
APPRENTICESHIP AND THEN
APPRENTICESHIP- THE WORK THAT
YOU DO BUT HOW DID THE
WRAPAROUND SERVICES FIT INTO ALL
OF THIS HOW DO YOU COORDINATE.
ABSOLUTELY SO SORT OF BEING
BILLION WOULD ALSO GO GO BACK TO
YOUR PREVIOUS QUESTION OF NOT A
R. SUM GOES INTO ALL THE PRISONS
EVERY PERSON IS INCARCERATED
WILL BE AWARE OF THE SERVICES
AVAILABLE BECAUSE WE WILL MAKE
SURE THAT. WE'RE PASSING THIS
INFORMATION ALONG TO OUR LIFE
COACHES AND ALL THIRTY THREE
PRISONS. THEN SPECIFICALLY TO
THE QUESTION THAT YOU JUST ACT
WRAPAROUND SERVICES INCLUDE
EVERYTHING FROM THERAPY
OFTENTIMES PEOPLE GOING TO
PRISON WHAT A GREAT DEAL OF
COMEDY HAS NOT BEEN ADDRESSED
AND SADLY WHILE IMPRISONED THOSE
PROBLEMS ARE NOT ADDRESSED AND
SO WHEN A WRAPAROUND SERVICES
WILL BE ACCESS TO REPAIR.
ANOTHER IS HOUSING IN ORDER FOR
A PERSON TO BE ABLE TO REALLY
SEE SEED- AND EMPLOYMENT AND
CREATE A PATHWAY FROM
INCARCERATION YOU HAVE TO HAVE A
SAFE PLACE TO REST ANDTO
PREPARE TO GO TO WORK TODAY SO
HOUSING IS CONSIDERED ONE OF
THE- BROWSERS. OF THE BILL'S
WRAPS AROUND SERVICES AS A
PERSON LEARNS HOW TO MANAGER AND
BUDGET MIGHT FINANCIAL LITERACY
- MENTORING AND- NAVIGATION AND
GUIDANCE- BLOOD TO THE
TRANSITION FROM INCARCERATION-
TWO OF THREE. ARE THERE ARE
OFTEN TIMES WHEN WE LOOK AT
INDIVIDUALS COME UP CARS RACED
AWAY FORGET THAT SERBS MAYBE IT
WAS WHEN AND WHEN WE WERE
TEENAGERS AND HALF HAVE NOT
LIVED UP FOR LIFE. I DON'T FULLY
UNDERSTAND HOW TO USE A CREDIT
CARD WITH A CREDIT CARD HOW TO
OPEN A BANKACCOUNT. OF HOW TO
ACTUALLY APPLY FOR A LOAN OR IF
I WANTED TO GET AN APARTMENT HOW
TO WHAT I FILL. YOU KNOW- THIS
IS A BALLPARK OF RAPPER SERVE
INC ADDITIONAL SUCH AS A PERSON
OF FINES THEY GOODNESS FAMILY
AND THEY NEED THAT PR TO HAVE
SOME OF A- THOSE ARE ALL WRAPPED
SIR SO WHEN WE WHEN WE SEE INTO
WRAPAROUND CASE MANAGEMENT SIR.
ALL THINGS BUILT TO THE PEOPLE
ARE IN THESE PROGRAMS. THANK
OKAY WONDER WELL- A PRE ALL OF
THE WORK THAT- AIR C. DOES ALL
OF THE OTHER ORGANIZATIONS ON
THAT ARE ON THE GROUND- AND-
PROVIDING THESE SERVICES BECAUSE
I THINK YOU HIT ON THE NAIL
IMAGINE THE CUSTOM PRISON
COMPARED TO THE COST OF HELPING
INDIVIDUALS- GET BACK ON TRACK
WITH THEMSELVES AND THEIR
FAMILIES SELF THANK YOU AGAIN MR
LEWIS- APPRECIATE YOU VERY MUCH
WELL. OKAY MOVEON NOUNS TO ISSUE
EIGHTEEN. HE ISSUE EIGHTEEN IS
ALLOCATION TO THE CALIFORNIA
YOUTH LEADERSHIP CORPS FOR
CAREER PATHWAYS AGAIN- MISTER
ALAMO FROM THE ALEJO'S OFFICE
THEN WE MOVE ON TO. OUR DOCTOR
ROSA GARCIA EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA YOUTH
LEADERSHIP CORPS AND CO DIRECTOR
OF COMMUNITY LEARNING
PARTNERSHIP- MR ELEMENT. THANK
YOU DOES ALMOST ALEJO- THIS ITEM
IS ANOTHER SENATE BUDGET PLAN
COMPONENT AND BY WAY OF CONTEXT-
THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET
INCLUDED TEN MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND ONE TIME FOR THE
CALIFORNIA YOUTH LEADERSHIP
PROGRAM LANGUAGE JUSTICE
PATHWAYS- AND INNOCENCE AS WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THE PROPOSAL
WOULD. PROVIDE US WITH GRANT
FUNDING TO NONPROFIT COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS TO BRING ON-
STUDENT APPRENTICES AND INTERNS
ARE AND TO BE ABLE TO PAY THEM-
THE INTERNS AND APPRENTICES AND
TO BE ABLE TO COVER SOME OF THE
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH ME. OUR STUDENTS CAN TURN
PROGRAM. THAT SENATE PROPOSAL HE
- INCREASES. ARE THE GOVERNOR'S
JANUARY OF BUDGETED AMOUNTS BY A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND ONE TIME. TO PROVIDE THREE
COMPONENTS OF FUNDING THE FIRST
IS TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
TO- SUPPORT OVERHEAD COSTS OR
OVERHEAD EXPENSES ARE THE SECOND
IS FORTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
SPECIFICALLY FOR SCHOLARSHIPS
AND STUDENT THE- CALORIES. AND
THE LAST COMPONENT THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO SUPPORT THE
NONPROFIT HOST ORGANIZATIONS ARE
HOSTING THE STUDENTS- I WOULD
WITHOUT FURTHER DO- I WILL HAND
IT OVER OBVIOUSLY TO SEE OUR
PANELISTS. TO SPEAK MORE ABOUT
THE PROGRAM THANK YOU. THANK
YOU- THE GRACE. PLEASE I THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE IT'S AN HONOR FOR
ME TO JOIN YOU TODAY MY NAME IS
ROSS AYE GARCIA AND I SERVICE
THANK YOU DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA
YOUTH LEADERSHIP CORPS AND CO
DIRECTOR OF THE COMMUNITY
LEARNING PARTNERSHIP I WOULD
LIKE TO BEGIN BY EXPLAINING WHY
CALIFORNIA YOUTH LEADERSHIP
COURSE WORK MATTERS NOW. MORE
THAN EVER SEE WHAT ELSE HE WAS
CREATED IN RESPONSE TO THE
DRAMATIC IMPACTS OF THE GLOBAL
PANDEMIC AND THE ECONOMIC CRISIS
DURING THE PANDEMIC YOUNG PEOPLE
EXPERIENCE COUNTLESS JOB LOSSES
. EIGHT BASIC NEEDS ONCE IN
THEIR FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES
TO BE SURE MARGINAL MARGINALIZED
BLACK INDIGENOUS LATIN NEXT
ASIAN AMERICAN IMMIGRANT YOUTH
AND THEIR COMMUNITIES ARE MOST
IMPACTED BY THESE CRISES THE
NONPROFIT SECTOR WAS ALSO HIT
HARD AND IS IN DIRE NEED OF
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO HAVE THE
EXPERIENCE AND ACADEMIC
CREDENTIALS NECESSARY TO ASSUME
LEADERSHIP ROLES IN THE
NONPROFIT SECTOR. SINCE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. C. Y. L. C. HAS BEEN
PARTICIPATING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AGENCY SELECTED
COMMUNITY CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE THE COMMUNITY LEARNING
PARTNERSHIP LOCAL NONPROFITS AND
PRIVATE PHILANTHROPY TO DESIGN
AND PILOT COMMUNITY CHANGE LEARN
AND EARN CAREER PATHWAYS FOR
MARGINALIZED YOUTH. MADAM CHAIR
WE GREATLY APPRECIATE GOVERNOR
NEWSOM'S INCLUSION OF TEN
MILLION IN HIS BUDGET TO
STRENGTHEN WORKFORCE PATHWAYS
FOR QUALIFIED LANGUAGE
INTERPRETERS AND DOJ ACCREDITED
PROVIDERS OF COMMUNITY BASED
IMMIGRATION LEGAL SERVICES. AND
WE'RE THRILLED TO SEE THAT THE
SENATE MAJORITY LEADERSHIP HAS
INCLUDED AN ADDITIONAL HUNDRED
MILLION AND PROPOSE FUNDING FOR
C. Y. L. C. WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP IN CREATING AN
EQUITABLE ECONOMY FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS AND FOR HELPING TO
SHEPHERD THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL
THROUGH THE PROCESS. DISH
HUNDRED MILLION OVER A FOUR YEAR
PERIOD WILL ALLOW C. Y. L. C. IS
THE STAIN ITS CURRENT WORK AND
TO EXPAND TO A TOTAL OF TWENTY
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. THIS FUNDING
WILL TO SERVE OVER A TWO
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED STUDENTS
AND TO CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
LEARNING AREN'T CAREER PATHWAYS
I COMMUNITY COLLEGES INCLUDING
EAST LOS ANGELES COLLEGE. IT IS
IN YOUR DISTRICT. SEE WELL SEE
ADDRESSES SEVERAL CRITICAL
ISSUES AT ONCE FIRST IT CENTERS
EQUITY BY OFFERING EDUCATIONAL
AND CAREER ADVANCEMENT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
WHO HAVE BEEN MOST IMPACTED BY
THE GLOBAL PANDEMIC YOU'VE WITH
LOW INCOMES YOUTH OF COLOR
IMMIGRANT YOUTH OPPORTUNITY
YOUTH AND YOUTH YOUNG PEOPLE
IMPACTED BY THE CRIMINAL LEGAL
SYSTEM SEE WELL SEE CREEK THE
WORKFORCE PATHWAY FOR COMMUNITY
ORGANIZERS CHANGE AGENTS AND
YOUNG LEADERS IN THE NONPROFIT
SECTOR- SECOND. THE WEALTHY
PROMOTE ECONOMIC SECURITY BY
PAYING AT LEAST FIFTEEN DOLLARS
PER OUR STUDENTS GAIN WORK
EXPERIENCE A COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND CAN ARE NOT
TEN THOUSAND DURING THEIR
PARTICIPATION IN THE- THIRD. C.
O. L. C. TAPS INTO THE DESIRES
OF YOUNG PEOPLE TO CREATE
POSITIVE CHANGE IN THEIR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. FOR THE WHILE C.
HAS BEGUN COLLABORATING WITH
PARTNERS JUST STRENGTH IN
WORKFORCE PATHWAYS FOR QUALIFIED
LANGUAGE INTERPRETERS AND D. O.
J. CERTIFIED PROVIDERS OF
COMMUNITY BASED IMMIGRATION
LEGAL SERVICES AND HIGH NEED
AREAS OF THE STATE THESE EGGS
NEW CITING IMMIGRATION. TO
PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED CRITICAL
SERVICES TO UNDERSERVED
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA FIFTH SEE WELL SEIZE
HOLISTIC MODEL INCORPORATES
ROBUST WRAPAROUND SUPPORTS THAT
PROMOTE STUDENT SUCCESS CAREER
READINESS AND OVERALL HEALTH AND
WELL BEING. FINALLY I'D LIKE TO
LEAVE YOU WITH THE STORY ABOUT
HAVE YEAR A RECENT GRADUATE OF
C. Y. L. C. DE ANZA COLLEGE AS A
YOUNG PERSON IMPACTED BY THE
CRIMINAL LEGAL SYSTEM HABIA
WORRIED ABOUT HIS FUTURE HAVING
BEEN FORMERLY INCARCERATED HAVE
YOUR WAS ANXIOUS ABOUT ABOUT
ANXIOUS ABOUT HIS EMPLOYMENT AND
CAREER OPPORTUNITIES. HOWEVER
HOWEVER DUE TO THE GUIDANCE
SUPPORT AND EDUCATIONAL
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES HE
RECEIVED FROM C. Y. L. C. DANS A
COLLEGE AND COMMUNITY PARTNERS
SILICON VALLEY DO YOU. HAVE YOUR
IS NOW A COMMUNITY ORGANIZER A
COLLEGE STUDENT AND A YOUNG
LEADER HE RECENTLY GRADUATED
WITH A CERTIFICATE IN LEADERSHIP
AND SOCIAL CHANGE FROM DAN'S A
COLLEGE. AS A RESULT OF HIS
PARTICIPATION IN C. WASI C. Y.
L. C. HI THERE WAS ABLE TO GET
OFF PAROLE SECURE FULL FULL TIME
EMPLOYMENT AND NOW HAS A NEW
VISION FOR HIS LIFE AND
COMMUNITY. HAVE YOUR IS GRATEFUL
TO THE PROGRAM FOR OFFERING
THESE EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES
AND WORK BASED LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES THAT THE THAT HAVE
COMPLETELY CHANGED THE
TRAJECTORY OF HIS LIFE FOR THE
BETTER. IN SOME SEE WELL SEE IT
EXPANDING COMMUNITY CHANGE
PURPOSE REYES PLANS AND LYFT.
STRANGE WORKFORCE PATH IN
CRITICAL AREAS THAT ADDRESS
UNMET NEEDS IN IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE
THESE PATHWAYS ARE PROMOTING THE
- OF. THE DAY. AT THE SECURITY.
IT AND SO. SOCIAL BOB AMONG.
JULY'S THIS MADAM AND CLOSE I
YOU THE COMMITTEE AND YOUR
COLLEAGUES FOR SUPPORTING THIS
MESSAGE- ONE TIME INVEST.
HUNDRED TEN. I'LL BE PEOPLE WITH
ONLY AND YOUNG OF THRIVE AND
CIVICALLY IN. MEMBERS OF THEIR
COMMUNITIES THIS INVESTMENT IT
WILL ALLOW SEE WELL SEE TO
SUSTAIN THIS TRANSFORMATIVE WORK
AND TO EXPAND THESE IMPACTFUL
OPPORTUNITIES TO GREATER NUMBERS
OF MARGINALIZED USED ACROSS
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH DR GARCIA- SOUNDS LIKE
A VERY COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH TO
THE ISSUE THAT YOU RAISED I JUST
HAVE A QUESTION HERE IN TERMS OF
THIS PARTNERSHIP. OF IT'S A NEW
STATEWIDE PARTNERSHIP AND YOU
MENTIONED A NUMBER OF BOTH STATE
AGENCIES AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
CALIFORNIA DALMAN HILTON
FOUNDATION OF LOCAL NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS AND OTHER COMEY
PARTNERS HOW HOW DO YOU ENVISION
THAT WORKING WITH ACTUALLY SO
MANY. A DIFFERENT ENTITIES- AT
THE TABLE. I'M SURE WELL WE-
WE'VE ESTABLISHED ANIMAL USE
WITH THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE OUR
PARTNERS- AND SO WE'VE LAID OUT
THE SCOPE OF WORK- THAT WE ARE
ARE DOING TOGETHER ON. ALL RIGHT
THE V. AND NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT STUDENTS ARE
DOING THEIR INTERNSHIPS AND SO
THERE ARE- THERE ARE SEVERAL
PIECES TO THIS OUR STATE
PARTNERS ARE THE LABOR AGENCY-
YOU KNOW WE HAVE. A MONTHLY
CALL- WE HAVE- COMMUNICATION
WITH A COMMUNITY COLLEGE TEAMS
ARE SO WE HAVE SET UP A
STRUCTURE ON THAT FLOWS VERY
NICELY- AND THAT REALLY BREAKS
ALL OF. PARTNERS TOGETHER ARE
ONCE A MONTH WE HAVE- WE HAVE
MEETINGS WITH WITH FACULTY AND
STAFF- ADD TO AND WE REALLY
SPENT TIME IN THIS PAST YEAR
BUILDING OUT THAT STRUCTURE AND
THIS IN THE INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
THIS PROGRAM. OKAY CENTERS
COMMENTS QUESTIONS. SENATOR
WE'VE HAD YOU JUST A BRIEF
POSITIVE COMMENT RIGHT SO I
THINK WE HEARD THIS INTERVIEW
COMMITTEE AND I AM IMPRESSED
HAVE YOU DONE A BUNCH OF
WORKFORCE MOMENTS OF THE PAST AT
JUST HOW GOOD AN IDEA THIS IS
HOW JUST HOW NECESSARY TO INVEST
SAYS SO I YOU KNOW LIKE I
COMMEND YOU I COMMEND MISTER SEA
IN EVERYBODY WORKING ON THIS. T.
A. U. B. B. X. BUT THIS IS
PRECISELY WHAT WE NEED TO DO-
TO- INVEST IN AND GUIDE
CALIFORNIA'S. HUMAN CAPITAL OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE TOWARD THE
OPPORTUNITIES. FOR WHICH THEY
ARE MENTALLY TALENTED BUT
OTHERWISE MIGHT NOT HAVE A
CHANCE TO PURSUE- GLAD TO
SUPPORT THIS. I SHOULD THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIR NEWMAN. OKAY
I THINK WE WILL AGREE ON THE ON
THE RECORD OF WHAT- WHAT THIS
WILL MEAN HOPEFULLY- AND TO
REACH SEVERAL THOUSAND A YOUNG
PEOPLE IT'S THE A VERY VERY
POSITIVE PROGRAM AND IT'S ALSO
VERY TANGIBLE TO. TO THOSE
YOUTH- SO THANK YOU DR GARCIA WE
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK AND YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY WE'RE GOING TO
HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN AND CONTINUE
TO ISSUE NINETEEN. THE SENATE
DEMOCRATS ARE PUTTING WELL TO
WORK PROPOSALS FOR A MORE
EXPANSIVE AND INCLUSIVE
APPRENTICESHIP SYSTEM. WE WILL
BEGIN WITH- MISTER ALAMO. OFFICE
AND THEN MOVE ON TO ERIC
MORRISON SMITH EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE ALLIANCE FOR
BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR. AND
CONCLUDE THE PANEL WITH ONE
EIGHT THE DOUGLAS SENIOR MANAGER
AND LABOR RELATIONS AT RISING
SUN CENTER FOR OPPORTUNITY MR
ALAMO. THANK YOU JUST DOWNLOAD
THE L. A. O. ISSUE NINETEEN YEAR
OF RELEASE TO TWO NEW
INITIATIVES FOR STATE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS- BY WAY
OF BACKGROUND- THE STATE'S.
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS OVERSEAS STATE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA HAN IN THE
DIVISION OF APPRENTICESHIP
STANDARDS IS THE SPECIFIC UNIT
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS WHO MANAGES
THIS WORKLOAD- THE SENATE BUDGET
PLAN HERE WOULD ADD TWO NEW
ELEMENTS TO- THE STATE'S
APPROACH. THE FIRST IT. WOULD BE
A NEW FOR YOU APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS ARE FOCUSED ON YOUNG
PEOPLE BETWEEN SIXTEEN AND
TWENTY FOUR WITH BARRIERS TO
EMPLOYMENT ON. THIS PROPOSAL
WOULD BE A HUNDRED AND TEN
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
ANNUALLY FOR THREE YEARS ON TO
GET THIS OFFICE UP AND RUNNING.
THE SECOND COMPONENT OF THE
SENATE PLAN IS A UNIT- FOR WOMEN
IN CONSTRUCTION PRIORITY- WHICH
WOULD ESSENCE FOCUS ON
ESTABLISHING A LARGER SHARE OF
THE OVERALL CONSTRUCTION
APPRENTICESHIP WORK FORCE-
REPRESENTED BY WOMEN ON AS YOU
KNOW- WOMEN IN THE TRADES. WOMEN
REPRESENT A VERY SMALL NUMBER OF
WORKERS IN THE TRADES AND ALSO A
VERY SMALL SHARE OF WORKERS AND
THE TRADE APPRENTICESHIP GRANTS-
AND SO THIS UNIT WHICH WOULD BE
DEVELOPED- TO CREATE THOSE RATES
FUNDING FOR THAT WOMEN IN
CONSTRUCTION PRIORITY. IN
MILLION DOLLAR. ON GOING- HE'S
TO COMPLY ARE ISSUED ID. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH HOW DID BUT
TURNING NOW TO PEOPLE'S. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- WE WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO MISTER MORRISON SMITH. ALL
RIGHT- GOOD MORNING JERRY
MEMBERS- MY NAME IS ERIC MORE
SINCE MIX ACTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
THE ALLIANCE OF BOYS MEN OF
COLOR AB MOC I'M HERE-
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THE
LEGISLATURE TO APPROVE FUNDING
REQUEST FOR A THREE HUNDRED
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS TO
ESTABLISH THE CALIFORNIA I
SHOULD PROGRAM AS OUTLINED IN
THE ANALYSIS- AB MOSTLY IS A
NETWORK OF TWO HUNDRED
ORGANIZATIONS WORKING. I'M SORRY
. THERE IS A COMMUNITIES WHERE
TO LEAVE BUDGET OF WITH K.
OPPORTUNITY YOUTH NETWORK AND
USE WILL. YOUNG PEOPLE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA ARE NEEDED AT
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES AND
CAREERS THAT LEAD TO SELF
SUFFICIENCY. AT THE SAME TIME
CALIFORNIA IS ALSO DEALING WITH
THE AGING WORKFORCE WHICH MEANS
WHATEVER RISK OF LOSING DECADES
OF EXPERIENCE IMPORTANT FACTORS
. WE KNOW THAT PRE
APPRENTICESHIP AND
APPRENTICESHIP START PROVEN
APPROACH TO BOTH TRANSFERRING
KNOWLEDGE AND SKILLS AND
EXPERIENCE WORKERS IN YOUR
WORKERS WHILE ALSO ENSURING
PEOPLE ARE GETTING PAID TO LEARN
AND STILL HIGH SALARY HIGH
DEMAND POSITIONS. THERE ARE
CRITICAL FOR COMMUNITIES AND
ECONOMY. GIVEN THAT THE AVERAGE
AGE OF THE PRINCES IN
CALIFORNIA'S THIRTY THREE AND
RISING. THIS INVESTMENT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA TO PRESSURE PROGRAM
WILL HELP OUR STATE GO STRONG
YOU CAN POINT ME IN FOR
STRUCTURE AND IT PASSED WITH THE
HELP MORE YOUNG PEOPLE
ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN
DISCONNECTED FROM OPPORTUNITY-
FROM YOU THE PRACTICE THE PRE
APPRENTICE AND APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS TO GOOD CAREERS. AS A
THREE HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION OF
YOUR USED FOR OVER THREE YEARS
THE SET UP THE NECESSARY PROGRAM
FRAMEWORK AND PROVIDE CRUCIAL
RESOURCES. THIS INCLUDES ONE
ESTABLISHING CALIFORNIA
DEPENDENCE OF OFFICE WHICH WILL
BY COHESIVE FLEXIBLE IN
COORDINATED STATEWIDE FRAMEWORK
AND STRATEGY. TO HELP INSURE
YOU'LL HAVE DISTRICTS AREN'T
ALIGNMENT WITH APPRENTICESHIP
STANDARDS BEEN INDUSTRY NEEDS.
TO PROVIDING GRANTS NOT ONLY YOU
UPGRADE YOU PILOT PROGRAMS. TO
HELP BOLSTER EXIT. SHIPCENTER
PARENTAGE JUST. CAN REPLICATE
AND SCALE. SUCCESSFUL MODELS.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPENDS UPON AND
ALSO X. GRANTS WORDS%
APPRENTICESHIP AND PRE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS THAT
EXPAND APPRENTICESHIPS LOTS
SPECIFICALLY FOR USING BASE
PAIRS OF PARTICIPATION IN THE
LABOR FORCE AND ACADEMIC
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS. THESE GRANTS
OF THE SENATE ON PARTNERSHIPS
WITH COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE A SOLITARY
IMPACTED SUPPORT USE. WE'RE
DISCONNECTED A MARGINALIZED USED
A COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATION
BY THE CENTRAL ROLE MISTER
MEANINGFUL RELATIONSHIP WITH YOU
PROVIDE WRAPAROUND COMMON FORM
SUPPORT SERVICES AND SERVE AS A
BRIDGE BETWEEN YOU. CARE GIVERS
INDUSTRY. AND OTHER K. A KEY
STAKEHOLDERS. LASTLY THE WILL
ALSO SUPPORT ASSISTANCE
OVERSIGHT ACCOUNTABILITY CROSS
AGENCY COORDINATION FOR INVOLVED
STATE AGENCIES. THIS TYPE OF
PROGRAM IS WORKING OTHER STATES
AND IS ALIGNED WITH AND SUPPORTS
THE GOVERNOR'S GOAL OF FIVE
THOUSAND FRANCS SEIZED BY TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY NINE. CALIFORNIA
HAS THE OPPORTUNITY TO SUPPORT
YOUNG PEOPLE FOR THE SOME
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE WHOLE
INVESTMENT. COORDINATED
STATEWIDE HOLDER ENGAGEMENT AND
A FIRM COMMITMENT TO
ESTABLISHING THE TYPE OF PROGRAM
THAT ARE USED IN STATE MEET. THE
CALIFORNIA DIVISION PROGRAM WILL
HELP OUR STATE BUILD THE
WORKFORCE INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDED
TO CREATE AN EXTRA AND THRIVING
ECONOMY. COOPER DISSIPATE AND
PROSPER AND ON BEHALF OF THE
MORE THAN TWENTY ORGANIZATIONS
SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF WE WANT TO MOVE ON
NOW TO OF ONE EITHER DOUGLAS
PLEASE. MORNING EVERYONE REALLY
LIKES IT THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME THIS OPPORTUNITY. DO YOU
CONSTRUCTION TRADES PROVIDE
SUBSTANTIAL ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES UP WORK SOCIAL
MOBILITY FOR WOMEN IN THE UNDER
REPRESENTED COMMUNITY. THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY HAS ONE OF
THE SMALLEST PAY GAPS BETWEEN
WOMEN AND MEN. WITH WOMEN
EARNING ON AN AVERAGE OF NINETY
. NINE POINT ONE SENT TO EVERY
DOLLAR COMPARED TO ME. DESPITE
WOMEN MAKING UP 2407% OF THE
TOTAL EMPLOYMENT IN THE U. S.
ONLY TEN POINT THREE. PERCENT
ARE REPRESENTED IN THE NATION
WIDE CONSTRUCTION WORK FORCE
ACCORDING TO THE U. S. BUREAU OF
LABOR STATISTICS. FARTHER ONLY
324% OF WOMEN WERE HIGH PAYING
FIELD JOB. WITH MOST WOMEN IN
THE TRADES PLACED IN OFFICE
POSITIONS REINFORCING OUTDATED
IDEAS THEY CANNOT HANDLE THE
PHYSICAL DEMANDS OF THE TRADE.
BUT PERCENTAGE OF WOMEN IN THE
FIELD OF RAISING DUE IN PART TO
TRAILBLAZERS PAVING THE WAY FOR
THE NEXT GENERATION OF WOMEN IN
CONSTRUCTION. HELLO MY NAME IS
JUANITA I WAS ONE OF THE ONLY
WOMEN IN THE TRENCHES WHEN I
JOIN THE CONSTRUCTION TRADE AS A
CARPENTER APPRENTICE IN NINETEEN
. I JOIN THE CONSTRUCTION TRADE
AS A CARPENTER APPRENTICE IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE I WORKED
AS A COMMERCIAL CARPENTER FOR
SIXTEEN YEARS. ADD A LAND
SURVEYOR FOR ANOTHER FIFTEEN. AS
A SINGLE MOTHER. I INTO THE TREE
TO PROVIDE FOR MY SON AND GIVE
US A STABILIZE. BECAUSE OF THE
STRUCTURE OF THE UNION TRADES I
WAS ABLE TO SEND MY CHILD OFF TO
A FOUR YEAR COLLEGE DEBT FREE.
THIS WAS THE MOST REWARDING
EXPERIENCE. L. A. CATALYST TO
SHARE MY TESTIMONY AND TO
ENCOURAGE MY COMMUNITY TO
UNDERSTAND THAT UNION
CONSTRUCTION CAREERS OR A
PATHWAY TO BECOME STABLE AND
FINANCIAL INDEPENDENCE. MY
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT CALIFORNIA
HAS A NEW FIVE YEAR
INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN GUARANTEED
FUNDING IN VARIOUS SECTORS OF
THE STATE THIS MEANS JOBS JOBS
WOMEN JOBS FOR YOU ESPECIALLY
JOBS RESIDENTS TO WORK. ON THE
LOCAL PROJECTS UNDERWAY NOW WHAT
I DO EVERY DAY. I TEACH THE PRE
APPRENTICE CONSTRUCTION TRAINING
PROGRAM. ON MAY SIX I GRADUATED
THIRTEEN WHEN. THIS IS MY NINTH
CLASS THREE OF THE CLASSES HAVE
BEEN WOMEN THE FIRST CLASS WE
GRADUATED FOURTEEN WOMEN. ALL
WOMEN COLD WAR SECOND CLASS I
GRADUATED TWENTY FIVE WOMEN ALL
WOMEN FOR. EVERY ONE OF THESE
NINE CLASSES. ALL THE CLASSES
HAVE BEEN 50% PLUS WOMEN. ALL
BUT ONE AND ONLY HALF THREE THE
CLASS I GRADUATED IN DECEMBER.
IN WOMEN AND FOUR MEN. I AM HERE
TO INSPIRE YOU ON THE IMPORTANCE
OF NOT ONLY JOINING THE
CONSTRUCTION TRADES BUT ALSO
SUPPORTING PATHWAYS FOR THE NEXT
GENERATION ENTERING THE TREE.
MAKING SPACE FOR MORE WOMEN FROM
ALL BACKGROUNDS PARTICULARLY LOW
INCOME SINGLE MOTHERS OF COLOR
NOW IS THE TIME ESPECIALLY IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO
ACTIVELY RECRUIT AND STAND
BEHIND BILLS ARE COMING THIS WAY
TO SUPPORT THAT VERY CALL. WITH
THIS PROGRAM. WHEN WE GRADUATE
WE WORK WITH THEM ANOTHER YEAR
TO PLACE THEM IN CONSTRUCTION
TRADES NOW THIS CLASS I JUST
GRADUATED I HAVE A YOUNG LADY
THAT JUST ENTERED THE PLUMBERS.
YESTERDAY I HAVE THREE YOUNG
LADIES THAT WILL GO DIRECTLY TO
THE LABORS I HAVE THREE YOUNG
LADIES THAT JUST PASSED THE
SURVEY. SO I KNOW IT'S POSSIBLE
WE JUST NEED MORE HELP THANK YOU
. THANK YOU MISTER GLASS I THINK
IF I HAD HEARD YOU. OF WHEN I
WAS MUCH YOUNGER AND DECIDING
WHAT TO DO IN MY LIFE I THINK I
WOULD HAVE GONE INTO ONE OF THE
TRAITS. IT YEAH I'VE GOTTA ADMIT
MANAGER IT IS NEVER TOO LATE.
YOU CAN YOU ARE TERM LIMITED I
WOULD POINT OUT SHE- USED TO
THINKING ABOUT THAT RIGHTNOW.
WELL YOU- THANK YOU SO MUCH-
THANK YOU FOR. YOUR TESTIMONY
BECAUSE YOU NOT ONLY DESCRIBED
THE PROGRAM BUT YOU DESCRIBE
REALLY DAY TO DAY- WHAT YOU DO
AND HOW YOU ARE STEP BY STEP
YEAH THERE'S A- THERE'S A HERO
OF MINE SAYS I CHÁVEZ USED TO
SAY IT'S ONE BY ONE. ONE AND A
LOT OF PEOPLE THINK ALL
EVERYTHING'S DONE IN BIG NUMBERS
BUT ONE BY ONE BY ONE IS WHAT
ADDS UP TO MAKE A HUGE
DIFFERENCE IN OUR COMMUNITIES SO
YOU'VE A YOU'VE ADDED A WHOLE
NEW LEVEL OF EXCITEMENT AND
ENTHUSIASM FOR ME- I'VE BEEN
FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO KNOW- AND BE
WITH WOMEN IN THE TRADES THAT IS
NOT TRUE. HELLO OF WOMEN IN
NONTRADITIONAL TRADE- CAREERS
AND EXTRAORDINARY JUST AS
OBVIOUSLY JUST AS EXTRAORDINARY
AS THE MAN- AND TO SEE THEM AND
THE DIVERSE TRADES IS VERY
EXCITING AT THE TO SEE THAT YOUR
EXPERIENCE- CAN I JUST ASK YOU
ONE QUESTION WHAT WHAT DO YOU
FIND. THE SINGLE OR WHATEVER ONE
OR TWO BIGGEST ISSUES THAT WOMEN
THEMSELVES FACE. AS THEY DECIDE
TO ENTER INTO THESE CAREERS
HEALTHCARE. MMHM THAT'S THE
NUMBER ONE PROBLEM BECAUSE OF
THE HOURS THAT YOU WORK IN
CONSTRUCTION I WOULD HAVE TO
REALLY TAKE MY SON TO FRESNO AND
DROP HIM OFF AT MY MOTHER'S.
BECAUSE THE CONSTRUCTION TRADES
USUALLY START AT SIX AM OR SEVEN
AM AND THERE'S- NO ONE THAT
OPENS OF CHILD CARE EARLY ENOUGH
. AND WHEN YOU HAVE TO WORK
OVERTIME IT'S USUALLY LIKE YOU
GETTING READY TO GO HOME AT
THREE PM AND IT'S LIKE OH NO NO
NO YOU GOT TO SAY THAT
AFTERWARDS SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN
HOURS A DAY. AND YOU CAN'T JUST
CALL YOUR CHILD CARE PROVIDER
AND TELL THEM I CAN'T COME UNTIL
NINETY NINE PM WBB OFF IT FOR
RIGHT. THE CHILD HERE WAS THE
BIGGEST. THE MOST BIGGEST ISSUE
OKAY GREAT WELL WE'LL HAVE TO
TAKE THAT UP WE HAVE A WE HAVE A
VERY SUCCESSFUL CAMPAIGN TO
INCREASE NOT ONLY THE SLOTS FOR
CHILD CARE BUT I THINK TAKING
THAT INTO CONSIDERATION WE
SHOULD CONNECTED. WITH THIS
PROGRAM OF WOMEN'S- OF
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM OF.
SENATORS ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. NO GOOD OKAY WELL
THANK YOU BOTH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR MORRISON SMITH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISS DOUGLAS- WE CAN
DO ALL WE CAN TO GET THE
RESOURCES OUT THERE FOR THESE
PROGRAMS AND MAKE SURE THEY
REACH OUR COMMUNITY. THANK YOU-
WE'RE GOING TO HOLD THIS OPEN
AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE TWENTY. OF
THIS ISN'T OVERSIGHT ALL ITEM
THAT ALSO INCLUDES A PROPOSAL.
IN THE SENATE DEMOCRATS PUTTING
WELL TO WORK PLAN FOR THIS PANEL
WE HAVE THE END UP PAYING AND
JOSH IVERSON FROM OF THE
DIVISION OF INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS
DIR MARIO GET RATTLED FROM CAL
H. R. CHASE ALAMO FROM DELEO AND
TIA COONS- FROM THE LEGAL AND
POLICY RESEARCH MANAGER AT THE
UCLA LABOR CENTER. OF LET'S SEE-
WE WILL HAVE A WHOLE WE HAVE
FIRST I THINK SHOULD WE START
WITH MR- ALAMO. MADAM CHAIR
SHOWS ALTHOUGH IT THAT
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST OFFICE- AS
AN INFORMATIONAL ITEM I WOULD
DEFER TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS TO STRIP
PERCENT OVERALL TOPIC AND MAYBE
ADDRESS. SOME OF THE QUESTIONS
IN THE AGENDA- HAPPY RIGHT
CONTEXT TO WORK WITH STAFF ON
HOLD. OKAY SO WE HAVE AGAIN THE
PAYING AND JOSH IVERSON WHICH OF
YOU WOULD CARE TO SPEAK FIRST.
HEY I GOOD MORNING JACK PAYNE
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE
DEPARTMENT DUST RELATIONS I'M
HAPPY TO START OFF OF THAT WOULD
BE OKAY WITH THE CHAIR. YES GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU AND GOOD
MORNING THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY. HI AGAIN DEANNA
PAYING WITH DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS. AND SO
JUST. TO QUICKLY PROVIDE SOME.
RELEVANT CONTEXT SOMEWHERE
DIARIAS TODAY COMPARED TO ALMOST
THREE YEARS AGO IN TERMS OF OUR
HIRING SO I AM ABLE TWENTY
NINETEEN DR LOST ITS HIRING
DELEGATION. FOR ALL CIVIL
SERVICE APPOINTMENTS AND
UNDERWENT A HIRING FREEZE FOR
ALMOST SIX MONTHS. THAT YEAR THE
DEPARTMENT MADE TWENTY
APPOINTMENTS. IN TWENTY TWENTY
THE I. ARE MADE TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY TWO APPOINTMENTS AND IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THE I. R.
REGAINED ITS HIRING AUTHORITIES
AND WE MADE SEVEN HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE APPOINTMENTS THAT'S A
210050% INCREASE. FROM THE
PREVIOUS YEAR AND WE ACTUALLY
ALSO LOOKED AT OUR PROGRESS. SO
FAR IN TWENTY TWENTY TWO THROUGH
APRIL AND SO FAR WE EACH YEAR
AND FORTY THREE. CENTS WHICH
ACTUALLY PUTS US ON TRACK TO
SURPASS OUR NUMBERS FROM LAST
YEAR. SO I SAW IN THAT COMMITTEE
AND I WAS THERE. IN THE BOX OUR. DEPARTMENTS RECALL. HI AND
RETENTION. AND SO TO SHARE HE
ABOUT OUR STRATEGY IS THROUGH
THE- IN EXPANDING. OF AND
INFORMATION ALONG WITH
CONTINUOUS LEARNING AND PROCESS
IMPROVEMENT AND IF I MAY I JUST
TAKE A MOMENT TO ALSO TAKE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ACKNOWLEDGE OUR
DEDICATED TEAM MEMBERS ACROSS
OUR DEPARTMENT. BEEN
INSTRUMENTAL IN THIS
CONSIDERABLE PROGRESS AS WE'VE-
THAT WE'VE MADE ON FILLING OUR
VACANCIES AND IF THE CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS LOOK LIKE
HAPPY TO GO IN MORE DETAIL.
ABOUT OUR HIRING AND RECRUITMENT
AND RETENTION STRATEGY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH IS BEING MISTER I
RESCIND DO YOU WANT TO. MAKING
ARGUMENTS. NO THANK YOU. OKAY
OKAY- HOW ABOUT MISTER GET
RATTLED FROM CAL HR. OKAY HERE
YOU WE CAN'T. I HAVE TO START
AGAIN. NEWS THE. OKAY ARE VERY
VERY HIGHLY TRAINED IT PERSONNEL. CAN'T HEAR YOU YET MISTER
GATHERED ON. IT'S ON HIS SIDE SO
THE FOUND ISSUES WITH YOU MISTER
GET IT'LL BUT IT. IS HE ON THE
PHONE MADAM CHAIR. NO NO WE CAN
SEE WHAT WE COULD SEE HIM IF
THAT'S WHAT YOU. SHOULD CONSIDER. ALL DO YOU WANT TO LOG OUT
MISTER GET ADULT LOG OUT AND
THEN- LOG BACK IN. OR TRY A
DIFFERENT DEVICE. BUT WE CAN
HEAR YOU AT ALL WE COULD SEE YOU
BUT WE CAN'T NEARLY A WORD
YOU'RE SAYING. THE WORRIES. WITH
THE FINAL SUGGEST IN HERE. ONE
THE FIVE. COLIN AND JUST DO
AUDIO OKAY MISTER GUERRERO IF
OUT WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT PANELIST IF YOU COULD LOG
OUT LOG BACK IN ON A DIFFERENT
DEVICE OR CALL IN AND JUST DO
AUDIO. OKAY DID YOU CAN YOU WAVE
AND SAY YES YOU HEARD US. MMHM
CAN YOU HEAR IS IF YOU CAN
HEROES CAN YOU HOLD UP YOUR HAND. HELLO YOU CAN HEAR SEASON.
ASSEMBLY CHATHAM AND SOON CAN
SOMEBODY. THANKS HIM WOULD USE
THE ZOOM CHAT. ASSEMBLY TEXAN
PLEASE AND COMMUNICATE THEIR
OKAY I'M SORRY WE'RE GONNA CUT
YOU OUT- MISTER GET IT ALL AND
PUT ON MISS GOONS. I'M HERE CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES YOU'RE FINE I
THANK GOD WE WALKED ON THE MOON
BUT WE STILL CANNOT MASTERS IN
TWO YEARS INTO THE PANDEMIC'S.
EARNINGS SENATORS ARE MANY
SEASONS I MANAGED LEGAL AND
POLICY RESEARCH AT B. UCLA
REVEREND JAMES LAWSON WORKER
JUSTICE CENTER THE ARTIST
FORMERLY KNOWN AS THE UCLA LABOR
CENTER. AND I'M HERE TO TALK TO
YOU TODAY ABOUT THE STATE'S ANTI
RETALIATION ENFORCEMENT.
INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH IS
RELATIVELY ARCANE SUBJECT I
NEVER ASSUME ANYBODY HAS PRE
EXISTING KNOWLEDGE LET'S GET UP
TO SPEED REALLY QUICKLY. WE ALL
KNOW CALIFORNIA BNG OF THE
NATION'S OR ARE STRONG WORKER
PROTECTION LAWS BUT RCI OUR
STATE YOUR TELL YOU SHOULD
COMPLETE INVESTIGATION UNIT. IS
OUR DEFENSE MECHANISM RIGHT
THOSE LAWS ARE ONLY AS STRONG AS
THEIR ENFORCEMENT. AND DATA SHOW
THAT WORKERS WHO ARE AFRAID OF
REPRISALS FOR SPEAKING OUT HAVE
A GOOD REASON TO E WE ARE ABOUT
TO PUBLISH- COURTESY OF THE
NATIONAL EMPLOYMENT LAW PROJECT
AB SURVEY OF OVER A THOUSAND
WORKERS STATE WHY OF ALL INCOME
LEVELS ALL ETHNICITIES THAT
SHARE THE IS WELL OVER HALF HAVE
ACTUALLY EXPERIENCED
RETALIATION. I NEARLY ALL ARE
AFRAID OF IT EVEN. THERE IF YOU
KNOW YOUR BOSS DOESN'T HAVE TO
RETALIATE IN ORDER TO KEEP YOU
IN LINE IS THAT YOUR- THAT
FUNCTIONS TO CONTROL BEHAVIOR.
THE TWO MOST COMMON FORMS OF
RETALIATION HE FIRED AND THEN
THE REST TO CALL IMMIGRATION
MAKING IMMIGRANTS AND LOW WAGE
WORKERS WHO LITERALLY CAN'T MISS
A PAYCHECK. EXTREMELY VULNERABLE
TO THE CHILLING EFFECTS OF
RETALIATION. YES DESPITE BACK
EVERY YEAR NEARLY FORTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE ARE BRAVE ENOUGH TO FILE
A COMPLAINT WITH ONE OF THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER SIXTEEN
OFFICES. STATEWIDE AT THE STATE
PARK INFRASTRUCTURE TO AND
AGAINST EMPLOYER RETALIATION IS
THE LABOR COMMISSIONER'S
RETALIATION COMPLAINT
INVESTIGATION THAT. OTHERWISE
KNOWN AS RCII. RCI AND FORCES
FORTY FIVE STATUTES THEY'RE NOT
JUST WAIT AN HOUR BUT ALSO OSHA
AND EVERY WHISTLE BLOWER STATUTE
IN THE LABOR CODE. THAT RECEIVES
JUST SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS TO DO
THAT. R. C. I PASSED COULD
REALLY COMPLAINTS AND RECEIVED
MORE THAN FIFTY THREE HUNDRED OF
THEM IN TWENTY TWENTY ALONE. AND
THAT INCLUDED THE TELEVISION FOR
ASKING FOR COLLUDED SICK LEAVE
FOR EXAMPLE THEY CAN QUITE
LITERALLY MEAN LIFE OR DEATH FOR
WORKERS. NOT SURPRISING WE ARE
SEE I HAD A BACKLOG OF NEARLY
TWO THOUSAND. CLOTHING PIECES
AND WORKERS TODAY WAIT AN
AVERAGE OF THREE HUNDRED KEYS
JUST RECEIVED WORD THAT ARE C.
EYES OPENED AN INVESTIGATION.
THE QUICKEST FIX RESIDENTS ARE
LEGISLATIVE TWEAKER ISN'T NEW
STATUTES LIKE I SAID
CALIFORNIA'S ALREADY THE ENVY OF
THE NATION FOR ITS STRONG ANTI
RETALIATION PROTECTION. BUT
SIMPLY WERE RESOURCES. RCI
OPERATING AT MAX CAPACITY IT'S
INTERVIEWING TO FILL ELEVEN
VACANCIES OUT OF A TOTAL OF
FIFTY TWO POSITIONS. AND
INVESTIGATORS ARE LAWYERS IN
THAT UNIT ACTIVELY THAT CLAIMS
FILE LAWSUITS AGAINST VIOLATORS
AND THEN RECOVER ANYTHING OVER
THE WORK ON BEHALF OF WORKERS
WHICH HERCULEAN TASK. REQUIRES.
GREATER SUPPORT. THIS DAY IN THE
NEEDS BENEFIT FROM LARGE AND OF
WORKER AND YOU KNOW YOU'RE RIGHT
AB SHINS ARE READY TO WORKERS
FILE CLAIMS TO RECOVER AND I'M
SO HAPPY TO SEE THE SENATE.
PROPOSE ONGOING SUPPORT OR SEE
WHAT THE COLLUDED WORKER
OUTREACH PROJECT.
INTERNALIZATION THINK OF THE
STATE AGENCY AS A WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PIPELINE. RIGHT I
CAN FUNNEL PEOPLE WHO EXPERIENCE
WHICH IN OUR VIOLATIONS INTO THE
AGENCY THAT INVESTIGATES AND
ENFORCES WAGE IN OUR LIVES. I'M
REALLY HAPPY TO SEE THIS BODY
EXPLORING HIRING BACKLOGS AND-
YOURS. AS ANY OF US IN THIS
FIELD KNOWS OF NUMEROUS EXAMPLES
OF REALLY WELL QUALIFIED
APPLICANTS WHO COME FROM SOME OF
THESE COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS.
BEING DENIED- THEIR APPLICATION
PLANET. I'M REALLY HAPPY ANSWER
QUESTIONS AND HERE'S HOPING THAT
MY COLLEAGUE OF MONEY OKAY I
DON'T CAN GET ON. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF. THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
. MISS COONS OF MISTER GET
RATTLED ARE YOU BACK IN EITHER
AUDIO OR BOTH VIDEO. NOPE. IS
THERE. BUT WE CAN HEAR YOU.
MR GUERRERO.
MISTER MISTER GET OUT OF COULD
YOU COULD IF SOMEBODY CAN
SOMEBODY IN TOUCH WITH HIM. OKAY
COULD YOU ASK HIM TO OF COLIN OR
HE'S LOOKS LIKE HE'S CALLING IN
. TO CALL IT. OKAY IS I MEAN
THROUGH THE MODERATOR OKAY. OKAY
Q. WE GO. HELLO MR GUERREIRO.
MISTER MODERATOR MS MODERATOR I
GOT A CALL. MISTER GUERRERO
LEVINE. MADAM CHAIR CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES I CAN HEAR YOU. WHO ARE
YOU WHAT SPEAKER ARE YOU LOOKING
FOR MARIO GUERRERO. I DO NOT SEE
OF ONE CONNECTED NOT ON. WELL
HIS NAME IS ON ARE VERY VIDEO
SCREEN. OKAY THAT'S PROBABLY
CONNECTED WITH YOUR ZOOM THEN
BUT NOT ON THE PHONE LINE. HE IS
NOT CONNECTED AS THE SPEAKER.
HE'S. I ABOUT DIED I. BUT IF YOU
SEE HIM ON THE SCREEN IT'S
PROBABLY YEAR- WEB CONNECTION
THERE. EIGHT OKAY I'LL THEN WILL
I LET YOU KNOW OKAY- WE'RE GOING
TO UNFORTUNATELY SKIP PM UNLESS
AND UNTIL WE CAN GET HIM BACK ON
AND- WE COULDN'T GO ON TO A D.
I. R. AND THEN- THE LSE AND DEAL
ESTATE. SO WE'LL START WITH A
DIR- AND I HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS
THAT- MISS. WHO WILL BE SPEAKING
FOR. OKAY MISTING UP OR MISTER
IVERSON- OKAY- COULD YOU GO
THROUGH AND- I APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS- AND DOUG TELL ME HOW
MANY VACANCIES THERE ARE AT THE
I. R. TODAY I AM AND THANK YOU
FOR HIGHLIGHTING THE PROGRESS
THAT WAS MADE OF ESPECIALLY
SINCE THE ADA AUTHORITY WAS.
READ DELEGATED OF WHAT IS THE
WHAT IS THE NUMBER OF VACANCIES
VACANCIES THAT EXIST TODAY
WHAT'S YOUR VACANCY RATE OF PER
DIVISION. OF AN OVERALL I THINK
YOU MENTIONED THIS WHAT IS YOUR
RECRUITMENT AND- AND ESPECIALLY
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION
STRATEGY. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION. THANK YOU CAN I PAINT
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS SO. CURRENTLY DIR HAS
NINE HUNDRED AND FORTY FOUR
BANQUETTE BACON POSITIONS OUT OF
THREE THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY ONE WHICH IS THAT
VACANCY RATE OF APPROXIMATELY
TWENTY SEVEN PERCENT. I AND I'M
GONNA JUST GO BY DIVISION AS I
WAS WHAT WAS REQUESTED SO. FOR
THE DIVISION OF APPRENTICESHIP
STANDARDS THERE'S THIRTY SEVEN
POSITIONS VACANT. I WHICH IS A
32% BACON C. RATES LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE IS TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY NINE POSITIONS
VACANT. WHICH IS A THIRTY TWO
POINT. ZERO WELL HELLO. HOUSE
TWO HUNDRED FORTY TWO POSITIONS
VACANT WHICH IS A 30% VACANCY
RATE AND THEN THE DIVISION OF
WORKERS COMPENSATION HAS TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY TWO POSITIONS
VACANT WHICH IS A 23% VACANCY
RATE. I WOULD LIKE IF I MAY
PROVIDE SOME ADDITIONAL CONTEXT
IN RELATION TO THESE POSITIONS
THAT MIGHT BE HELPFUL FOR THE
COMMITTEE. TO START THAT THE
VACANT POSITION FIGURE ALSO
INCLUDES ABOUT A HUNDRED NINETY
SIX POINT FIVE NEW POSITION.
ALLOCATED TO THE DEPARTMENT AND
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL FROM
PREVIOUS YEARS IT'S HARD TO PUT
THAT AN ADDITIONAL CONTACTS THAT
MEANS THOSE NEW POSITIONS MAKE
UP ABOUT TWENTY ONE PERCENT. OF
THE BACON POSITIONS THAT I JUST
REFERENCED. I WOULD ALSO JUST
LIKE TO NOTE AS WELL THAT LIKE
MANY DEPARTMENTS SOME OF OUR
HIRES ARE INTERNAL TRANSFERS OR
PROMOTIONS WHICH AREN'T
REFLECTED. IN VACANCY RATE BUT
WE DO THINK IT REPRESENTS AN
IMPORTANT MOBILITY OPPORTUNITY
FOR THE MEMBERS OF OUR TEAM.
I'VE AND IF AND I CAN PAUSE
THERE BUT THEN I CAME WARRANT.
HIRING AND RETENTION STRATEGY IF
THE COMMITTEE WOULD LIKE. YES
PLEASE COULD YOU. YES THANK YOU
THE CLIP. SO IN TERMS OF OUR FOR
HIRE. RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION
STRATEGY SO FOR HIRING WE DO IT
IS VITAL TO ENSURE THAT OUR
HIRING MANAGERS HAVE THE TOOLS
AND INFORMATION THEY NEED. TO
ASSIST THEM IN THE HIRING
PROCESS AS WELL AS ENSURE THAT
OUR RECRUITMENT FOLLOW THE MERIT
BASED HIRING SYSTEM AND SO JUST
TO PROVIDE SOME CONCRETE
EXAMPLES FOR THE COMMITTEE IN
CASE IT'S HELPFUL OF WHAT THAT
LOOKS LIKE. WE'VE TRAINED ALL OF
OUR HIRING MANAGERS AND
SUPERVISORS ON COLLEGE OUR
HIRING PRACTICES. WE'VE
DEVELOPED AND DISTRIBUTED I TOOL
KIT OF RESOURCES AND JOB AIDS
FOR OUR TEAM MEMBERS THAT ARE
INVOLVED IN HIRING TWO ASSISTANT
THINGS LIKE DROPPING DUTY
STATEMENTS. INTERVIEW QUESTIONS
AND ALSO HELP ENSURING THE
COMPLETION OF HIRING PACKAGES.
AND THEN WE'VE ALSO IMPLEMENTED
STRATEGIES THAT CAN HELP
FACILITATE MORE HIRING AT SCALE
I AND SO THIS CAN INCLUDE FOR
EXAMPLE INTERVIEWING LARGER
POOLS OF CANDIDATES AND MAKING
MULTIPLE HIRES WHEN WE HAVE.
OPENINGS FOR THE SAME
CLASSIFICATION TRENDS THE FOR
EXAMPLE WE HAD ONE DIVISION
RECENTLY DO THIS WHERE THEY
INTERVIEWED OVER FIFTY
CANDIDATES AND WERE ABLE TO SELL
SIXTEEN LEGAL POSITIONS. ARE ON
ON THE RECRUITMENT SIDE WE'VE
EXPANDED OUR EFFORTS TO MEET
PROSPECTIVE CANDIDATES WHERE
THEY ARE SO THAT THEY CAN LEARN
. OPPORTUNITY WE ACTUALLY ONE-
THE I. R. DOT CA DOT GOV SLASH
DIR JOBS AND THIS WEBSITE IN A
WAY IS A ONE STOP SHOP FOR DIR
EMPLOYMENT INFORMATION SO THIS
INCLUDES INFORMATIONAL VIDEOS
ABOUT OUR DEPARTMENT HIGHLIGHTS
OF CERTAIN JOB CLASSIFICATIONS
WE ALSO GIVE YOU SOME GUIDANCE
TO APPLICANTS REGARDING THAT
STATE HIRING PROCESS BENEFITS
FOR WORKING FOR US AND THEN ALSO
JUST DIFFERENT HIRING EVENTS
THAT WE HAVE. AND I HAVE FOR
EXAMPLE WE'VE ALSO EXPANDED OUR
REACH THROUGH IN PERSON AND
ONLINE CAREER FAIRS SO OVER THE
LAST SIX MONTHS WE'VE HELD
SEVERAL VIRTUAL CAREER FAIRS FOR
CALLOW SHOT THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE AND ALSO
THE DIVISION APPRENTICESHIP
STANDARDS WHICH HAS ALLOWED US
TO CONNECT WITH HUNDREDS OF
CANDIDATES TO THE MORE TAX ALL
WORK OUT WE DO AS WELL AS THE
STATE HIRING PROCESS AN
INTERVIEW YES. AND ALSO IN AND
TRY TO IMPROVE ACCESS IS. WE ARE
YOUR TIES TO MAKING EXAMS MARC
SENSIBLE THROUGH AUTOMATION AND
BEING ONLINE SO PREVIOUSLY MANY
OF THE I. R. AS EXAMS WERE PAPER
BASED TODAY MANY POTENTIAL
APPLICANTS CAN QUALIFY ONLINE.
FOR SOME OF OUR ESPECIALLY HIGH
PRIORITY OF POSITIONS SUCH AS
THE DEPUTY LABOUR COMMISSIONER.
INDUSTRIAL HYGIENIST AND SAFETY
ENGINEERS WHICH MAKE THE
QUALIFICATION PROCESS A BIT MORE
ACCESSIBLE AND EFFICIENT. HI AND
LASTLY WE'VE REALLY BEEN
EXPANDING OUR USE OF ONLINE
ADVERTISEMENT TO DRIVE
ENGAGEMENT WITH OUR JOB POSTINGS
ON RECRUITMENT SITE.
ADMINISTRATION AS WELL AS YOUR
TO TRY AND BROADEN OUR CANDIDATE
POOL I AND THEN JUST LASTLY ON
ON THE RETENTION SIDE I JUST
LIKE TO SAY IN MY LAST TWO YEARS
HERE WITH THE DEPARTMENT I'VE
JUST BEEN CONTINUES INSPIRED BY
THE TEAMS THAT WE HAVE IN THIS
DEPARTMENT WHO DAY TO DAY AFTER
DAY CONTINUE TO HELP US MOVE
FORWARD OUR MISSION AND SO IT'S
FOR THAT REASON THAT WE'VE
IMPLEMENTED A STRATEGY TO HELP
WITH THE RETENTION OF OUR
EXISTING I TEAM THAT INCLUDES
THE REESTABLISHMENT OF SUPERIOR
ACCOMPLISHMENT AWARDS. I HAD TO
RECOGNIZE THE CONTRIBUTIONS OF
OUR TEAM MEMBERS ACROSS THE
DEPARTMENT WE ALSO THIS IS WHY
WE'RE PRIORITIZING THE FILLING
OF VACANCIES TO HELP ALLEVIATE
THE WORKLOAD ON THE EXISTING
TEAMS AND THEN ALSO PROMOTING
MOBILITY TRAINING OPPORTUNITIES
AS WELL AS DEPARTMENT Y. JOB
OPPORTUNITIES TO ENCOURAGE
CONTINUED GROWTH AND DEVELOPMENT
WITHIN OUR DEPARTMENT. TURNED
OFF. HEY I GUESS I'M NOT MOVING
TO MASS. OKAY ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU- THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS
COLLINS THE MANAGER YES.
MARLBORO I APOLOGIZE FOR THE
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES I'M HAPPY
TO SPEAK THAT YOU'D LIKE BECAUSE
YES GO AHEAD. WELL GOOD MORNING-
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
WITH YOU TODAY MY NAME IS MARIO
BETTER ON ON THE LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
HUMAN RESOURCES KELLY CHAR.
OCULTAR IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
ISSUES RELATED TO RECRUITMENT
SELECTION TOLERATE BENEFITS AND
POSITION CLASSIFICATIONS. AS
WELL TO PROVIDE A VARIETY OF
RAINY- TRAINING AND CONSULTATION
SERVICES THE STATE DEPARTMENT
AND LOCAL AGENCY. ON THIS ISSUE
COLLEGE ARE WITH NO HIRING
SOMEONE CHALLENGE NATIONWIDE IN
BOTH PUBLIC AND PRIVATE SECTORS
IN LARGE PART DUE TO A COVER
NINETEEN PANDEMIC SOME PEOPLE OF
LEFT THE WORK FORCE AND OTHERS-
HAVE RETIRED. HOW IT STARTS
TRACKING DATA CLOSELY TO
IDENTIFY TRENDS AND THE STATE
DEPARTMENT WE HOPE THAT MANY OF
OUR PC'S HE'S THE BEST LATER
TODAY UNDER ISSUE TWENTY ONE.
WELL ASSIST. IN THIS AREA. WE
WERE ALSO AFTER A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS. MADAM CHAIR
REGARDING- COLLEGE DEGREE- AND
OTHERS YOU DON'T HAVE TO DO
GOING FROM HAPPY TO WAIT- TO SEE
IF. THERE ARE ANY QUESTIONS. NO
ONE TO TOUCH ON THE- AND RESPOND
TO THOSE QUESTIONS. SURE TO THE
QUESTION OF WHAT IT COLLEAGUES
ARE DOING TO REVIEW DEGREE
REQUIREMENT FOR STATE HIRING
WHEN KELLY JOHN LOOKS AT JOB
APPLICATIONS FOR MINIMUM
QUALIFICATION UPDATE WE WORK
WITH DEPARTMENTS TO DETERMINE
WHAT REQUIREMENTS ARE TRULY JOB
RELATED. AND LEAD TO SUCCESS IN
THE CLASS I THINK TWENTY
FOURTEEN COUNTY CHARTER AN
ENGAGED IN A NUMBER OF PRODUCTS
THAT NOT. MINIMUM QUALIFICATION
WHERE YOU HAVE FOUND THAT THE
EXISTING MINIMUM QUALIFICATIONS
OF A FIVE CREATED ARTIFICIAL
BARRIERS TO ENTRY ARTICULAR ONLY. RELATED TO GREEN REQUIRE- THE
STATE FACES REACH OUT THAT ARE
OF. SECTORS ESPECIALLY THAT WERE
SPECIALIZED EDUCATION. KNOWLEDGE
OUR REVIEWS DEPARTMENTAL
REQUIRED TO RE EVALUATE EXISTING
MINIMUMQUALIFICATION WHENEVER A
DEPARTMENT PROVIDE CALORIE CHART
DATA TO INDICATE THANK YOU ARE A
POTENTIAL BARRIER- THE HIRING.
THAT IS A- THE END OF MY
COMMENTS MANAGER AND ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU OR THE COMMITTEE
MAY HAVE. SENDER COURTESY WANT
TO GO AHEAD AND ASK- THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR IN IN I JUST WANT TO
KNOW AND I'M VERY APPRECIATIVE
OF- THE SENATE'S. YOU KNOW
SPENDING PLANNER PROPOSAL
RELATIVE TO AUG BIDDING- EFFORTS
IN THIS AREA- JUST A QUESTION
FOR MISS PAYING HIS. WHAT IS
THE- OR OR MISTER GROW AND
MATURE. BUT DISTINGUISHED
TALKING QUITE A BIT ABOUT
RETENTION WHAT IS THE CHIEF
OBSTACLE OR- M. NOT SURE THE
RIGHT WORD IT'S PROBABLY NOT
COMPETITOR BUT THE CHIEF
COUNTERPOINT TO RETENTION RIGHT
NOW- BESIDES JUST. YOU KNOW
EFFORT IN AND PROMOTION AND ALL
THOSE THINGS THAT WE DO AND
WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT-
YOU KNOW PEOPLE ARE FEELING
VALUED IN THE ORGANIZATION ARE
THERE ARE THERE ARE OUTSIDE
FORCES THAT- JUST MAKING IT.
MORE DIFFICULT- PERHAPS A WHAT I
HEARD- MAYBE SPOKE ABOUT THAT
AND IT WENT OVER MY HEAD. SENATE
DEMOCRATS ARE DEPARTMENT
INVESTOR RELATIONS I'M HAPPY TO
TOUCH ON THAT AND THEN MY
COLLEAGUE I COLLEGE ARM MAY
WANT. TO ADD A BIT MORE ON THE
TREND THAT. THEY'RE SEEN ACROSS
THAT. DEPARTMENT BUT JUST IN
TERMS OF THE QUESTION ON. WHAT
WE'RE NOTICING WITH RESPECT TO
RETENTION I IT'S SOMETHING
THAT'S JUST NOT UNIQUE TO OUR
DEPARTMENT I THINK IT'S HOPPING
ACROSS STATE GOVERNMENT AND ALSO
JUST HAPPENING ACROSS FOR
EMPLOYERS ACROSS THE STATE
ACROSS THE COUNTRY OF WE'RE JUST
SEEING MORE MOBILITY. AND TERMS
OF FOLKS. THAT ARE ARE MOVING IN
I'M JOBS AND SO THAT'S NOT.
STANDS BY SOMEWHERE WHAT YOU
WERE SAYING OUR OUR PRIORITY HAS
JUST BEEN WE RECOGNIZE THAT IT'S
BEEN A VERY CHALLENGING COUPLE
OF YEARS AND LIKE I MENTIONED WE
HAVE SOME. REALLY IMPRESSIVE AND
DEDICATED FOLKS WITHIN OUR
DEPARTMENT AND SO OUR PRIORITY
IS JUST TO GET. TO GET MORE HELP
THEY ALSO HELP OUR FOLKS WHO ARE
WITHIN OUR DEPARTMENT GOT
ADDITIONAL TRAINING AND
SUPPORTS. AND THEN ALSO SHOW
THEM PATHWAYS WITHIN OUR
DEPARTMENT THAT THEY CAN
CONTINUE TO LEARN AND GROW. YES
IT'S YOU KNOW WE'RE IN A IN A
BUDGET COMMITTEE HERE- IN WE
HAVE I THINK SOME OF US HAVE OUR
OWN. ON GOING TO LIVED
EXPERIENCE. WITH RETENTION
ISSUES YOU KNOW EVEN AMONG- EVEN
IN OUR DEPARTMENT ZERO EVEN
AMONG THEIR OWN. STUFF WHICH YOU
KNOW PRESSURE SEEMS TO BE OF
COURSE THE MACRO ECONOMY AND
INFLATION YOU TALK ABOUT THIS
BEING. A TREND ALL OVER- I GUESS
THE COULD THE CONCERN WOULD BE
EVEN WITH THE PROPOSALS THAT ARE
ON THE TABLE NOW IS THERE
ENOUGH. THERE TO REMAIN
COMPETITIVE. I GUESS THAT'S
PERHAPS MORE DIRECT QUESTION.
AND I'M AND I GUESS I'M IMPLYING
THAT THE LACK OF COMPETITION YOU
KNOW IN TERMS OF. FOLKS. IT IN
TERMS OF PREVENTING AN EXODUS
THAT- YOU KNOW- YOU KNOW SALARY
AND BENEFIT COMPETITION IS A
THING. I MAY HAVE TO ADD. A
DEFERRED TO MY COLLEAGUE AT
COLLEGE ARE WITHOUT QUESTION
GREAT. MISTER GOOD OTHER THAN
ARE THE ONLY- INFORMATION I
WOULD LIKE TO HEAR IS THAT STUFF
I WOULD JUST REITERATE THE CALYX
ARE- YOU KNOW THAT WE ARE SEEING
THESE ARE HIRING CHALLENGES
NATIONWIDE BOTH IN THE PUBLIC
SECTOR AS WELL AS THE PRIVATE
SECTOR- OR KELLY GEORGE PART- ON
THE HIRING PART- WE- HAVE BEEN
PROVIDING BEST HIRING PRACTICES
TRAINING FOR. HR LIAISON AND
HIRING MANAGERS- FACILITATE AND
SUPPORT AFTER PARKLAND HIRING
PROPERTIES- ON THE RETENTION-
PORTION- AS YOU MAY KNOW YOU WE
HAVE BARGAINING WITH- UNION FOR-
BENEFITS AND OTHER ISSUES. THAT
MAY IMPACT- RETENTION. YEAH WE
WOULD BE GOOD TO KNOW- MORE
SPECIFICALLY IT IN THERE I DON'T
THINK I DON'T THINK THAT DRIVES
THIS PARTICULAR. BUDGET
CONVERSATION RIGHT NOW BUT TO
NOTE- IF- YOU KNOW A COMPETITIVE
YOU KNOW CONTENT COMPETITIVE
COMPENSATION IS IN AND OF ITSELF
A NEW ISSUE I MEAN OBVIOUS
OBVIOUSLY THE PROBLEM IS- NUMBER
ONE- WE WANT PEOPLE TO FEEL
THAT- THIS IS THEIR EMPLOYER OF
CHOICE RIGHT TO FEEL VALUED IN
THERE'S A LOT THAT CAN BE DONE I
THINK THAT- WAS WAS BEING
DISCUSSED IN TERMS OF JUST.
CULTURE BUT IT'S BUT SECONDLY IF
WE'RE LOSING PEOPLE AND THAT IN
TURN IS FUELING A BACKLOG- IN
TERMS OF ABILITY TO DO
ENFORCEMENT IN THIS IS REALLY
KIND OF A DOUBLE WHAMMY IN IN MY
MIND I MEAN WE'RE WE'RE LOSING
PEOPLE THAT ARE GOOD PEOPLE TO.
OUTSIDE COMPETITION OR WHEREVER
THEY'RE GOING PERHAPS INTEREST
STATE COMPETITION- YOU KNOW
BETWEEN AGENCIES I SUPPOSE I
DON'T REALLY I DIDN'T CATCH. IT
WE'RE WE THINK FOLKS ARE GOING-
BUT WHILE THAT'S HAPPENING A
WHOLE. A WHOLE OTHER SET OF
EMPLOYEES- YOU KNOW UP AND DOWN
THE STATE WHO. ARE ARE WAITING
FOR ENFORCEMENT COMPLIANCE OR
IMPACTED SO I GUESS THIS IS TO
SAY- I THINK WE TAKE THIS VERY
SERIOUSLY AND- YOU KNOW PERHAPS
ARE IN THE POSITION TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT THAT TO MAKE
SURE- YOU KNOW THAT. THE
LEGISLATURE'S PROVIDING THE
RESOURCES TO MAKE SURE THAT-
THAT THEY CHOOSE THE DIR CAN
COMPETE- IS NOT ONLY RETAIN BUT
BUT COMPETE- SO THAT IT. I DON'T
THINK THAT REQUIRES ANY FURTHER
RESPONSE BUT- AND ONE EXPRESSED
THAT SENTIMENT- IT'S NOT A BLAME
FREE. THE A. WHY AREN'T YOU
DOING BETTER I THINK WE'RE-
WE'VE BEEN AROUND ENOUGH TO KNOW
THAT THAT SOMETIMES NO MATTER
HOW HARD YOU TRY IF YOU JUST
AREN'T COMPETITIVE- EITHER ON ON
A LATERAL OR PROMOTIONAL BASIS
THAT. IS AN ACCOMPLICE
COMPENSATORY BASIS- YOU KNOW WE
CAN HAVE A CASCADING IMPACT
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE'RE DEALING
WITH. AN AGENCY LIKE THIS
THAT'S- REALLY DIRECTLY- THE
ESSENTIALLY THE ONLY AGENCY THAT
CAN HELP FOLKS- YOU KNOW WHO ARE
BEING OPPRESSED OR TAKEN
ADVANTAGE OF OUT THERE. THANK
YOU MANAGER THANK YOU SENATOR I
DO WANT TO DIVE INTO- THE MORE
PARTICULARS HERE WITH WITH EACH
OF YOU AND- AFTER REPEAT
EVERYTHING THAT THIRTY CORTESE
FAYE- SAID BUT WE GREATLY
APPRECIATE THE WORK OF- ALL THE
ALL OF YOU THAT ALL THE CURRENT
STAFF DO IT'S CRITICAL. I'VE
BEEN A DOING THIS LABOR WORK ALL
MY LIFE AND THE ROLE OF
GOVERNMENT IS REALLY IMPORTANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT ESPECIALLY LOW
WAGE LAW LOW PAID. INDUSTRIES
WHICH IS WHERE THE MOST
EXPLOITATION TAKES PLACE SO I'M
VERY VERY CONCERNED- ABOUT THE
DIRECT IMPACT THAT THE LACK OF
HAVING A SUFFICIENT STAFF IS
HAVING ON THOSE OF LOW PAID
COMMUNITIES THOSE IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES THOSE VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES THE FACT THAT
THEY'VE BEEN THROUGH COVERT
THEY'VE BEEN HIT THE HARDEST.
THEY NEED THE MOST ATTENTION
THEY NEED THE MOST RESOURCE SO-
I KNOW- MAYBE MISTER GHETTO CAN
YOU JUST WALK ME THROUGH A SHORT
VERSION BUT FROM START TO FINISH
UP- FOR PERSON TO BE HIRED IN-
DIR. MANAGER I BELIEVE THAT THAT
QUESTION IS- THAT'S DIRECTED AT
THE I. R. WE HABITS AND LYFT
HIRING- STRUCTURE AND THE I. R.
DOES THE HIRING DIRECTLY. OKAY
NOT SO- UGH CAL HR DOESN'T HAVE
A ROLE IN THAT. IN THE HIRING.
FIVE YOU KNOW MADAM CHAIR- YEAH
THE R. HAS IT I'LL GET IT I
DURING A FORTY- THE HIRE
EMPLOYEES DIRECT THEMSELVES.
OKAY I'M HAPPY TO TAKE THAT
QUESTION MADAM CHAIR YES GO
AHEAD THANK YOU THANK YES OF
COURSE I DEVELOPING I HAD THE I.
R. SO AS AS WE MENTIONED DR HAS
A TIRING DELEGATION BACK ON
THANKS TO THE SUPPORT OF CALLIE
CHARGE. AND SO. IN TERMS OF THE
PROCESS I SAID D. I. R. WE
FOLLOW CALLIE JARS BEST HIRING
PRACTICE GUIDELINES AND SO IT'S
VERY SIMILAR TO WHAT OTHER STATE
AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS DEAL.
BUT BUT I WILL NOTE THAT OUR
HUMAN RESOURCES OFFICE THAT'S
COMPLETE A REVIEW OF THINGS LIKE
A NATIONAL ALLOCATION LEVELS.
HELLO AS IN WHICH WE IDENTIFIED
THAT THERE WAS A NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL CONTROLS AND
OVERSIGHT AND SO WE'RE
CONTINUING TO WORK ON A BUT THAT
WITH WITHOUT BEING SAD WE ARE
PRO ACTIVELY EVALUATING OUR
EXISTING PROCESS TO IDENTIFY AND
IMPLEMENT STRATEGIES TO BE MORE
EFFICIENT AND EFFECTIVE WE
ACTUALLY RECENTLY COMPLETED A
PEER REVIEW OF OUR HIRING
PROCESS AND WE'RE WORKING ON
IMPLEMENTING RECOMMENDATIONS SO
THAT WE CAN IMPROVE OUR PROCESS
IN ADDITION TO LOOKING FOR
OPPORTUNITIES TO AUTOMATE- WHAT
IS A LARGELY MANUAL PROCESS
CURRENTLY. SO CAN YOU WHAT CAN
YOU I'D ASK THIS OF A MISTER GET
A LITTLE CAN YOU WALK ME THROUGH
THAT START TO FINISH HOW DO YOU
FEEL VACANCY. IN TERMS OF THAT
BE INCREMENTAL STEPS- TO FILL A
VACANCY SO I I'M HAPPY TO FOLLOW
UP TO PROVIDE A BIT MORE I CAN
GIVE A HIGH LEVEL IN. SOME OF
THOSE PIECES LOOK LIKE AND SO
IT'S- DIFFERENT LAD AND- IF MY
COLLEAGUE AT COLLEGE I WANTS TO
JUMP AT A TIME FEEL FREE BUT SO
IT CAN LOOK LIKE YOU ARE
SUBMITTING A FORM IN WHICH
YOU'RE ESTABLISHING A POSITION
THAT'S A FORM ONE I'M YOU'RE
ALSO THERE'S THE PIECE ON THE
PROGRAM SIDE AND THERE'S THE
PIECE ON OUR HUMAN RESOURCES
OFFICE SIDE YOU ALSO HAVE A DUTY
STATEMENT THAT YOU'RE CRAFTING
SO ABOUT THAT. ESSENTIALLY. A
LIST OF WHAT ARE THE DIFFERENT.
PLEASE A POSITION IS DOING IN
THE DIFFERENT PERCENTAGES OF
TIME BUT BUT LOOKS LIKE. ARE
YOUR POSTING A JOB AND LOOKING
FOR PEOPLE TO APPLY YOUR SCREEN
APPLICATIONS JUST MAKE SURE THAT
THEY MEET MATH MINIMUM
QUALIFICATIONS. INTERVIEWING
ENOUGH ABOUT THAT SORT OF
PROCESS AND THEN YOU COMPLETE
SCORING AND SUBMIT A COMPLETE
HIRING POCKET. AND THEN THAT'S
WHAT GETS REVIEW TO MAKE SURE
THAT ALL OF THE BEST PRACTICES
WERE FOLLOWED. WE'VE BEEN OUT
WERE ALSO CHECKING TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE FOLLOWING THE BEST
PRACTICE GUIDELINES RIGHT TO
ENSURE ABOUT WHERE WE'RE MEETING
BAD EXPECTATION TO FOLLOW THE
MERIT BASED HIRING SYSTEM. FIVE
THOSE ARE SOME OF THE DIFFERENT
I GUESS MILESTONES BUT HAPPY TO
CIRCLE BACK WITH WITH YOUR STAFF
TO WALK THROUGH WHAT THAT LOOKS
LIKE MORE OPERATIONALLY. YES IN
- YOUR I JUST WANT I JUST WANT
TO BE CLEAR IN TERMS OF WHERE
THE WHERE IS THE POTENTIAL. YOU
KNOW ISSUES OR BOTTLENECKS EARTH
YOU KNOW AS YOU SAY YOUR DATA
EVALUATING- THIS THE PROCESS- TO
HIRE- WHAT'S THE ROLE OF THE IR
IN. THE DELISSIO ON THE D. O. S.
H. HIRING. YEAH OF COURSE I'VE-
BEEN A TWENTY YARD SO OUR HUMAN
RESOURCE OFFICE AYE SO THE
DIVISION OF LABOR STANDARDS
ENFORCEMENT LABOR COMMISSIONER'S
OFFICE AS WELL AS CALLOW SHOWS
THAT UNDER OUR DEPARTMENT D. I.
R. AND SO WE HAVE A CENTRALIZED
HUMAN RESOURCE OFFICE WHICH
HELPS GUIDE THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE. AS WELL
AS CAL OSHA SUPERVISORS AND
MANAGERS ON THE RECRUITMENT
HIRING PRACTICES TO ENSURE THAT
ALL HIRES ARE IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THE STATE'S MERIT BASED
PRINCIPLES I HAD AN ALIGNMENT
WITH COLLEGE OURS BEST HIRING
PRACTICES. SO LIKE I MENTIONED
THIS CAN INCLUDE REVIEWING AND
APPROVING HIRING PACKAGES WHICH
HAS DUTY STATEMENTS
ORGANIZATIONAL CHARTS SO THIS IS
SHOULD WEAR SHOWS WHERE
POSITIONS THAT'S- IN A UNIT FOR
EXAMPLE IN WHERE REPORTS TO-
JUSTIFICATION MEMORANDUM
SCREENING CRITERIA AND ALSO
INTERVIEW QUESTIONS AND THEN.
ONCE AGAIN IT HAS BEEN SELECTED
THAT TEAM ALSO VERIFIES THAT THE
CANDIDATE MEETS ALL REQUIREMENTS
AND MINIMUM QUALIFICATIONS TO
ENSURE THAT IT'S A MERIT BASED
HIGHER I THINK IN TERMS OF WHAT
OPPORTUNITIES WERE FINDING
WITHIN THAT PROCESS. I'VE TRIED
TO REALLY BRING MORE
EFFICIENCIES AND TO BE MORE
ACTIVE I THINK WE'RE STILL IN
THE EARLY STAGES OF EVALUATING
THIS REVIEW IN THE FEEDBACK BUT
ALSO HAPPY TO CIRCLE BACK TO
TALK A BIT MORE CONCRETELY ABOUT
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT WE'RE
LOOKING I'M FLAMAND. BUT WE HAVE
BEEN FOR EXAMPLE LIKE I
MENTIONED EARLIER TRYING TO
PROVIDE MORE RESOURCES TO ENSURE
THAT FOR EXAMPLE THERE IS FIVE
BUT OUR HIRING MANAGERS HAVE THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED TO ENSURE
THEY HAVE THE MOST COMPLETE AND
EFFECTIVE DO STATEMENT OR
INTERVIEW QUESTIONS. ABOUT THEIR
IN ALIGNMENT WITH BEST.
THAT YOU HAVE. COULD YOU TALK
ABOUT THAT IN TERMS OF EITHER
HOW MANY OR- AND I'M
PARTICULARLY ARE ASKING ABOUT
THAT OBVIOUSLY BECAUSE JUST AS I
SAID A LITTLE WHILE AGO. THERE
ARE STILL MANY AW INDUSTRIES LOW
WAGE INDUSTRIES THAT HAVE LIKELY
TO HAVE. OF CLAIMS AND THEIR-
DOMINANTLY NON ENGLISH SPEAKING
SO HOW DO YOU YOU KNOW HOW ARE
YOU ADDRESSING THAT HI WE
ADDRESSING THE NEED FOR THAT
FROM. UP WORKING CALIFORNIANS
OUT THERE WHO ARE YOU KNOW
COMING TO YOU FOR HELP. YES OF
COURSE THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION- MADAM CHAIR JANET
PAYING DIR SO ON THE QUESTION OF
BILINGUAL POSITION SO WE
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
MAKING ART DEPARTMENTS WORK MORE
ACCESSIBLE AND MEETING WORKERS
WHERE THEY ARE. AND SO TECH TO
GIVE A BIT OF BACKGROUND I
BELIEVE THERE WAS A QUESTION
ABOUT FIVE. HOW SOME BACKGROUND
HOW BILINGUAL POSITIONS ARE
ESTABLISHED SO JUST TO START TO
OUR DIVISIONS HAND AND HAVE
DESIGNATED SPECIFIC POSITIONS I
WAS NEEDING A BILINGUAL SKILLS
THAT HOWEVER THERE ARE ALSO
POSITIONS AND WHICH ON OUR
POSTINGS WE ENCOURAGE OUR
RECRUITMENT SPY LINGLE
CANDIDATES TO APPLY I JUST TO
GIVE AN EXAMPLEON THE FORMER
CAL OSHA THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE AND THE
DIVISION OF WORKERS COMP ALL
RECENTLY ADVERTISED AND
RECRUITED FOR EXAMPLE FOR A
BILINGUAL OUTREACH AND EDUCATION
ANALYST NOT TO HELP YOU WITH
FLIGHT OUR DEPARTMENT A
MULTILEVEL OUTREACH EFFORTS. I
AND JUST TO GIVE SOME MORE
INFORMATION SO CURRENTLY ON THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER'S SIDE WE
HAVE SIXTY SEVEN EMPLOYEES THAT
ARE BILINGUAL I BETTER
DESIGNATED BILINGUAL SO JUSTICE
I JUST BECAUSE THERE DOESN'T
MEAN THAT DOESN'T MEAN THERE
AREN'T OTHERS- AND THEN FIFTY
ONE EMPLOYEES AND CAL OSHA- WHO
AREN'T RECEIVING THE BILINGUAL
PAY DIFFERENTIAL AND SO I ON THE
BILINGUAL PAY DIFFERENTIAL AND
HOW THAT WORKS I WOULD JUST SAY
THAT WE FOLLOW THAT STATE
GUIDELINES FOR THE BILINGUAL PAY
DIFFERENTIAL SO. FOR EXAMPLE IF
A NEW POSITION IS ESTABLISHED
AND THE DIVISION SIDE ADDED
DIVISION DEMONSTRATES THAT IT
HAS TO BE A BILINGUAL POSITION
CANDIDATES WOULD NEED TO PASS A
LANGUAGE ASSESSMENT AT THE SAME
FOR THEIR INCUMBENT EMPLOYEE WHO
IS GETTING AB FILING WILL PAY
DIFFERENTIAL WE WOULD HAVE TO
ESTABLISH THAT THEY'RE USING
THEIR BILINGUAL SKILL SET AT
LEAST 10% OF THE TIME IN THEIR
POSITION AND THEN ALSO THAT DAY
THEY MEET THE REQUIREMENTS AS
SET BY OUR- STATE GUIDELINES. SO
I- IS THAT SIXTY SEVEN FIFTY ONE
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS IN
THE SCHEME OF THE TOTAL THERE
BUT I- I KNOW THERE MUST BE IN
SOME POSITION. AND I DON'T KNOW
TECHNICAL THE WITH THE CLASSIC
IS. BUT THERE MAY BE ON. OF A
NEED IN SOME. SOME JOBS THEN
THERE IS A OTHER AND SOME OF
THOSE THAT ARE DIRECT. MORE
DIRECTLY INVOLVED WITH THE
PUBLIC OF OR OR WITH THE
CLAIMANTS I'M SORRY THEN- THAT
MUST BE A MUCH HIGHER
PERCENTAGE- AND I KNOW COMING
FROM AND WORKING IN THESE
INDUSTRIES. THAT OF THE LEVEL OF
TRUST. THAT COMES WITH YOU KNOW
OF GOING TO OUR AGENCIES. A LOT
OF IT DEPENDS ON ARE YOU
BILINGUAL ARE YOU BY CULTURAL-
THAT GIVES A LEVEL OF TRUST
THAT'S NEEDED BECAUSE IT AS WAS
SAID EARLIER YOU'RE SO MUCH
FEAR. ODD TO- TAKING ADVANTAGE
OF THE RIGHTS THAT THE WORKERS
HAVE SO. HOW DO I CAN ONLY
IMAGINE THAT THE NEED HAS ONLY
GROWN FOR A BI LINGUAL-
BILINGUAL STAFFING HOW DO YOU
SEE YOURSELF ADDRESSING THAT
GREATER NEED. ALL WERE PUTTING A
LOT OF RESOURCES INTO COMPLIANCE
AND ENFORCEMENT. HOW HOW CAN YOU
MEET THAT NEED. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR DANCING WITH THE I. R. SO
IT OKAY VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK ABOUT A BIT
MORE ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
HAVING AN INFORMATION- AND ALSO
OUR SERVICES ACCESSIBLE HEAR
CALIFORNIANS AND THE LANGUAGE
THEY'RE COMFORTABLE SPEAKING ART
OR CAN'T SPEAK TO BANG OUT OF
THERE MONOLINGUAL. AND SO I ON
THE SIDE OF ALSO WE'RE TRYING TO
RECRUIT MORE CANDID SIDE
MENTIONED AND ESTABLISHING MORE
POSITIONS THAT WE'VE IDENTIFIED
AS BILINGUAL ALSO ENCOURAGING
MORE MULTILINGUAL CANDIDATES TO
APPLY WE'VE ALSO BEEN TRYING TO
ADVERTISE OUR POSITIONS TO. MORE
JUST A WIDER BREADTH TO GET MORE
DIVERSE CAN ARE REPRESENTATIVE
OF CALIFORNIA INCLUDING OUR
COMMUNITY PARTNERS THAT WE WORK
WITH OUR AND OUR WORK. AND I
WOULD ALSO JUST LIKE TO NOTE AS
WELL BUT IN ADDITION TO HIRING
MORE OF. MORE STAFF. THAT HAVE
BILINGUAL SKILL SETS WE ARE ALSO
ASSESSING OUR CONTRACTED
RESOURCES FOR BILINGUAL ACCESS
THAT WE HAVE A WORKING GROUP.
CURRENTLY INTERNALLY WHERE WE'RE
WORKING TO ENSURE THAT ALL OF
OUR TEAM MEMBERS HAVE ACCESS
EITHER TO AN EMPLOYEE OR SOME
KIND OF BILINGUAL TRANSLATION
SERVICE VIA PHONE OR EMAIL SO
THAT. THAT DOESN'T BECOME A
HINDRANCE AS WELL WE'RE TRYING
TO MAKE MOREOF OUR ACTUAL
MATERIALS AND RESOURCES
AVAILABLE IN MORE LANGUAGES AS
WELL TO WORKERS. DO YOU HAVE- DO
YOU HAVE PARTICULAR GOALS OR
TIME FRAME TO REACH THOSE GOALS
GOALS IN TERMS OF THE HIRING OF
PARTICULAR NINE- NON ENGLISH
SPEAKERS BUT JUST OVERALL. YOU
MENTIONED- BOMB EARLIER THE
LEVEL OF VACANCIES THAT THAT YOU
HAVE- WE DIDN'T GET INTO EVERY
DETAIL OF THE PROCESS- ALL THE
HIRING PROCESS BUT IF WE CONNECT
THAT BACK TO THE NUMBER THAT THE
VACANCIES AND I KNOW YOU'RE
WORKING REALLY HARD BUT THE
NUMBER OF VACANCIES THE
INCREASED NUMBER OF A NEED FOR
NON ENGLISH SPEAKERS HOW DO YOU
REALLY HOPE TO- ADDRESS THAT. IN
THE STRONGER STINT YOU KNOW WAY
POSSIBLE AS SOON AS POSSIBLE AND
I ASK THAT BECAUSE AND
CONNECTION ALSO TO THE PROCESS
OF HIRING YOU KNOW SOMETIMES AT
HIRING COULDN'T GET IN THE WAY
OF. HIRING THE GOOD PEOPLE OUT
THERE SO I KNOW YOU MENTIONED-
EVALUATING YOUR PROCESS BUT- IT
SEEMS TO ME WE'VE GOT A- WE'VE
GOT TO FIGURE OUT WHERE THE
POTENTIAL BOTTLENECKS OUR- TO
REALLY ADDRESS THIS AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE. AND I KNOW YOU
UNDERSTAND THE URGENCY HERE I'M
NOT TALKING ABOUT JUST SPEEDING
IT UP FOR THE SAKES OF. OKAY
SOMEBODY COULD GET SOMETHING
DONE IN A FEW MONTHS EARLIER- MY
EXPERIENCES. THIS GOES ON FOR
YEARS OF SOMETIMES AND NOT
EXACTLY. YOU KNOW I WANNA USE
THE EXACT TIME FRAME OF A YEAR
WHICH YEARS BUT- OF THAT WAS MY
FIRST EXPERIENCE WHEN I CAME
HERE TO THE LEGISLATURE. HE WAS
TAKING YEARS TO GET OF- FOR
EXAMPLE WAGE CLAIMS ARE TAKEN
CARE OF SO THAT'S NOT EXACTLY
THE SITUATION NOW BUT IT COULD
BE AND THAT'S WHAT I'M TRYING TO
GET TO THE BOTTOM OF. THANK YOU
MADAM. YAKKING DIR AND SO I HEAR
YOU AND WE SHARE THAT THE
COMMITMENT TO CONTINUE TO HIRE
AND RECRUIT MULTI LINGUAL STAFF.
I DON'T NECESSARILY HAVE
SPIDER-MAN HAPPY TOOK TO FOLLOW
UP ON WHY ARE SPECIFIC STRATEGY
LOOKS LIKE ASIDE FROM. IT REALLY
IS. TRYING TO BE INTENTIONAL
ABOUT ARE HIRING AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE AND WHEN WE'RE PUT IN
POSITIONS REALLY EVALUATING THE
DIVISION'S EVALUATE. WHAT THE
LANGUAGE COMPETENCY IS NEEDED
I'M I'M HAPPY TO GO AND LOOK AT
WHAT SOME OF OUR RECRUITMENT.
ARE IN TERMS OF HOW WE'RE
EVALUATING- LANGUAGE ACCESS AND
ON THOSE THINGS BUT ALSO IN THE
INTERIM AT LEAST WE'RE REALLY
DEDICATING TIME AND ENERGY TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE. BETTER
RESOURCES AND IN PLACE. ANY OF
OUR STAFF THAT NEEDS SOME KIND
OF TRANSLATION AND I'VE SERVICE
OR ASSISTANCE HABITS AS WELL SO
WE'RE TRYING TO JUST TAKE A
MULTI PRONGED APPROACH TO ENSURE
THAT THAT ACCESS IS AVAILABLE.
OKAY I DON'T KNOW IF MR GET RID
OF IT IF YOU HAVE ANY THING TO
ADD TO MISS THINGS- RESPONSES.
YES MADAM CHAIR I THE ONLY THING
I WOULD ADD IS THAT ALL STATE
AGENCIES ARE CONDUCTING BI
ANNUAL SURVEY TO DETERMINE THE
LEVEL OF VIOLENCE WILL MEET- AND
STAFFING- AT THE NECESSARY IT
AGENCIES DEVELOP A PLAN RESPOND
TO ANY ARTIFICIAL FEES. I IN IT
LOOKS. AND SO THAT IS A-
SOMETHING THAT EACH OUR
DEPARTMENT BECAUSE IT. MISTER
WITH REGARD THE LIVE OF BIG AND
DO I ARE- THE IT RANGES FROM
23232% IN EACH OF THE-
APPRENTICESHIP LABOR
COMMISSIONER OSHA WORKERS COMP.
HOW HOW DOES THAT RANGE IS THAT
NOT. OF A RED FLAG IN TERMS OF
ADDRESSING THOSE VACANCIES. AT
THE END OF YOUR AND YOUR AND
YOUR ROLE IN AND YOUR ROLE IN
ADDRESSING THAT. R. KELLY
CHARCOAL IN IN- IN THAT AREA IS
REALLY JUST TO- PROVIDE HIRING
PRACTICES TRAINING- TO. THEIR HR
LIAISON AND HIRING MANAGERS-
MANY THE ITEM- THAT THE I. R.
IDENTIFIED- MAKING SURE THAT
THEY MEET UP- PRINCIPAL- IS THAT
THEY HAVE- I HAVE A PROPRIA TO
THE STATEMENT THAT THEY HAVE. A
ROBUST RECRUITMENT TOOL AND SO-
ON THE DEFICIENCY SIDE BECAUSE
THE I. R. HAS. AUTHORITY TO HIRE
THAT IS. DIRECTLY. A QUESTION I
BELIEVE FOR THE I. R. OKAY
-
OKAY JUST ONE WAS ANOTHER
QUESTION I BELIEVE WITH. WAS
NEAR OF ROOM. OKAY FORUM-
DILISIO IN AND DO ES AGE IS OF
THE NUMBER OF EMPLOYEES OR HOW
MUCH TIME IS SPENT ON HIRING- OF
HOW MUCH TIME OR HOW MANY
INDIVIDUALS ARE SPENT ON HIRING. IN THE END UP PAYING DR JUST A
QUICK POINT OF CLARIFICATION
MADAM CHAIR YOU YOU MEAN WITHIN
OUR HUMAN RESOURCES. NO WITHIN
THE DIVISION. OKAY SO LATE LIKE
I MENTIONED THERE'S PARTS OF
THAT HIRING PROCESS THAT
HAPPENED THAT ARE SUPPORTED BY
HUMAN RESOURCES OFFICE AND THEN
THEY'RE ALSO THAT ARE ON THE
PROGRAM SITES THAT WITHIN THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE AND
CAL OSHA I DON'T NECESSARILY
HAVE BAD HOW OSHA. NUMBER IN
FRONT OF ME BUT I CAN AT LEAST
SAY ON THE LABOR COMMISSIONER
SIDE EIGHT CREATE A HIRING TEAM
AND RE DIRECTED SEVENTEEN
MEMBERS WHO HELPED FOCUS ON ON
HIRING AND DOING THIS HIRING
LIAISON ROLE IN ADDITION. YOU
HAVE HIRING LIAISONS WHO HELD AT
DOING BAG BACK AND FORTH WITH
OUR HR TEAM BUT THEN YOU ALSO
HAVE HIRING MANAGERS AND IF THE
HIRING MANAGERS TO REALLY DO
SOME OF THAT HE SAID OF. MAKING
SURE THE DUTY STATEMENTS ADDRESS
ALL OF THEIR DUTIES THAT THIS
POSITION YOU'RE HIRING FOR
ENTAILS- THAT WAS ENTERED
DEVELOPING INTERVIEW QUESTIONS
EXCEPT TRUCK AND SO IT'S A
BIGGER NUMBER THAN THAT IN TERMS
BECAUSE WE'RE HIRING SO MANY
POSITIONS WE HAVE A LOT OF
HIRING MANAGERS. WHO ARE PLAYING
THAT ROLE AND THEN WE HAVE THOSE
HIRING LIAISONS WITHIN THE
DIVISIONS AND THEN WE HAVE OUR
HUMAN. RESOURCES OFFICE AS WELL
. OKAY WELL I APPRECIATE- I
KNOWS TRAIN BEGIN A LITTLE BIT
MORE BUT- THIS IS AN- AN
OVERSIGHT- ITEM AND WANTED TO
GET A BETTER UNDERSTANDING
BECAUSE IT CONNECTS SO MUCH TO
OUR BUDGET OUR INVESTMENT IN-
ENFORCEMENT AND COMPLIANCE- AND
YOU ALL ARE THE ONES WHO CARRY
OUT THIS HARD WORK FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES AND IS IT IS- IT IS-
VERY VERY HEART BREAKING WHEN WE
SEE SO MANY CALIFORNIANS THAT
CAN GET PAID SO MANY
CALIFORNIANS THAT ESPECIALLY
DURING THE PANDEMIC. ALL
WORKPLACE HEALTH AND SAFETY WAS
COMPLETELY IGNORED WHEN THERE'S
SO MANY WORKPLACE ISSUES AND-
YOU KNOW WHATEVER WE NEED TO DO
AS THE LEGISLATURE TO PROVIDE
THE RESOURCES THIS BUDGET- AND
ANY OTHER KIND OF RESOURCES. OF
WE NEED YOU KNOW WE WANT TO GET
TO THE BOTTOM OF WHAT THAT NEED
IS- THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR WORK
. ANYTHING ELSE. NO OKAY I THANK
YOU TO EVERYONE WHO JUST- SPOKE
APPRECIATE YOU VERY MUCH MISS
BEING MISTER IVERSON- MISTER GET
RATTLE THANK YOU ALL. VERY MUCH
AND MISS COLLINS. OKAY WE'RE
MOVING ON NOW TO- WE WANT TO
LOOK AT A WHOLE THIS ITEM OPEN
CONTINUE ON TO A ISSUE. TWENTY
TWO. I'M SORRY- OKAY AT THE REAR
OKAY ISSUE TWENTY ONE THE SENATE
DEMOCRATS PUTTING WELL TO WORK
PROPOSALS TO SUPPORT SMALL
BUSINESSES AND NONPROFITS AND-
WE WILL BEGIN WITH MR ALAMO FROM
THE LA O'S OFFICE. HELLO WITH
THE L. A. ON THANK YOU- THIS
ITEM- CONSISTS OF TWO COMPONENTS
OF THE SENATE BUDGET PLAN
RELATED TO SMALL BUSINESS AND
NONPROFIT RELIEF. THE FIRST
COMPONENT IS A PROPOSAL TO
REIMBURSE CERTAIN SMALL
BUSINESSES AND NONPROFITS FOR
THE COSTS- INCREASE PAYROLL TAX
COSTS THE RESULT FROM- THE
STATE'S NEED TO REPAY FEDERAL
LOANS THAT WERE TAKEN DURING THE
PANDEMIC I HAD TO KEEP PAYING
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE BENEFITS-
SO TELL TO UNPACK THAT A BIT-
DURING THE PANDEMIC. AS YOU KNOW
THAT THE STATE- YOU I TRUST FUND
BECAME INSOLVENT SO THAT THE
STATE BORROWED ABOUT TWENTY
BILLION DOLLARS IN TOTAL FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO KEEP
PAYING UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS-
UNDER FEDERAL LAW- THE REPAYMENT
PLAN. TO REPAY THE PRINCIPAL
AMOUNT OF THOSE LOANS- IS A
INCREMENTAL INCREASE IN THE
FEDERAL PORTION OF BUSINESSES
YOU I PAYROLL TAXES ARE
BEGINNING WITH- I MEAN CREATION
OF ONE THIRD. OR THREE TENTHS OF
A PERCENT- AND NEXT YEAR AND
THEN INCREASE INCREMENTALLY
INCREASING UNTIL THOSE LOANS ARE
REPAID A CUSTOMARILY THE STATE
GENERAL FUND HAS PAIDANNUAL
INTEREST ON THOSE FORMS I'M INTO
THIS SENATE PROPOSAL. WOULD
PROVIDE A- ONE TO ONE. OF THOSE.
FEDERAL YOU I CUTS. FOR
BUSINESSES AND NOT. BOB THE
FIRST YEARS IN INCLUDES
LEGISLATIVE AND WHEN TO CONVEY
PER THAT DIRECTOR. FOR THE- OF
THE FEDERAL LOAN. THE SECOND
COMPONENT THIS ITEM- RELATES- I
DID RELIEF. FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES- WHO HAVE PROVIDED
EMPLOYER PAID PAID SICK LEAVE
FOR KOBE NINETEEN RELATED
REASONS- AS PART OF A- RECENT
STATE LAW THAT MANDATED
EMPLOYERS PROVIDE THAT PAID
COVERAGE- OUR OFFICE HAS NO
SPECIFIC ASSESSMENT OF EITHER
THE PROPOSALS- WERE SIMPLY ASKED
TO DESCRIBE THEM ABOUT HOW TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS. CLARIFIER
CONTEXTUAL OR- OBVIOUSLY GET
BACK TO STAFF WITH WITH ANY
ISSUES THAT ARE ARE MORE COMPLEX
. OKAY. WE DON'T HAVE WE DON'T
HAVE ANYONE ELSE SPEAKING ON
THIS OKAY OF. MEMBERS. YOUR
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS ARTICLE
THING SO THERE'S A REFERENCE IN
THE ANALYSIS TO. A TABLE I
ASSUME TROUBLE FIND. YEAH SAID
JUST FIGURE WITH THE L. A.
OSHA'S I IMPORTS COMBINED STATE
YOUR TAX LIFE OR OF HAVING
TROUBLE FOR. THAT ITEM NUMBER.
THREE SURE THAT THERE WOULD A
GOOD CONTACT.
OKAY. OKAY OKAY HELLO ARE YOU
SEE I DO HAVE A QUESTION- YOU
KNOW WITH RESPECT TO AID FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES HOW WILL THIS
OPPORTUNITY- THIS BENEFIT BE
PUBLICIZED- IS THERE WILL BE
AUTOMATIC OR IS IT IS IT KIND OF
IS THE ONUS ON THE BUSINESS TO
ACCESS THE RELIEF HOW IT HOW
WILL THAT WORK. THIS IS. ON AS I
UNDERSTAND IT BUT DETAILS OF THE
PROPOSAL ARE STILL BEING WORKED
OUT- BUT THAT THE INTENT WAS
THAT- FOR BOTH THE YOU ARE COST
REIMBURSEMENT AS WELL AS THE
PAID SICK LEAVE GRANT
REIMBURSEMENT THAT THE
ADMINISTRATIVE IN A DEEP WOULD.
INITIATE THOSE PROGRAMS-
AUTOMATICALLY RATHER THAN HAVING
A BUSINESS NEED TO COME FORTH
AND PRO ACTIVELY- REQUEST OR OR
MAKE A CLAIM FOR REIMBURSEMENT.
THAT THAT'S OCCURRING OBVIOUSLY
THE DEVIL'S IN THE DETAILS FROM
WE CAN WHEN WE LOOK BACK OVER
THE LAST. COUPLE YEARS FISH AND
THINGS LIKE WOULD YOU KNOW RENT
RELIEF YOU KNOW THAT THAT HAS
BEEN A STICKING POINT WHERE
UNCLEAR. ESPECIALLY LIKE ACROSS
THE CALENDAR LIKE WHEN PEOPLE
KNEW ABOUT IT NOW THEY WERE YOU
KNOW WELL EQUIPPED TO ACCESS IS
TO THE C. THANK YOU. MISTER- I
HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE TWO WE
COULD REMIND ME ONE IS ON AS FAR
AS YOU AYE COST. IS FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES WITH UP TO FIFTY TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY EMPLOYEES. AND
OBVIOUSLY THAT'S AN EASIER THING
IT'S A REBATE SYSTEM. THE RELIEF
OF GRANT FOR PAID SICK LEAVE
COSTS IS FOR BOTH SMALL BUSINESS
AND NONPROFITS UP TO A HUNDRED
FIFTY EMPLOYEES. OF AND THAT'S
THROUGH A GRANT PROGRAM COULD.
OF COULD YOU TALK ABOUT WHY THAT
THE DIFFERENCES BETWEEN THE TWO
I BEEN- APPROACH BY THE NUMBER
OF NON PROFITS WERE REALLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE CAP. OF YOU
KNOW BEING BEING CAPPED AT A
HUNDRED FIFTY EMPLOYEES THEIR
NONPROFITS AND SO OBVIOUSLY SEE
THEMSELVES AND ALSO THEIR
ABILITY TO ACCESS I THINK
BECOMES MORE DIFFICULT TO MORE
COMPLICATED THEY GO THROUGH A
GRANT. OF PROGRAM SO ANY
THOUGHTS ON HOW TO ADDRESS THAT
. OF COURSE SENATOR DORADO- TO
YOUR FIRST QUESTION ABOUT THE
ADMINISTRATIVE ENTITIES ON FOR
THE U. I. COST REIMBURSEMENT THE
STATE HAS REPLIED MINISTRY TO
ADVANTAGE OF KNOWING A GREAT
DEAL ABOUT THE EMPLOYERS YOU WHY
COSTS INCLUDING THE INCREASED
FEDERAL YOU AYE COST BECAUSE OF
THE CLOSE RELATIONSHIP THAT THE
EMPLOYER COMMUNITY HAS. WITH THE
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT WHO OVERSEES THE
PROGRAM SO IT'S A NATURAL.
PROPOSAL TO HAVE ON THE STATE
DIRECTLY TO MINISTER THAT
REIMBURSED BACK ON FOR THE PAIN
SICK LEAVE. PROVISIONS THAT
THERE DOESN'T EXIST THE SAME
NATURAL- OVERSIGHT OR
ADMINISTERING ENTITY AND THIS IS
AS I UNDERSTAND IT THE REASON
WHY A GRAND ADMINISTRATOR HAS
BEEN PROPOSED- THERE ARE PROS
AND CONS WITH WITH GOING FOR THE
ADMINISTRATOR BUT I IN THE
ABSENCE OF SUCH A CLEAR STATE
ENTITY- IT'S OBVIOUSLY ONE OF
THE- THE- MOST VIABLE
ALTERNATIVES. YOUR SECOND
QUESTION SENATOR ALSO ABOUT THE-
THE SCOPE OF BUSINESS SIZE OR
NONPROFIT SIZE IT WOULD BE
ELIGIBLE FOR RELIEF THAT REALLY
IS A QUESTION FOR THE SUB
COMMITTEE AND FOR THE SENATE TO
DETERMINE ITS IN IN ITS
PRIORITIES. OBVIOUSLY EXPANDING-
ABOVE. TO LARGER EMPLOYERS IN IN
EITHER PROGRAM WOULD INCREASE
STATE COSTS FOR THE GRANTS-
WHILE HAVING A MORE RESTRICTED
PROGRAM THAT'S MORE NARROWLY
TARGETED SMALLER BUSINESSES AND
NONPROFITS WHICH WOULD DECREASE
STATE COSTS RELATIVE TO THE
CURRENT PROPOSAL. I MEAN THAT'S
REALLY- WILL HAVE A VALUES
QUESTION FOR THE SUB COMMITTEE
AND HOW IT FITS INTO THE BROADER
SENATE BUDGET- OUR PORTFOLIO AND
PLAN. YEAH OKAY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WORSE YES SENATE COURTESY.
YEAH THEN I APPRECIATE THE
EXPLANATION ON THE DIFFERENCE IN
ADMINISTRATION AND IT IT DOES-
NO OCCURRED TO ME THAT. JUST
BECAUSE OF THE NATURE OF THE
RELIEF ON PAID SICK LEAVE- THAT
THE ONLY EMPLOYER WOULD WOULD
REALLY KNOW AND BE ABLE TO
CERTIFY- YOU KNOW WHAT THEIR OUT
OF POCKET ON HOW MANY EMPLOYEES
HAVE ACTUALLY. IF YOU WILL STEP
FORWARD AND CLAIM THAT KIND OF
RELIEF- SO IT'S- YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY SOME OF THE SAFEGUARDS
IN IMPLEMENTATION THE
ADMINISTRATOR GOING TO HAVE TO
MAKE SURE THAT- YOU KNOW ALL
THAT'S DONE- WITH USUAL SAVE
CARS IN A PENALTY OF PERJURY
AND- YOU KNOW PROP PROTECTION
AND EVERYTHING ELSE BUT- BUT IT
IT IT WOULD BE PRETTY IMPOSSIBLE
FOR THE EMPLOYER. FOR THE STATE
TO KNOW. YOU KNOW WITHOUT SOME
KIND OF A SURVEY OR SOMETHING
WHO. EVEN YOU KNOW WHAT. THE
MAGNITUDE OF THESE CLAIMS ARE
GOING TO BE OVERALL UNTIL THEY
START COMING IN SO LIKE I GET IT
I A GRANT PROGRAM IS NOT AS
ATTRACTIVE AS- AS YOU KNOW SORT
OF AUTOMATED WAY THAT THE U. I.
IS GOING TO BE HANDLED BUT- YOU
KNOW I'M NOT SURE EITHER. I CAN
COME UP WITH A BETTER. BUT A WAY
OF DOING THAT- AS WE SEE HERE
TODAY. I DO SUPPORT BOTH ITEMS I
SUPPORT EVERYTHING IN THIS ITEM-
YOU KNOW HOW 2% YOU KNOW IN
TERMS OF THE NEED IN TERMS OF
THE BUDGET. BUDGET PRIORITY AND-
I KNOW OF. SEVERAL BUSES IT
PROBABLY ACTUALLY THE SAME
COHORT APPEAR ON THIS PANEL BEEN
PRETTY VOCAL ABOUT. MAKING SURE
THAT THERE'S RELIEF- FOR THE
SMALL BUSINESSES IT LEAST AS
DEFINED HERE- BUT WE'VE HEARD A
LOT ABOUT THE HARDSHIP ALREADY
SO WHATEVER WHATEVER'S HAPPENING
OUT THERE N TERMS OF
REIMBURSEMENTS NEEDED IT'S
SIGNIFICANT ENOUGH OF BECAUSE
WE'RE HEARING. FROM
CONSTITUENCIES FROM EMPLOYERS
THAT IT'S HURTING- IT'S PUTTING
A REAL HURT ON ON ON SMALL
BUSINESSES OUT THERE AND OF
COURSE IF THAT'S- NOT RELIEVED
SOMEHOW- YOU RISK OF SOME SORT
OF YOU KNOW INSOLVENCY OR
LAYOFFS OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT
WHICH IN TURN- GOES BACK IT
HURTS THE EMPLOYEES THEMSELVES-
KIND OF DEFEATS THE PURPOSE OF
THE PAID SICK LEAVE IN THE FIRST
PLACE SO. I'M ALL FOR IT- I HAD
NOT HEARD OF BILL IS MUCH OF.
FROM THE NONPROFIT COMMUNITY-
CHAIRED RUSSELL AND WHICH IS
AMAZING BECAUSE WE HAVE SUCH OF.
THE NETWORK OF. ACTIVE IN
SOMETIMES SIZABLE NONPROFITS- IN
MY COUNTY SO- HOPEFULLY WE CAN
HELP- YOU KNOW HOW FIGURE OUT.
WHAT THE NEED IS THERE AND IF
THERE NEEDS TO BE SOME KIND OF-
THE SPECIAL OUTLET FOR THEM-
I'VE I THINK WITH- THE FOR
PROFIT EMPLOYERS. BUT WE'VE
HEARD PRETTY CLEARLY THAT
HUNDRED FIFTY IS A PRETTY GOOD
CUT OFF BUT DUMP. THEM I I'D I'D
LIKE TO HEAR MORE ABOUT THAT I'M
SURE WE WILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND THANKS RECENT QUESTION. OKAY
THANK YOU I ALSO THE OTHER THING
I APPRECIATE ABOUT THESE TWO IS
THAT IT'S UP TO TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY EMPLOYEES- UP TO A HUNDRED
FIFTY EMPLOYEES VERSUS THE OTHER
WAY WHICH WAS. THE HIGHER ALL
INCLUSIVE DOWN TO TWENTY FIVE
AND SO THOSE WHO ARE UNDER
TWENTY FIVE WERE WERE LEFT OUT
OF RELIEF IN THE PAST- AND- IS
THERE A WAY OF. GENERALLY
CALCULATE MISTER ALAMO IF WE
WENT FROM WITH THE NONPROFIT'S
NOT WITH THE FOR PROFIT
BUSINESSES AND NONPROFITS WE
WOULD HIGHER. IS THERE SORT OF
A- A WAY TO GENERALLY CALCULATE
LIKE UP TO FIVE HUNDRED IF
YOU'RE A NONPROFIT OR NO CAP IF
YOU'RE NONPROFIT HOW HOW DO YOU
. GET TO THE BOTTOM OF THAT
BECAUSE I UNDERSTAND THIS COMES
DOWN TO WHERE WE GONNA PUT. THE
FUNDS THAT WE HAVE. MADAM CHAIR-
IT'S NOT AS SIMPLE AS WE WOULD
LIKE IT TO BE- WE'D BE HAPPY TO
WORK WITH WITH- THE EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT ON I'M
GATHERING SOME DATA AND THINKING
ABOUT IT WANT ONE. KEEP
CONSIDERATION NONPROFIT SECTOR
IS THAT. AS YOU KNOW MANY
NONPROFITS DIRECTLY REIMBURSE
FOR THEIR YOU AYE COSTS- AND SO.
DOES NONPROFITS. WOULD NOT BE
SUBJECT TO THE INCREASE FEDERAL
YOU MIGHT TAXES NUMBER NOT
ELIGIBLE FOR THIS GRANT PROGRAM
SO THAT. THE SUBSET OF NON
PROFITS THAT THAT WOULD BE
ELIGIBLE HIS PHYSICAL RELATIVELY
SMALL PORTION- I SAID ONLY TO.
HELP PUT SOME. A. B. CONTACT ON
THE ORDER OF ADDED TO- IT'S NOT
- TWO SIXTY BUT WE'D HAVE TO
WORK A PARTNER AND GET SOMETHING
MORE KIND BACK TO OKAY THANK YOU
. VERY MUCH. APPRECIATED WILL
MOVE ON OUT LEAVE THAT OPEN.
ISSUE TWENTY TWO IS A LAKE FOR
LET LABOR WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
WORKERS RIGHTS IN THE SENATE
DEMOCRATS PUTTING WEALTH WORK
PLAN. WE WILL BEGIN WITH MR
ALAMO. OF FROM THE L. A. O.'S
OFFICE ON THIS ISSUE TWENTY TWO
. HURTADO LOGIN WITH THE L. A.
THIS OTHER CA OF ISSUE TWENTY
TWO THAT COMPRISED- ADDITIONAL
PIECES OF THE SENATE BUDGET PLAN
OBLIGATED TO DISTRICT LABOR
EMPLOYMENT CONCERNS AND
PROGRAMS- THE FIRST COMPONENT IS
THIRTEEN BILLION DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND FOR THE- UC ARE THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA WORKER
RIGHT CENTER POLICY CLAPPER- THE
SECOND PROPOSAL IS. AN
EXPANSION- OF A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND OVER TWO
YEARS FOR THE CLUB IN NINETEEN
WORKPLACE OUTREACH PROJECT WHICH
IS A CURRENT PROJECT AT THE
STATE'S LABOR AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AGENCY. ON THE THIRD
COMPONENT IS FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND ONE TIME-
FOR A CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL TREAT
A HOSPITALITY TRAINING CENTRE.
CREAMY I'M- THE NEXT COME IS UP
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL
ONE. FOR THE PRAYER- PESAR. AT
THE DOLORES MISSION IN LOS
ANGELES. THERE'S FIVE MILLION
CHEN FUND ONE TIME- TO ASSIST
HOMEBOY INDUSTRIES- WITH A
TRAINING CENTER AND OTHER
ASSOCIATED. SORT OF PROGRAMMING
THAT THAT THAT THEY HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED IN RECENTLY- THERE IS A
SMALLER ONE TIME GENERAL FUND-
AUGMENTATION FOR THE HOLLYWOOD
PARTNERSHIP- AND ADDITIONALLY I
AN EIGHT MILLION DOLLAR GENERAL
FUND ONE TIME- COMMITMENT FOR A
GARMENT WORKER CENTER IN THE LOS
ANGELES- FASHION OR GARMENT
DISTRICT- AND THEN TO SORT OF
STATUTORY AND OR OR TECHNICAL
FIXES- RELATED TO EMPLOYMENT
ISSUES. THAT I'M NOT GOING TO
MORE DETAILED AGAIN JUST FOR
DESCRIBING THE COMPONENTS OF THE
SENATE PACKAGE THANKS. OKAY
CURRENT ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. THE CRITICISM ANYTHING
NO NOTHING MORE THINKING OKAY
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT THANK YOU MR
ALAMO WILL- HOLD THIS OPEN. MMHM
WE'RE NOW MOVING ON TO ISSUE
TWENTY THREE- THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL. WE WERE UNABLE
TO COVER ON MARCH FIRST THIS IS
THE CAL HR CALIFORNIA LEADS AS
AN EMPLOYER IMPLEMENTATION
PROPOSAL WE HAVE A MISS EVELYN
SEUSS FROM DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
NICK SCHROEDER FROM THE ALEJO'S
OFFICE AND MY YOU GET OUT OF
FROM CAL H. R. SOME. MISS SUSAN
WILL YOU BE STARTING OUT. I
ACTUALLY HAVE CAL H. R. THAT
WILL BE PRESENTING ON THIS ITEM
THANK YOU- OKAY. GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR- GOOD MORNING
ONCE AGAIN- LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR
DEPARTMENT IF YOU. KALINJAR
BELIEVE THAT DIVERSITY IT WAS AN
UPPER PLATE ARE FACTORED
BUSINESS THE FIREMEN ACCORDINGLY
PLATE STARTED IMPORTING SESSION
AND SEVEN POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLARS TO BEGIN IMPLEMENTING
PROPOSALS TO RECRUIT AND RETAIN
A DIVERSE WORKFORCE THAT REFLECT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. DEGREE
CLUED IN IN A NON HIGHER PILOT
TO ADDRESS AND CON BIAS. REMAINS
IN CALGARY WEST THIS IS THE
WEBSITE USED BY PERSPECTIVE. THE
BOARD FOR APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS. OUR KEY DATA
INITIATIVE. TO ENHANCE OUR DATA
COLLECTION ANALYSIS AND
REPORTING AND TO SUPPORT COLLEGE
ARTICLE OPPORTUNITY ACADEMY
AMONG OTHER PROJECTS WE BELIEVE
THAT THESE EFFORTS WILL
MODERNIZE OUR CURRENT WORKFORCE
AND HELP TO BUILD AND MAINTAIN A
TALENTED AND DIVERSE WORKFORCE
WITH CAPABILITY TO NOT ONLY
SERVE THE NEEDS OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS BUT THE BETTER
REPRESENT ALL OF CALIFORNIA
WELL. I'D BE HAPPY TO ADDRESS
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE I DID
NOTE THAT THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
QUESTIONS- IN THE HEARING
KNOWLEDGE OF MATERIALS AND I'M
HAPPY TO DIVE INTO THEM WHEN YOU
WOULD LIKE. THANK MANAGER.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. ONE
STATION IT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
I HAVE NOTHING TO ADD AT THIS
TIME BUT I AM AVAILABLE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE. OKAY-
AND. MISTER SCHROEDER FROM THE
ALEJO'S OFFICE. A GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR THIS NEXT ROTOR FROM
THE L. A. O. THE AGENDA INCLUDES
THE FULL COURTHOUSES ALONG
COLLECTIONS TOO MUCH DETAIL ON
THAT BUT THE PROPOSAL REFLECTS
THE START OF A MULTI PRONGED AND
A MULTI YEAR INITIATIVE WITH AN
OVER ARCHING THEME OF MAKING THE
STATE A FEDERAL EMPLOYER AND
ALSO- TO MAKE IT TO THE STATE
WORKFORCE. IS MORE
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE PUBLIC
THAT ANSWERS. AND WE RECOMMEND
THAT THE LEGISLATURE APPROVED OF
THE PROPOSAL HOWEVER- BECAUSE OF
A LARGE INCREASE IN BUDGETARY
RESOURCES AND STAFFING FOR
COLLEGE ARE THAT REPRESENTS AS
WELL AS THE FACT THAT IT'S SUCH
AN IMPORTANT TOPIC. FOR LATER WE
RECOMMEND THE LEDGE. ACTIVELY
OVER THE- OF THE PA GOING
FORWARD. AS THE AGENDA INDICATES
WE SPECIFICALLY RECOMMEND THAT
AS PART OF THE BUDGET PROCESS
NEXT YEAR- BY JANUARY TENTH
TWENTY TWENTY THREE- THE
ADMINISTRATION REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE IS PROGRESS ON
FILLING THE POSITIONS. THAT
REQUESTED- IN THE BUDGET YEAR
IT'S PROGRESS IN DEVELOPING. A
DIVERSE EQUITY AND INCLUSION
STRATEGY- AND ANY CHANGES THAT
YOU WOULD RECOMMEND EXISTING
LEGISLATIVE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS CONCERNING- THE
DEMOGRAPHIC MAKE MAKE UP OF THE
STATE WORKFORCE. AS WELL AS ANY
CHALLENGES THAT MIGHT OF- FACED
IN ITS BEGINNING STEPS OF-
ADDRESSING THESE POLICY ISSUES-
AND THEN ALSO A- REPORT OF WHAT
IT SEES ITS NEXT STEPS. KIND IN
REACHING ITS OVER ARCHING
OBJECTIVES THE LEGISLATURE CAN.
BE. INTEGRAL PART OF THAT
PROCESS. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I JUST HAVE A COUPLE
OF QUESTIONS- HAS A- CAL H. R.
LOOKED AT SPECIFIC WAYS THAT
YOU'RE GOING TO CONNECTOR
OUTREACH PLANS FOR- MANY
NEGLECTED. COMMUNITIES
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES- THE
INCARCERATED AND REENTRY A
COMMUNITIES ARE TO THESE JOBS
AND CAREERS. I'M SURE MARIO
GUERRERO OUR OUR CURRENT LAW
EIGHT FROM ACTING AND I'VE BEEN
ABOUT- CRIMINAL- ERRING IN THIS
AND DOES ANYTHING AGAINST THEM
THE HIGHER PROCESS. I'LL BE
WAITING ENOUGH BASED BACKGROUND
OR EVALUATE GAP BASED ON-
QUALITY. ALEX ARE IS UP. IT
ARCHITECT PAYING MEMBER THE WORK
. PARTNERSHIP AND BRICK. THANK
MICHELLE- THE OPERATE. APARTMENT
I DID IT OUT JUST OUR IT REDUCED
RATES AND I'M KIND OF LABOR
MARKET. THIS I'M STATIC MISTER
HALL ON HOLD ON A SEC MISTER GET
LETTER WE'RE HAVING OF. YOUR
YOUR IN AND OUT. VERY UP VERY
DIFFERENT TO A WHICH SAYING.
SURE LET ME- TRUCK AT ABOUT. I
WILL ARE REBEKAH MEDICALLY THE
ISSUE IS RESOLVED. HOW THE CHART
IT FIRST IT'S EXPECTED TO PICK
PARTNERSHIPS AND PRESENT
EMPLOYMENT INITIATIVE THIS IS A
COLLABORATION BETWEEN VERY
APARTMENT. ARE THERE- FOCUS OF
THE FACT IT'S YOUR RISK. AND
LABOR MARKET I'M THROUGH A
SYSTEMATIC AND ON GOING IF.
BILITY OF PROGRAMS WITHIN THE-
AND THE STATE WORK FOR THAT THEM
. ALEX ARE PARTICIPATE BUT THERE
ARE NO GIRLS AS THE EIGHT
CAREERS ACCOUNT OF THIS BILL.
WHERE PEOPLE OF FOR- THE POINT
AND OF COURSE ALL THE TAKING
EXAMINING. OKAY OF THEM. I THINK
THAT THAT'S IT FOR ME. SENATORS
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. I
GUESS- QUESTION FOR MR ARE THERE
TO DO THIS IS AND THE KIND OF
THE GENERAL. CATEGORIES
IMPROVING THEIR CAL CAREERS
WEBSITE- WHAT'S THE STANDARD
LIKELY IN WHAT'S THE STREET
WHAT'S THE STANDARD FOR
IMPROVEMENT OF THE ON SOMETHING
AS SUBJECTIVE AS BETTER IS THERE
A- A SCOPING DOCUMENT THAT
EITHER IS IT IS PREPARED WILL BE
PREPARED AND WHAT WHAT WHAT ARE
THE BENCHMARK SHOWS TO MY STAFF
IN PREPARATION THIS THIRD TO GO
LOOKING KIND OF A TOUR. OF
LISTENING IN THERE WAS GENERAL
AGREEMENT THAT IT WAS- WASN'T
THE WORST BUT IT WAS PRETTY
UNWIELDY AND YOU KNOW THERE ARE
MULTIPLE STEPS- WHEREIN YOU
KINDA DEAD AND WHERE YOU'RE A
PAGE AND A NOT CLEAR WHAT YOU DO
HAVE TO GO BACK AND- YOU KNOW
THE OBSERVATION WAS THE YOU KNOW
THERE THERE ARE A WHOLE BUNCH OF
POINTS WERE SPECIALLY IN THIS
LABOR MARKET- WERE SOMEBODY WITH
OTHER LABOR YOU KNOW EMPLOYMENT
OPTIONS MIGHT ABANDON THIS- AND
GO LOOK FOR- SHOULD WORK
REQUIREMENT WORK ON SITES THAT
ARE MORE STREAMLINED SO WHAT'S-
YOU KNOW IS THE TO BITS OF THIS
BIG PROJECT OUTSIDE BUT WHAT
WHAT'S THE KIND OF CONNECTION
THINKING ISSUE AS YOU CONSIDER.
HOW TO DO THAT. IT AND I'M SORRY
IF I JUST ADD TO. A LOT ABOUT
WAY OF UP ALONG THOSE LINES. IS
THERE OF. YOU KNOW ISSUES WITH
APPLICATION TIMELINE. PROCESS
THAT YOU WOULD. OF PURSUE- A
LONG THE LINES OF WHAT SENATOR
NEWMAN WAS ASKING FOR A LETTER
AND I WOULD OUT OF ANY DO YOU
KNOW WHAT YOU MEAN I KNOW MISTER
WITH SOMEBODY DOES LIKE YOU KNOW
ARE WE TRACKING- THINGS LIKE YOU
KNOW THE YOU KNOW PROCESS
ABANDONMENT YOU KNOW WHAT
PERCENTAGE OF USERS. GET TO WHAT
POINT IN THIS IN THE PROCESS AND
THEN SEEKS TO CONTINUE.
MORISSETTE'S OR DROP OUT.
CORRECT NO. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND SENATOR NEWMAN- WE'VE
CERTAINLY HEARD OF SOME OF THE
FRUSTRATION- FUNDING FOR
CONQUERORS WOULD SURE THAT
NECESSARY UPDATES AND
ENHANCEMENTS. TO THE STATE JOBS
JOB SEARCH WEBSITES SUCH AS A
FIX SUCH UPDATE WITH- AND A
NUMBER OF ITEMS FOR EXAMPLE
INCREASE OVERALL USER EXPERIENCE
. YOU'RE UP FOR THE OF
INFORMATION HELLO IN ARABIC.
SITE AND DATA SECURITY
ACCESSIBILITY AND IF. INCREASED
OPTIMIZATION TO MOBILE DEVICES
BY LIMITING ROLLING PROVIDE
EASILY ACCESSIBLE WEBSITE
METRICS. AND ANALYTICS FOR
EXAMPLE THE NUMBER OF TIMES
USERS VISIT A CERTAIN CHARACTER
YOUR STAGE. BOB AND FOR ONGOING
IMPROVEMENT TO THE CALCULATOR
SITE. ADDITION ENHANCE JOBS
CABLE ACROSS ALL INDUSTRY
LEADING JOB RECRUITMENT
PLATFORMS. I DO NOT HAVE A TIME
LINE- THAT- THAT I CAN PROVIDE
YOU AT THE TIME BUT I'M HAPPY
TO- FOLLOW UP WITH THAT
INFORMATION. HEY I THINK I
ANSWERED ALL OF YOU KNOW I DID I
DIDN'T DIDN'T EXPECT ANSWERED
ALL BUT A DONE GONE GLAD TO HEAR
THAT IT'S CONSIDERED- YEAH AND I
GUESS YOU KNOW I'M I'M STILL.
KIND OF INTERESTED IN THIS
QUESTION OF WHAT WE KNOW WHAT IS
THE STANDARD OF THE END
OBJECTIVE THAT THAT'S- A
QUANTIFIABLE YOU KNOW BY WAY OF-
YOU KNOW THE MEASURE TO
IMPROVEMENT. AND THEN I TO TERRY
QUESTION TO BE YOU KNOW WHICH IS
ABOUT OUTRAGE YOU KNOW HOW HOW.
HOW DO YOU. JOBS J. YOU KNOW GET
. WITH THE STATE RUSSIAN BY
CLASSIC- CAL. AND WHAT'S THE IN
TERMS TO MAKE THAT BETTER- TO
BETTER. UP FOR SHE WOULD TO A-
DIVERSE PERSPECTIVES. THANK YOU
AT NEWMAN FOR THE FALL UP- FIRST
I WOULD NOTE THAT THE- IS- THESE
IT WE HAVE A FRONT THAT SO AGES
IN THE- ARE- I HAVE- HIRING. I
ADD THAT- MANY OF THE DATA-
FUNDING THAT WE'RE REQUESTING TO
CALIFORNIA LEADS WOULD. BE
DOCTOR TO SPECIALLY IN TARGETED
TARGETING- APPLIQUE. SO
CHARACTER YEARS IMPROVE IN TO.
THE AT HALF DATA COLLECT- AND
ANALYSIS WE ARE YOU CAN JUST
ANALYZING THE INFORMATION WE
CURRENTLY HAVE- WILL HOPEFULLY
HELP APARTMENT- BETTER TARGET-
DIFFERENT COMMUNITY. THANK YOU
MR CENTER BECAUSE HE HERE ARE
THE AT THE RISK OF SOUNDING
CRITICAL AND I DON'T. YEAH I'M
I'M GOOD THIS IS GOING FORWARD
BUT- I THINK. THE OUT REACH
QUESTION IS- IT I I'M NOT
HEARING THE ANSWER THAT I WAS
HOPING I WAS GOING TO HEAR FROM
CENTER NEWMAN'S QUESTION WHICH-
IT IT IT FEELS LIKE. THE
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE SYSTEM THOSE
FOR- ON WHAT I WOULD CALL THE
PASSIVE SIDE OF THE SYSTEM- IN
IT MAY NOT BE THE CASE MAYBE
IT'S JUST NOT IN OUR YOU KNOW ON
OUR REPORT HERE RECEIVE- IN
WRITING OR ORALLY- BUT THE POINT
OF COURSE OF. THE WEBSITE-
CENTRALIZED OR DECENTRALIZED I
DON'T I DON'T THINK CAL HR
LEADERS PREFER COLLEGE OR TO
SAY. YOU KNOW OUT REACH- ON THIS
IS GOING TO BE DECENTRALIZED THE
QUESTION WAS BUT OUR REGION
ABOUT REACHES CAN BE
DECENTRALIZED AND WE'RE WAY WAY
OFF I THINK WHERE WE WANT TO BE
THAT'S- GROUP THAT'S GONNA BE
COMPLETELY COUNTERPRODUCTIVE. I
THINK THE WHOLE POINT HERE. IF
YOU KNOW OF. YOU KNOW THE
DIRECTION THE ADMINISTRATION
WANTS TO GO IS TO. IS TO DRIVE
IMPLEMENT IN A MORE DIVERSE
MANNER WHICH MEANS DRIVE PEOPLE
TO THE WEBSITE. HOPEFULLY A
WEBSITE THAT WORKS BUT HOPE
DRIVE PEOPLE TO THE WEBSITE FROM
FROM EVERY SECTOR EVERY
DEMOGRAPHIC- YOU KNOW
ESSENTIALLY A UBIQUITOUS WAY. IN
THAT HAS TO BE DONE TO CENTRAL
IS WHERE IT IS. YOU KNOW
CERTAINLY DEPARTMENTS AND
DIVISIONS CAN GIVE INPUT AS TO-
IN IT WOULD HAVE TO PARTICIPATE
IN THAT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
OUT REACHES. AS IS EFFECTIVELY
DESCRIBING THE OPPORTUNITIES
THAT ARE AVAILABLE- BUT. YOU
KNOW HOPEFULLY. YOU KNOW HE DOES
NOT TO BUT- I. PART OF WHAT I'M
HEARING THE L. A. C. IS. YOU
KNOW GET REPORTS BACK ON THIS
LEGISLATURE YOU KNOW IF YOU'RE
WORRIED ABOUT THINGS LIKE THAT
IF YOU'RE WORRIED ABOUT HOW. A
PROGRESSIVE WERE AFFIRMATIVE THE
OUR REACH IS GOING TO BE IN A
USE THAT WORD IN THE LAYMAN'S
CONTEXT WHEN IS THE AFFIRMATIVE
BUT HOW HOW AGGRESSIVE IN
AFFIRMATIVE IS IT COULD BE. AN
PLEASURE TO BEGIN REPORTS BACK-
SO THAT WE CAN REVISIT THIS SO
WE DON'T GET DOWN SEVENTY YEARS
DOWN THE ROAD IN ESSENTIALLY
HAVE HAVE THE SAME PROBLEM- IT I
THINK THE OTHER THING THAT IT
WOULD BE IMPORTANT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO REVIEW IS NOT
ONLY. HAS TO DECIDE WHETHER OR
NOT THE RECRUITMENT IS BECOMING
MORE DIVERSE WITHIN OUR PEOPLE
WHO COME IN THROUGH THAT
EXPANDED THE FIRST RECRUITMENT
PROCESS BEING TAPPED ON THE
SHOULDER THE MANAGEMENT
OPPORTUNITIES YOU KNOW AS IN
EIGHT A YOU CAME IN THREE YEARS
AGO THROUGH THIS PROGRAM- IN.
WE'D LIKE TO HAVE YOU- YOU KNOW
BURN IT TO CERTAIN PEOPLE
BECAUSE WITHOUT THAT THERE'S NO
UPWARD MOBILITY IN TERMS OF
FUTURE. DIRECTORS AND-
ADMINISTRATORS AND PEOPLE WHO
BASED THE ARE CALLING THE SHOTS
SO I THINK ALL OF THAT IS POLICY
OF THE FORGET THE FUN THIS. IS A
LEGISLATURE WE SHOULD BE SAYING
WE'D LIKE TO COME BACK AND
REVIEW THE IMPLEMENTATION SIDE
OF IT TO MAKE SURE IT'S IT
REALLY IS. GOING IN THE- FROM
APOLLO STAMP THAT WE LIKE TO GO
SO. YOU MIGHT. CAN THE SOME CARE
IF I MAY- UP HELLO YES COURSE.
DEPARTMENT CURRENTLY REQUIRED TO
HAVE A PLAN TO INCREASE UPWARD
MOBILITY FOR STATE WORKERS AND
LITTLE THINGS THAT THEY
SHOULDN'T. RETIRING OF PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES. ADDITIONALLY
COUNTY CHAR LACKS THE STAFF OF
THE DATA WE HAVE ACCESS TO ANY
INFORMATION WE WANT TO GATHER TO
MAKE INFORMED DECISIONS. WITH A
FUNDING CHARACTER WILL BE ABLE
TO ANALYZE DATA DATA TO BETTER
INFORM OUR POLICIES AND
PROGRAMS. AND HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
DO THE THING. FOR EXAMPLE THE
DATA RESOURCES- THAT I MENTIONED
PREVIOUSLY WOULD ALLOW KELLY
CHART AND EMPOWERMENTS TO
ENHANCE THEIR PLANT- THEIR
CURRENT PLANS- AND- LOOK AT
ADDITIONAL TARGETED. RECRUITING. THE TWO THAT YOU'RE THAT'S
THAT'S APPRECIATED I'D I JUST.
MY SENSE IS MY FEELING IS AFTER
HEARING ALL THIS THAT. THERE
NEEDS TO BE A GREATER EMPHASIS
ON. WHAT YOU WERE JUST TALKING
ABOUT AT THE END THERE IN TERMS
OF- THE TARGETED RECRUITMENT. WE
ARE WE'RE IN A WORLD OF DATA AND
AGGREGATED DATA AND EVIDENCE
BASED DATA AND ALL THAT WE'RE
GONNA NEED TO SEE THE DATA THAT
YOU'RE DESCRIBING WHAT THE DATE
IS GOING TO SHOW WHAT WE ALREADY
KNOW IF THERE'S IF THERE'S NO
EFFECTIVENESS IN THE OUTREACH
FIVE YEARS FROM NOW IT'S GOING
TO. IS GONNA BE GREAT DATA BUT
THIS IS GOING TO SHOW SAME OLD
SAME OLD- DIFFERENT YEAR SAME
RESULTS IN LESS THE OUTREACH IS
REALLY EFFECTIVE SO PERHAPS WHAT
I'M ASKING FOR IS. YOU KNOW THE
ASSURANCE THAT WHAT WE'RE REALLY
DOING HERE IS DRAMATICALLY
ALTERING BOTH THE- THE
INVESTMENT IN AND THE AND THE
CULTURE AROUND- DIVERSE RECOUP
RECRUITMENT IN IN. IT TARGETING
IS OKAY I JUST WANNA SAY THIS
OUT LOUD BUT THE WORLD OUT THERE
IS ALREADY DIVERSE IF YOU DO
COMPREHENSIVE UBIQUITOUS OUT
REACH YOU GENERALLY WILL GET-
DIVERSE A DIVERSE APPLICATION
POOL IN IT SO HE- YOU KNOW I'M
I'M NOT HOLDING MYSELF ALL ITEMS
ACT AS AN EXPERT ON THIS BUT THE
EACH. ONE OF US UP HERE IN.
ASSEMBLY ANY WOULD CARDUS A
THEIR BACK WAS IN LEAD TO. RIGHT
NOW HAS THE SAME TASK YOU KNOW
EVEN IN THE MICRO LEVEL OF
RECRUITING ARE ON STAFF AND WE
KNOW WHEN WE GO OUT. THE
OBJECTIVE IS TO MAKE SURE THAT.
THAT THAT EVERY ORGANIZATION OUT
THERE THAT CAN PUSH THE MESSAGE
OUT THAT THESE OPPORTUNITIES
OROVILLE. DEMOCRATIC ALLIANCE
HAS TO BE ENGAGED IN IN HOUSE BE
TOUCH MULTIPLE TIMES WITHOUT
REACH. AND THEN THE HIRING POOL.
WILL BE WHAT YOU WANTED TO BE TO
. GREAT YES I'M SORRY I WAS THIS
THERE'S A COST COMPONENT TO OUR
REACH RIGHT WHICH BE CONSIDERED.
MOVING FORWARD AND I DON'T KNOW
THAT THAT'S BEEN CENTRAL TO THIS
CONVERSATION BUT THE E. NOTED
THAT'S ONE OF THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGES IN. HIRING AND
RECRUITMENT ISSUES BRANDON
MARKETING. BY MR ARE YOU YOU
MEANT- AND EMPHASIS ON DATA- YOU
KNOW TO INTERNALLY TO MAKE SMART
DECISIONS- I I'D SUGGEST AS YOU
DO THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL- CUT
ALONG THE WAY PER. SECRETARY'S
COMMENTS TO DEVELOP A DASHBOARD.
WHERE YOU KNOW THE LEGISLATURE
ALSO HAVE SOME INSIGHT. INTO
THAT DATA OVER TIME INTO
ADDITIONAL WE CAN GAUGE.
PROGRESS OVER TIME- AS IT
RELATES TO OBJECTIVES AND
DIVERSITY SO I. D. JUST A
THOUGHT I KNOW THIS SUMMIT WILL
REVISIT. OKAY THANK YOU- THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I WANNA. THANK A
MASSEUSE MISTER SCHROEDER MISTER
GET IT'LL OFFER UP FOR YOU BEING
HERE AND FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
APPRECIATE YOU- WE'RE GONNA HOLD
THIS PROPOSAL OPEN. AND MOVE ON
NOW TO PUBLIC COMMENT- AND THEN
AFTER THAT WE'LL TAKE OF THE
VOTE ONLY CALENDAR FILLED OUT
WITH MOVING ON TO ANYONE WANTING
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT
REGARDING ITEMS ON THE AGENDA-
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBERS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX
EIGHT ONE SIX THREE. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS SEVEN THREE SIX
TWO EIGHT THREE THREE DUE TO OUR
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE LENGTH
OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY AND
CLEANING PROTOCOLS- TODAY WE'RE
GOING TO LIMIT THE- A TIME OF.
PARTICIPANT TO WITHIN ONE MINUTE
MAXIMUM PLEASE- AND SO MISSED.
THE MODERATOR HELLO I'M SORRY WE
DO HAVE SOMEONE HERE ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM- SO UNUSED TO THAT. BUT
THANK YOU IT'S GREAT TO SEE
PEOPLE YEAH I THINK THE MORNING
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS- JENNIFER
FEARING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
NONPROFITS ALSO MEALS ON WHEELS
CALIFORNIA- AND I'M I'M ALSO
CARRYING THE TORCH FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PRIMARY CARE
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS AND
OTHERS. WHO ALL SIGNED ONTO A
LETTER ON IN MARCH AND WE SOME
OF US MET WITH YOU YESTERDAY AND
CHAIRMAN ISSUE TWENTY ONE
RELATED TO THE RELIEF- SENATOR
CORTESE WE WILL GET OUR LETTER
TO YOU RIGHT QUICK- BUT REST
ASSURED THAT THIS IS AN ISSUE IN
THE NONPROFIT COMMUNITY DEEPLY
GRATIFIED TO SEE THE SENATE
PROPOSAL INCLUDE- AND EFFORTS TO
TRY TO ADDRESS THAT RELIEF
THAT'S THAT'S DEEPLY NEEDED I.
WANTED TO JUST WRITE A FEW
THINGS THAT THAT WE TALKED ABOUT
YESTERDAY IN YOUR YOUR QUESTIONS
WERE WERE DEAD ON WE WOULD LOVE
TO WORK WITH L. A. L. WITH SOME
OF THE DATA THAT WE HAVE AROUND
THIS BUT- WE WOULD LOVE THERE
WERE THE TWO PROVISIONS THAT I
HEARD HIM SAY- NONPROFITS AND
SMALL BUSINESSES ON THE U. I.
REIMBURSEMENT PROVISION BUT IT
DOESN'T SAY HERE- WE WOULD LIKE
TO BE INCLUDED IN THAT. AND THAT
WOULD BE BENEFICIAL TO
NONPROFITS AS WELL- AS
EMPLOYERS- EIGHT A SUBSET DO
SELF INSURED BUT A SUBSET THERE
ARE SIGNIFICANT PORTION THAT
THAT DO NOT AND SO THAT WOULD BE
A BENEFICIAL IT FOR NONPROFITS
AS WELL I'M WE WOULD ASK THAT
CONSIDERATION OF RELIEF THROUGH.
THE PAYROLL TAX- NO CHANNEL BUT
TO IT TO WITH EDS THERE'S BUT
THERE MIGHT BE A WAY TO EXECUTE-
AT REPORTING BY EMPLOYERS AND
THEY GET A CREDIT. REPAIR OF
WHAT THE BURDENS ON BOTH OF
PURSUING PROBE. TAKE I ALSO
BELIEVE WOULD. WE BE A WAYS OFF
AND THEN LAW. YOU'D ABOUT
REMOVING THE CAP. ON EMPLOYERS
FROM. WE WILL STRONGLY. THAT
MANY HOME PROVIDERS HOSPITAL.
HOMES AND HEALTH CARE SERVICES
ARE LARGE ORGANIZATIONS THEY
HAVE A LOT OF EMPLOYEES BUT
THEY'RE STILL NONPROFITS AND
THEIR ABILITY TO ABSORB AS- WE
THINK F THERE'S A DESIRE TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO LIMIT. THIS TO
LOOK MORE AT THE AT THE
NONPROFIT TYPE ARE THE TYPE OF
EMPLOYEE THAT NEEDS TO BE
REPLACED WITH ANOTHER EMPLOYEE
WHEN THEY'RE OUT BECAUSE OF THE
SERVICE THAT'S DELIVERED. THAT'S
MORE CRITICAL- TO US THE MORE
RELEVANT AND TO US IF THERE
NEEDS TO BE A LIMIT RATHER THAN
JUST PICKING UP A SIZE OF
ORGANIZATION AND CAPPING IT THAT
BELIEVE. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH ALL OF YOU AND
APPRECIATE YOUR ATTENTION ON
THIS THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
PLEASE. HI GOOD MORNING- CHAIR
AND MEMBERS CAN ALSO MAINLY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION.
WANTED TO SPEAK TOWARDS ITEM. OR
ISSUE TWENTY TWO ON THE UC
WORKERS RIGHTS OUT POLICY
COLLABORATIVE AND- APPRECIATE
ALL OF YOU ON THE DÍAS WHO HAVE
WORKED HARD TO PORTIONS- SUPPORT
THIS IN. AS A SENATE BUDGET
PRIORITY. OF THE IMPACT OF THE
UC LABOR CENTERS HAVE ON PUBLIC
POLICY AND RESEARCH. AFFECTS THE
LIVES OF CALIFORNIA WORKERS- AND
WE NEED TO ADEQUATELY.
ADEQUATELY FUND ARE YOU SEE
LABOR CENTERS TO SUPPORT THIS
CRITICAL RESEARCH. THEY HAVE
DONE FOR OVER FIFTY YEARS. IT'S
BEEN A FEW DECADES- SINCE THE
LABOR CENTERS HAVE RECEIVED
ADDITIONAL FUNDING- AND THIS
WOULD REALLY HELP TO BUILD THE
CAPACITY OF THE LABOR CENTERS TO
CONTINUE THAT CRITICAL-
EDUCATION RESEARCH THAT THEY
PROVIDE THE STATE SO. REALLY
APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU. OKAY SCENE NO MORE-
WITNESSES HERE IN THE ROOM WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TWO. OUR
TELECONFERENCE COLLINS MODERATOR
IF YOU PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT AND WE WILL BEGIN. AND
IF YOU COULD LET IS THE NUMBER
OF MONEY HE WOULD LET US KNOW
HOW MANY INDIVIDUALS ARE WAITING
TO COMMENT. AT THIS TIME WE
ALREADY HAVE A THIRTEEN QUEUED
UP I HAVEN'T GIVE INSTRUCTIONS
ON WHAT YOU KNOW AS SOON AS
THEY- GIVE THE INSTRUCTIONS
LEAGUE IS GERMAN IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO- TESTIFY. ON ANY OF THE
ITEMS ON TODAY'S AGENDA PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ONE
FILED BY ZERO. EIGHTY P. OPERATE
WILL QUICKLY GIVE YOUR LIFE
NUMBER OFF MY IN THE PLACE YOU
BACK AND YOU GET ONE ZERO FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT- MADAM CHAIR IT
LOOKS LIKE RIGHT NOW WE HAVE
BUT- WAS THE THIRTY IN Q. FOUR
TWENTY. YEP RIGHT AT THIRTY. SO
WILL BEGIN TODAY WITH A LINE
THIRTY EIGHT. PLEASE GO AHEAD
THIRTY EIGHT. GOOD MORNING THIS
IS SERRA BONTA ON BEHALF OF
FIRST FIVE CALIFORNIA STRONG
SUPPORT OF ITEM SIXTEEN PAID
FAMILY LEAVE FOR LOW INCOME
WORKERS NO PARENT SHOULD HAVE TO
MAKE THE CHOICE BETWEEN BOND
BEING WITH THEIR NEWBORN CHILD
AND THE FINANCIAL SECURITY AND
FUTURE. IT IS CRITICAL TO
PRIORITIZE AN INCREASE IN WAGE
REPLACEMENT RATES FOR PAID
FAMILY LEAVE SPECIFICALLY WE
NEED TO INCREASE THE WAGE
REPLACEMENT RATE FOR LOWER WAGE
WORKERS WHO 90% AND TO FIND
LOWER WAGE WORKERS OF THOSE
EARNING UNDER APPROXIMATELY.
EACH WEEKLY RANGE EITHER
CRITICAL PIECES TO THE PUZZLE
EVERY CHILD DESERVES TO SPEND
TIME WITH THEIR FAMILY BONDING
WITH THEIR LOVING PARENTING CARE
GIVER ESTABLISHING A FOUNDATION
OF LIFE FOR THE CLASS WE THANK
SENATOR DIRECTOR FOR CHAMPIONING
THAT MADE THIS ISSUE AND WITH
THAT WE REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT
PLEASE RIGHT THANK YOU MEDICARE
LINE FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD
. MORNING MY NAME IS SERGIO AND
WITH THE CALIFORNIA RECURSOS
ECON AND CALLING IN STRONG.
CLINTON QUICKLY REACHED ASSEMBLY
. AFTER MY PERCENT LOAN FAMILIES
AND FAMILIES ARE ON THE. ONLY
BOND WITH THE BABY FOR THE
EATING AND BAKING THE TIME THAT
THEY ARE IN TO IT THANK THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR THE NEXT. ONE
FIFTY FOUR YOUR OPEN. MANJERI
MEMBERS SEVERAL AFTER HE W.
APPLE VERY NICE VERY AND FOR
FORTY THOUSAND I COULDN'T HAVE
YOUR WORK. AND WE YOUR SUPPORT
BUT THEY NEED WAY OR IS THE
OTHER BILLING COVERED ON I.
TWENTY YOU I LOOK I LIKE
IMPORTANT OF RETURN INCREASE
ORIENT FOR I A PROVIDERS AFTER
THAT YOU FOR THE WORK WRITTEN
SURE IF COMMON WORK RIGHT.
THANKS ARE PROVIDERS UNDERSTAND
IF. ON THE JOB IN WALDRON.
TO PROVIDE THIRTEEN MILLION FOR
THE C. WORKER RIGHT POLICY
COLLABORATIVE. AND ALL THE
SUPPORT THE PROPOSED CHANGES THE
NEW EMPLOYEE ORIENTATION YEAH.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. PLEASE GO
AHEAD EIGHTY NINE. MEDICARE
NUMBERS AND DATA ON BEHALF OF
THE LOS ANGELES- WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF. NUMBER TWENTY
TWO THE MULTI UNION TRAINING
CENTER AS WELL AS THE NEW
EMPLOYEE ORIENTATION AND ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF THE S. P. LABOR
CENTER FUNDING. OF THE PURPOSES
OF THIS HEARING ON BEHALF OF THE
U. S. B. W. BUT THE STATE
COUNCIL IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
MULTI UNION TRAINING CENTER IN
LOS ANGELES IT WOULD BE A JOINT
PROJECT AS YOU LIKE HERE LOCAL
ELEVEN. HE W. SEVENTH SEVENTY
CAN BE L. A. COUNTY ORANGE
COUNTY BUILDING TRADE IN
TRAINING THE NEXT GENERATION OF
SKILLED WORKERS BACKGROUND THE
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU SO. MUCH
THANK YOU FOR CALLING. THE
PLEASE. EIGHTY ONE YOU ARE OPEN. ONE I CAN'T REMEMBER. AB ONE
CAMERA BUDGET OFFICE CALLING ON
BEHALF OF CENTER FROM THE UP VIA
HI ON A SHE SEVEN. HE WITH
LITTLE NATION WITH REENTRY WITH
OVER FORTY YEARS OF EXPERIENCE
EXCLUSIVELY SERVING PEOPLE
RECENTLY RELEASED FROM
INCARCERATION THE- THE SOCIAL
ENTERPRISE NONPROFIT THAT
PROVIDES PEOPLE RETURNING FROM
INCARCERATION WITH IMMEDIATE
PAID EMPLOYMENT LOCATIONAL
INSTILLS TRAINING AND ONGOING
CAREER SUPPORT. THE IT'S
CURRENTLY THIRD HAND COUNTY
REGIONS IN CALIFORNIA WITH
OFFICES IN OAKLAND SACRAMENTO
SOLANO MARIN SAN JOSE FRESNO LOS
ANGELES NEIGHBORHOOD YOU KNOW
AND RIVERSIDE AND SAN DIEGO OR
ALIENATING ORGANIZATION NOW
SERVES AN AVERAGE OF THREE
THOUSAND PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA
ANNUALLY IN OUR PROGRAM HAS
PROVEN TO INCREASE EMPLOYMENT
LONG TERM AND REDUCE RECIDIVISM. AMONG PROGRAM PARTICIPANTS.
FOLLOW BACK AND FORTH THIS
INVESTMENT THANK YOU FOR CBO
PROVIDE A THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR THE- THANK AND THAT ARE
DROUGHT THAT. THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. ONE EIGHTY FIVE YOU ARE
OPEN. GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN
QUICKLY ON THE OF THE SYMBOL
RIGHTS TELL. I WILL SUPPORT-
HELPFUL LEADS AND IT SHOULD
ADVISED SEVENTY OVER ONE- BUT
WE'D LIKE TO ALIGN COLOR WILL
THOSE BY THE OFFICE OF THE OF.
STATE WITH THIS. I WOULD SIMPLY
THAT THAT WE JUST SET.
REVITALIZATION STICK O'CLOCK
OPEN ALL DISABILITY OTHERS. ALL
PROP- WITH THIS ITEM THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU CALLING NEXT
. ONE SEVEN YOUR- FOR SEVEN IF
I'M HERE CAN YOU HEAR ME YES GO
AHEAD. I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS ANY HER ARGUE BEHALF OF
THE NATIONAL MEDICAL CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION AND UNITED
CONTRACTORS- REPRESENTING OVER
FIFTEEN HUNDRED UNION
CONSTRUCTION CONTRACTORS IN THE
STATE- YOU KNOW WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
ONE WHICH WOULD PROVIDE RELIEF
FOR OUR UNION- EMPLOYERS TO
PROVIDE PAID. LEAVE WE MET WITH
MANY OF THE- COMMITTEE MEMBERS
TO DISCUSS HOW- DETRIMENTAL THAT
LEAVE HAS BEEN ON OUR EMPLOYERS
TO THE FACT THAT WE PAY SUCH
HIGH WAGES AND- WE'RE VERY
THANKFUL THAT THIS ITEM HAS BEEN
INCLUDED- ARE WE CONFUSION AS IF
THE REFERENCE TO HUNDRED FIFTY
EMPLOYEE THRESHOLD ON THE PAY
COVERTLY WOULD APPLY TO ALL
EMPLOYERS. UP TO THEIR FIRST
HUNDRED FIFTY EMPLOYEES WHO TOOK
THE LEAVE FOR A BETTER PRICE TO
ALL EMPLOYEES WHO TOOK A LEAVE
OF EMPLOYERS WITH LESS THAN A
HUNDRED FIFTY EMPLOYEES- YOU
KNOW WE REALLY HOPE THE FORMER-
WE'RE LOOKING FOR SOME CLARITY
IN OUR ARE ARE HAPPY TO DISCUSS
MAYBE SOME OPTIONS TO BUY
TICKETS NUMBER. TO A PLACE TO
WORK FOR THE PARKS- OF- THE UNIT
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY- BUT WAS
ADVANCED THANK OUT VERY HAPPY
DECIDED THAT THERE AND WE WOULD
ORG PORT ITEM NUMBER TWENTY ONE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS.
THANK YOU. NINE NINETY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. IN YEAR NOT.
OUT CALLING STRONG SUPPORT OF
ISSUE NUMBER TO INCREASE WAY FOR
RATE- A FAMILY BELIEVE AND THE
LANTERN 90% THE LOWER
CALIFORNIANS. NEED ONE IS SURE
THAT MOST HELP WHO PAID FOR IT
L. AND S. YEAH AT THE STATE. A
FORTY VAGUELY FROM ONE WITH A
NEW. RECOVER FROM THEIR OWN L.
OR CHARACTERS KNOW FAMILY. WHAT
THANK YOU. WHY NINE THREE EURO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES GO AHEAD. THANK YOU YEAH ONE
FIVE I'M POLICY OF BOB THIS IS A
CHARITY A RESTRICTION THEM ON
THE REPRESENT EIGHTY FIVE
THOUSAND BUSINESS OWNERS NAY.
FOR CALLING INTO OF NUMBER
SIXTEEN- IN THE WAY AND THANK
RIGHT FOR LOW WAGE WORKERS FOR
FAMILY LEAVE EIGHT. AND BECAUSE
MOST OF THEM AMERICAN THAT IT
MAKES IT FUN TO TAKE CARE OF
THEM. AND ALSO FOR TRIP HOW AND
PROUD WORK BECAUSE UNFORTUNATELY
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS DON'T HAVE
THE RESOURCES TO OFFER ROBUST
BENEFIT PACKAGES- LIKE EIGHT
FAMILY AND MEDICAL LEAVE- IN
ADDITION TO HEALTHCARE IN
RETIREMENT. BUT I'M AT A
DISADVANTAGE WHEN IT COMES TO
ATTRACTING AND. RETAINING
EMPLOYEES. CAN I ARGUE THAT ITEM
NUMBER SIX TO INCREASE THE
WEIGHT. RATE FOR- EMPLOYEE WELL
EIGHT WAIT EMPLOYEES IN THE
PAPER LEAVE AND STATE. AND
PROGRAM THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT PLEASE. MY NINETY FIVE YOUR. GOOD MORNING THIS IS NOT A
ABOUT THE AS YET CAL- IN ON A OF
ITEMS AND- ISSUED TWO FIVE THAT
PARTICULAR WANNA SUPPORT ON THE
UCLA CENTER POLICY RIGHT COOPER
THIRTEEN MILLION- ONGOING
FUNDING PROPOSAL- ALSO CALLING
IN SUPPORT- OF THAT STATEWIDE
COALITION FOR WORKER POWER TO
ENCOURAGE YOU TO APPROVE
INCREASING FUNDING FOR THE
STATE'S ANTI RETALIATION
INFRASTRUCTURE BOB ENERGY JOB
PLEASE- INCREASES FACE
RETALIATION FROM LAKE
INVESTIGATION UNIT TO TWENTY ONE
MILLION DOLLARS. A CONTINUES-
COVERED NIGHT THE TEAM WORKER
OUTREACH PROGRAM OR C. W. O. P.
AB ONE HUNDRED MILLION THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU FOR CALLING
NEXT PLEASE. ONE NINETY SIX YOUR
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
THE COMMITTEE ONLY A GRIPPING
WITH THE AMERICAN FEDERATION OF
STATE COUNTY MUNICIPAL
EMPLOYEES. AND FROM SUPPORT AT
ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY TWO UPDATE
THE NEW EMPLOYEE ORIENTATION
LOCK PUBLIC EMPLOYEES ONE OF THE
MANY THINGS THAT THE PANDEMIC
HAS SHOWN US IS THAT WE NEED TO
TAKE PROACTIVE STEPS TO GET BACK
THE ORIGINAL INTENT OF THE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN BUDGET
LANGUAGE. WOULD HAVE TO ALLOW
THE UNION TO ENGAGE WITH NEW
EMPLOYEES IN PERSON AT THE
WORKPLACE AND THAT'S WHERE OUR
EMPLOYEES ARE REPORTING TO WORK.
IT'S CRITICAL THAT NEWLY HIRED
EMPLOYEES ARE ABLE TO MEET WITH
THE UNION TO GO OVER THE RIGHTS
AND RESPONSIBILITIES THAT COME
WITH GOING AND THEY KNOW HOW TO
ACT WITH THE UNION FORTY THREE
DEMOCRATS FROM SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR CALLING NEXT
PLEASE. WELL ONLINE SO ONE.
MEDICARE MEMBERS ANY GIRL WITH
S. ARE YOU LOOK FOR THOUSAND ALL
IN IN STRONG OR THE THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS ON A THEY USED
IT CENTER WORKER POLICY RIGHT I
WORK THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
CALLING NECK PLEASE. OVERLYING
YOU ARE OPEN. AB WATER THAT'S
WHAT THEY CALL WORK AND FAMILYCOALITION CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF ISSUES AFFECTING TO
INCREASE WEIGHT REPLACEMENT RATE
FOR PAID FAMILY AND STATE
INSURANCE THE 90% OR LOWER
INCOME CALIFORNIANS DEFINED AS
THOSE MAKING LESS THAN 70% THE
STATE AVERAGE WEEKLY WAGE ABOUT
FIFTY SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR IN TWENTY TWENTY TWO ALL
CALIFORNIANS DESERVE TO BE ABLE
TO RECOVER FROM ILLNESS BOND
WITH A NEW BABY OR CARE FOR
YOURSELF AND THE RIGHT NUMBER
WITHOUT RISKING THEIR FINANCIAL
SECURITY THANK. YOU THANK YOU
FOR CALLING NEXT PLEASE. WHY
TWENTY PLEASE AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME'S BEEN CLEARER
FOR US AND I'M CALLING ON BEHALF
OF PUBLIC COUNSEL IN STRONG
SUPPORT IT ISSUE SIXTEEN. TO
INCREASE WEIGHT REPLACEMENT RATE
FOR PAID FAMILY LEAVE AND STATE
DISABILITY INSURANCE THE 90% OR
LOWER INCOME CALIFORNIANS. THANK
YOU THING FOR THE HEALTH AND
WELL BEING OF FAMILY OR
PROVIDING FINANCIALLY ISN'T ONE
THAN ANYONE SHOULD HAVE TO MAKE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT PLEASE. WELL LINE. SIXTY
EIGHT. MULLIN CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE WRONG- CALLING ON BEHALF OF
HOUSE COULD ACTION IN THE STATE
LIKE CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
WORKER POWER. YOU NEED TO
INCREASE THE FUNDING FOR THE
STATE'S INTEREST INFRASTRUCTURE
OR IF YOU NEED TO INCREASE THE
RETALIATION COMPLAINT
INVESTIGATION UNIT BUDGET TWENTY
ONE MILLION INTO COMPUTER CODE
WORKOUT WHICH PROGRAM WHAT IS
THE LAW AND. ONE HUNDRED MILLION
. YOU KNOW THE EFFECTIVE
ENFORCEMENT OF LIMITS BUT THIS
MONTH CHOIRS MY FROM. AND IN THE
PAST YEAR HE WHILE. IF YOU COULD
BECAUSE- TO CONDUCT OUR- MORE
THAN A HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND.
HEALTH IN LANGUAGE DIRECT IN THE
WORKPLACE WITH A MISSION. SO
THAT WORKERS COULD STAY IN. WHEN
YOU HAVE POSSIBLE THE WHAT IFS
AND LOOK.
OF PETITIONS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR CALLING NEXT PLEASE. I
NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MICHELLE CAPRICA
SERVICE REQUIRED INTERNATIONAL
UNION CALLING ON ITEM TWENTY TWO
SPECIFICALLY- THE PROPOSED
MODIFICATIONS TO THE NEW
EMPLOYEE ORIENTATIONS LAW
RESERVE INTENDED THE WRITTEN LAW
WE- STRONG SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT PLEASE. MY NINETY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
KONG FENG AND THE EXECUTOR OF
JOBS WITH JUSTICE SAN FRANCISCO
I'M CALLING ON ISSUE TWENTY AND
TWENTY THREE TO INCREASE THE
STATE'S RETALIATION COMPLAINT
INVESTIGATION UNIT AND ALSO THE
CALL THE WORKER OUTREACH PROGRAM
AS WE LOOK AT HAVING A JUST
RECOVERY OR IMPROVING JOB
QUALITY WE REALLY NEED WORKERS
TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK OUT INSERT
THE LIFE AND TO DO THAT WE NEED
TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT
RETALIATION. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THANK PLEASE. FIFTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE FIFTY FIVE-
I'M SORRY AND- HELLO THERE- GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MAKE THE
THREE ON THE DIRECTOR BERMAN IN
THE HEADQUARTERS LOCATED THE
CALIFORNIA THE OPEN BUT WE FOR
CALIFORNIA IN GENERAL AND I'M
CALLING TODAY A SUPPORT ISSUE
NINETEEN THE WOMEN
INFRASTRUCTURE PRIORITY UNIT AS
PART OF THE VR- WE HAVE SEEN AND
YOU FOR TODAY AND WE CAN PROVIDE
YOU FOR INFORMATION ABOUT HOW.
THE FOCUS ON STRONG PATHWAYS
BUILDING ECONOMIC FUTURES FOR
CALIFORNIA IS AVAILABLE TO WOMEN
IN THE CONSTRUCTION TRADES AND
WE CAN BUILD THESE OPPORTUNITIES
AS WELL AS COORDINATING SOME OF
THE VERY A REDUCTION- THAT THE
STRUCTURE OF THE MENTIONED TDAY
THERE ARE MANY GOOD MODEL WAYS
THAT- WORKING THE NEW YORK THE
SUPPORT. OF MORE FUTURE AND
BETTER OUTCOMES FOR WOMEN TO
INSURE AND THANK YOU VERY. MUCH
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. PLEASE GO
AHEAD LINE SHOULD. GOOD MORNING
MY IS THE FOR AND EXECUTOR
DIRECTOR THE HOUSE TRAINING
ACADEMY IN LOS ANGELES THE
TRAINING ARM OF UNITE HERE LOCAL
ELEVEN I'M ALSO SPEAKING FOR
SEASON MONADO CO PRESIDENT OF
UNITE HERE LOCAL ELEVEN AND THE
BOARD CHAIR OF THE HOSPITALITY
TRAINING ACADEMY. WE ARE SPEAK
AND SPEAK IN FAVOR OF THE MALTA
UNION TRAINING CENTER FOR ITEM
TWENTY TWO WE BELIEVE THAT THE
PURCHASE OF A BUILDING TO HOUSE
OUR PROGRAM ALONG WITH THE END
OF THE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES IN YOUR FEET OF THE ALONG
WITH THE COUNTY THE ONLY COUNTY
FEDERATION OF LABOR WILL BE A
GAME CHANGER FOR THAT COMMUNITY
AND WHAT IT TAKES TO ENSURE A
FULL PANDEMIC RECOVERY FOR ONCE
DEVASTATED. HOSPITALITY INDUSTRY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU FOR CALLING NEXT PLEASE.
NINE TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR
CAREER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
PROPOSAL INCLUDED IT ISSUE
NUMBER TWENTY TWO WHICH WOULD
MODIFY THE NEW EMPLOYEE
ORIENTATION THAT YOU TO REFLECT
ACT THE CHALLENGES CREATED BY
THE PANDEMIC THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR CALLING. NEXT PLEASE. ONE
SIXTY ONE YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD
MORNING TURN MEMBERS OF THE
MARJORY FROM BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA EDGE COALITION
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORTER OF
THE PROPOSED ONE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA YOUTH SUPPORT WHICH
WILL PROVIDE OUR NUMBER IN
CAREER PATHWAYS AND CLUSTER IT'S
OPPORTUNITY YOUTH. OPPORTUNITIES
WITH FACING THE CONCORD BARRIERS
OFTEN DO NOT ALIGN WITH
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AFTER
BIRTH CONTROL ABOUT OR TAKING A
COMMUNITY WILL EXPAND THE POOL
OF TALENT THAT EMPLOYERS CAN
ACTED TO MAKE THEIR FOR
QUESTIONING FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY URGE THE COMMITTEE
TO THE COMMISSION. THANK YOU
THANK. YOU FOR CALLING. NEXT
PLEASE. TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. READ MORE ONE OF THE
OTHER MADAM CHAIR THAT ARE OFTEN
NEWMAN CRICKET FEE OF NINETEEN
THAT MOMENT NOT AND THE DEAN OF
AGRICULTURE IN IN THE STUDIES AT
THE END THE COLLEGE A GRADUATE
OF EAST LA COMMUNITY COLLEGE OUT
OF HARVARD GRAD SCHOOL OF
EDUCATION AND COMPLETED IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF ISSUE NUMBER
EIGHTEEN ALLOCATION CALIFORNIA
YOUTH LEADERSHIP CORPS. THE
QUICK POINT TO MAKE IS THAT
MONDAY IN THE WAKE OF THE CHORE
BUT HAD TO BE ABLE TO RAISE
AWARENESS OF STRUCTURAL RACISM
AND IMPEDIMENT IS THE
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR- DID I
BELIEVE THAT THIS GOT BOTH THIS.
ISSUE EIGHTEEN WILL BE A STRONG
SUPPORT IN THE OPPOSITE
DIRECTION CREATING STRUCTURAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR MARCH
HISTORICALLY MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES YEAH THE FUTURE OF
THIS PROGRAM IS THAT IT BUILDS
STRONG COMMUNITY AND SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL HEALING AND WELLNESS
AMONG ITS PARTICIPANTS HAVE BEEN
EXCEPTIONAL MODEL THAT ADDRESSES
MULTIPLE LEVELS OF
TRANSFORMATIVE CHANGE AND I
STRONGLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT SO
MUCH. YOU. NEXT PLEASE. OVER ONE
SEVENTY SIX. HELLO IF YOU HAVE
THAT IN IS PLAYING UP OF THE
THEY EMMA FEET THANK YOU. FOR-
THIRTY SAMPLE THE WHO HIMSELF
AND HOW LIKE PRUDENT. YES THEY
ARE HANDLING WITH THE EFFORT ON
JANUARY. ELEVENTH SENSE BUT IT'S
HELL IS IT LIKE- THAT RESIDENTS
AND THE IN OTHER LESSONS ALSO
FOR YOU PETER HALLIDAY. LANE
BECAUSE THERE. WELCOME I'LL PUT
BELIEVE IF THAT. THEY WITH. IF
THE ONLY EMOTION IF CARILLO
FOUND THE WHO YEAH HELLO A LOT
GOOD AT IT IS THIS A FOR THE IS
NOT A LITTLE GIRL THAT THE
MONEY. AROUND LITTLE. UP THERE
THAT. WOULD BE IT TOOK THANK GOD
HE DOES FEEL IS ANYTHING BUT I
MEAN. BUT I HAVE THAT I HOPE
THAT THE MEETING. ELEVEN GROCERY
L. ONE THE LAST EATING PLACE
OKAY FIFTY KNOW THE I WAS THERE
. GASEOUS IN THE RELEVANT FONG.
IS LAST YEAR LA LUZ YEAH LAST.
OKAY- SO GLASSES EMMA. NEXT
THANK YOU A LINE NINETY SO WEEK
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THE CARLESS
THAT LEGAL SERVICE IN SUPPORT OF
ISSUE TO TWO SPECIFICALLY. THE
SIX TWO DR TORE THANK. AT THE IT
WAS ONE OF THE COSTA OF THE
SIXTY THE GUY WORKER PROTECT
ACT- IN THE BURKE AS THE LAST
MOMENT BECAUSE- THERE WERE YOU
DRAFTING ERRORS OCCURRED AND
THIS- WILL FIX THOSE ERRORS AND
RESTORE. IT WITH YOUR INTENT OF
THE LAW AS WELL AS CORRECTING.
IF YOU DRAFTING ERRORS SO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU
FOR CALLING NEXT PLEASE.
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. RALPH
BLACK WITH THE EXCEPTION ATION
OF CALIFORNIA STATE EMPLOYEES
WITH DISABILITIES. SPEAKING ARE
IN SUPPORT OF ITEM TWENTY THREE
THE CALIFORNIA LEADS- PROJECT
BUT WE DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS
ABOUT THE ITEM- DAY
REPRESENTATION RATE FOR PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES IN STATE
GOVERNMENT HAS BEEN STEADILY
DECLINING AND OUR ORGANIZATION
HAS BEEN WORKING WITH CAL HR TO
TRY TO. FIGURE OUT HOW TO
REVERSE THAT TREND BUT WE
REALIZE THAT THEY NEED
ADDITIONAL STAFFING TO BE ABLE
TO MAKE PROGRESS AND WE SUPPORT
THIS ABOUT WE NOTE THAT OUT OF
ALL OF THE DECISIONS AUTHORIZED
UNDER THIS ITEM. TWO OR THREE
WILL BE TO VOTE TO THE CIVIL
RIGHTS UNIT WHICH WOULD ADDRESS
DISABILITY EMPLOYMENT ISSUES AND
WE THINK THERE NEEDS TO BE A
GREATER FOCUS. IN THAT AREA. IN
ADDITION THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
NOT DISCLOSED WHICH OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON DISABILITY
EMPLOYMENT THAT CAME OUT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S TASK FORCE. ARE GONNA
BE IMPLEMENTED SO WE'D LIKE TO
SEE A PROCESS WHERE OUR
ORGANIZATION AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS WOULD HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH CAL HR
TO DEVELOP A MORE DETAILED PLANS
SO THAT THESE RESOURCES GET USED
IN THE MOST EFFECTIVE WAY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
CALLING NEXT PLEASE. ONE EIGHTY
FOR EUROPE. HELLO CARE MY
MANAGER MEMBERS YEAH THAT THE
PERFORMANCE PART BEEN BURNING IN
STRONG SUPPORT TECHNICIAN AND
THEN FIGURE THE ONE TIME BUDGET
REQUEST A FIFTY MINUTE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT FOR THE RE ENTRY
POPULATION I THINK HOME ON
AUGUST TWENTY EIGHTH TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN GOT CONNECTED
WE FEEL WHO WE SLATER THE- OF
RCS PRACTICES AND PROGRAMS
AVAILABLE TO HELP YOU GET BACK
ON MY FEET BY PROVIDING A
SAVINGS ACCOUNT A STABLE INCOME
IN CONSTANT WORK FROM THE TEAM.
THIS IS A ONE TIME INVESTMENT
FOR ONE FIRST DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAM THAT WILL CONTINUE TO
HELP INDIVIDUALS THANK YOU ONE
POINT SEVEN. MEANS TO PROVIDE
BEEN SUCCESSFULLY INTEGRATE BACK
INTO SOCIETY THE REASON WE ASK
THAT THE STATE TO SUPPORT THE
BUDGET LLOCATION THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
FOR CALLING NEXT PLEASE. WE WILL
GO NINE NINE. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES GO AHEAD HI MY NAME IS
FINALLY LANDING ADVANTAGE OF THE
THING. WHEN CALLING THE STATE
FOLLOW WHO AVAILABLE POWER THANK
HEARD YOU CAN THROUGH THE OTHER
FOR THE EIGHT AND TALLY THIS
ISSUES TWENTY AND POINT THREE
THAT INCLUDES THE TWENTY ONE
MILLION- FUNDING INCREASE FOR
THE- BURKE HOW OF THE COMMISSION
WILL. AND TO CONTINUE THE CO THE
BOOKER OF PROGRAM OR WHAT AT A
HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS BELT
SUPPORT THE YOU- SUPPORT ME
FEMURS AND CENTER. HAPPIER HI
THIS SHANNON DECORATIVE FELL OFF
ACCORDING TO AND THAT OUTREACH
AND EDUCATION THOUSAND OF
GOVERNMENT WORKERS WHO LIMITED
ENGLISH AT OF THE HOUSE CALLING
ME WE'VE ALSO PARTNERED WITH THE
STATE MAY COMMISSION OFFICE JUST
WORKERS IN RECOVERY I KNOW TO
MAKE THAT THAT ONLY. FOR
RETALIATION INCLUDING CUTTING
FIRING WHAT AND HER WOMEN WHICH
HAVE HAD TO TRY DISSUADE WORKERS
ABOUT WE KNOW THAT QUESTIONABLE
ULTIMATELY LED HOLD THE FLOOR.
WONDERSTRUCK FIFTEEN OKAY THEN
WE'RE GONNA CUT DOWN THE TIME TO
OUR HALF A MINUTE SO OF PLEASE
EVERYONE- OF MAXIMUM OF THIRTY
SECONDS HALF A MINUTE THANK YOU
ALL GO HEAD MODERATOR. WE'LL GET
WE'LL GO LINE FIFTY YOU ARE OPEN
. HELLO IN HERE ME YES GO AHEAD
. I'M GOOD DAY MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS UNFOLDING HEALTHY FONG
MEDINA BACK FORWARD FOUNDATION
NUMBER OF EIGHT WHITE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR WORK FOR POWER
RECALLING HIM COURAGE THE SAMPLE
MEETING INCREASE FUNDING FOR IT
EIGHT ON PROVISIONAL
INFRASTRUCTURE BACK HE WILL URGE
IT TO CONFISCATE QUALITY. AND
COMPLIANCE. ASIAN UNIT ONE ONE
MILLION THE HOBBIT CALIFORNIA
WORK ALL THREE PROGRAM WITH YOU
WHAT A HUNDRED. THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU NEXT PLAY. EIGHTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALONG WITH
FORMER HAVE THE WOMAN OF THE FOR
THE CONSERVATIVE THE ALL THE
HOLDEN NOT OF THE GLASS NOT YEAH
THREE HUNDRED HOW YES YES THE
ARE. THE EUROPEAN ALLIES IN THE
WHAT I DID I WILL PUT A LOT OF
THE.
WHAT AM I TO GO AHEAD AND IT
NEXT PLEASE. ALL RIGHT WE'LL ALL
GO TO LOOK SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD SEVENTY FOUR. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS DAN AND I'M
CALLING WITH GREAT COMPANY GREAT
WORKERS ALLIANCE. AND HOUSEHOLD
HOMELESS BEFORE WHAT THE PART IN
STOCK OR IF ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
TWENTY THREE TO INCREASE FUNDING
FOR THE STATE AND FEDERAL
TAXATION. OF THE SECTOR THANK
YOU FOR CALLING. NEXT PLEASE.
ONE ONE YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR FROM THE
ON BEHALF OF YOUR W. WESTERN
STATES CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THE
THIRTEEN MILLION DOLLAR
ALLOCATION I'M GOING FUNDING FOR
THE LABOR CENTERS YOUR W.
REPRESENT EVEN RESEARCHERS
POSTDOCS AND ACADEMIC
RESEARCHERS WHO WORK AT THE
LABOR CENTERS. INVALUABLE
RESEARCH FOR STATE- AND WE HAVE
USED TO SUPPORT THE FUNDING AND
SUPPORT OUR MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU FOR CALLING
NEXT PLEASE. NINE EIGHTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. EIGHTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE AND MY
NAME IS ANTHONY AND I'LL
RIVERSIDE I'M CALLING STRONG
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY DISABILITY
YOU DELIVER THERE'S WERE CORRECT
COOPERATIVE YOU THINK THEY WERE
JUST A CRITICAL PUBLIC SERVICES
WHICH AND EVIDENTIAL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU FOR CALLING
NEXT PLEASE. MY NINETY EIGHT
PLEASE CALL. GOOD MORNING GUSMAN
ON BEHALF OF THE TEAMSTERS- IN
TO SUPPORT THE CHANGES TO THE
NEW EMPLOYEE ORIENTATION AND
ALSO THE- THIRTEEN MILLION AN
ONGOING FUNDING FOR THE UC LABOR
CENTER THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
. ONE OH FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI BENEFICIO CALLING ON BEHALF
OF U. S. ET AND COLLEAGUES IN
STRONG SUPPORT FOR ISSUE
EIGHTEEN RELATED FOR THE
CALIFORNIA YOUTH LEADERSHIP
CORPS RESPECTFULLY THE LAST
POLICEMAN REPORT THANK CRESCENTA
FOUR HUNDRED BILLION OVER FOUR
YEARS. FOR THIS IMPORTANT
INITIATIVE AND THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET THANK. YOU THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. WHY ONE OH NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS DR
FOR STEVENSON FROM STEP FORWARD
AND STRONG SUPPORT BY ITEMS
TWENTY AND TWENTY THREE MORE
FUNDING FOR THE LABOR COMMISSION
RCI UNIT AND FUNDING FOR AN
EXTENSION OF THE SEE WHAT
PROGRAM THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT PLEASE. WHAT ELEVEN
YOU ARE OPEN. I THINK THERE
MIGHT THE NEW FACT WORKERS
OPERATING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
I. TWENTY TWO THANK YOU CHAIRED
THE LAST INTO THE SENATE FOR
INCLUSION OF THE GARMENT WORKER
JUSTICE THE SENATE BUDGET PLAN.
PERFECT PALMER GARMENT WORKERS
CAN LEARN THEIR FATE RECEIVE
LEGAL REPRESENTATION AND WHAT
SERVICES IT'S NOT TREATING ME
THE CONNECTED AYE PERFECT REASON
JOBS ORGANIZED AROUND THEIR WORK
NEEDS TO BE AMENDED THE
SIGNIFICANT THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE WE
PROJECT CONTINUED SUPPORT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT PLEASE. WHY
ONE THIRD PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M
YES NINE THE CHINESE TO THAT AT
THE AGE TWEET THE COR ITEM
TWENTY TWENTY. THE FUND THEM TO
MAKE ARE YEAH YOU NAY AND THE
COVE IN MONTHLY OUTREACH PRIME.
ASIANS ARE THE FACT GROWING
RACIAL IN THE AND ABOUT WORKERS
WHO TRUSTED IN HER ABOUT THE
RIGHT AND STRONG AND FORCE
AGENTS THE CARRIER. OUT AT WORK
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT ONE
YOU ARE ALL. MY UNIFIED ALL
KOREA CALLING ON BEHALF OF YOU
WELL THE CALIFORNIA OPPORTUNITY
YOUTH NETWORK AND STRONG THE
CORPORATION NINETEEN RELATED THE
CALIFORNIA PRACTICE SHIP PROGRAM
WELL THE ANY BASED ORGANIZATION
MISSION IS TO EMPOWER AB BECAUSE
YOU. WE RESPECTFULLY URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO WORK THANK THE
JACQUI HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS OVER THREE YEARS IT'S
IMPORTANT INITIATIVE AND THIS IS
A JEFF THE. TWENTY ONE AND A
NUMBER. THE PROGRAMS EIGHT EIGHT
EIGHT IN A TWENTY FOUR AM
PROVIDING FOLKS BUT YOU'RE.
THANK YOU HI THANK YOU FOR
CALLING THANK YOU FOR CALLING
NEXT PLEASE. ONE OH TWO YOU ARE
A- HELLO MY NAME IS YEAH HI DAR
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE OF THE
MEMBER OF THE OPPORTUNITIES THAT
WORK IN STRONG OF ISSUE NUMBER
NINE REALLY TO THAT YOUTH
APPRENTICESHIP. RESPECTFULLY
URGE LEGISLATIVE THAT THE
QUESTION OF THREE HUNDRED THIRTY
MILLION OVER THREE YEARS THE
FIRST IMPORTANT INITIATIVES.
EXPIRED YOUR AVAILABLE THIRD
RACIAL ECONOMIC JUSTICE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR CALLING NEXT
PLEASE. WHAT- EIGHT PLEASE GO.
YES GO AHEAD. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME ONCE AND I AM CALLING ON
BEHALF OF USE WILL- IN STRONG
FOR ALL OF ISSUE NUMBER NINETEEN
RELATED THE USE OF THE
CALIFORNIA YOUTH APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM AS AN ORGANIZATION THAT
WORKS WITH AN ADVOCATE WITH THE
YOUTH AGES TWENTY FIVE AND UNDER
. WITH THAT URGED LEGISLATURE
BEFORE THE INCLUSION OF- THREE
HUNDRED NINE OVER THE OVER YEAR
FOR THE IMPORTANT INITIATIVE
THANK YOU FOR. CALLING ON THE
NUMBER OF THE APPRECIATED THANK
YOU FOR CALLING NEXT PLEASE. ONE
FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. A GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
CENTERS MY NAME IS AS LONG AS I
AM WITH ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION ON COLLEGE STRONG
SUPPORT OF ITEM NUMBER SEVEN ONE
TWENTY ISSUE SEVENTEEN STATEWIDE
RANCH EMPLOYMENT FIND I WOULD
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT
LEGISLATIVE PUT AN EMPHASIS
AROUND HIGH QUALITY PROGRAMS
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR CALLING.
NEXT PLEASE. MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE
ADJUSTED THE KILL. OKAY THANK
YOU THANK YOU MODERATOR
APPRECIATE ALL YOUR WORK- I'M
SORRY. YEAH YEAH YEAH YEAH. THE
SENATOR HERE SO THANK YOU TO UP
TO THE PUBLIC. SENATORS IN MORE
FINAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
HEARING NONE- WE HAVE A MOTION
TO MOTION WE WILL WHO WHO WHO
HAVE MOTION I WOULD LIKE TO MAKE
THE MOTION TO MOVE ON THE VOTE
ON THE CALENDAR. USA THE ISSUES
THAT ISSUES- ONE THROUGH FIFTEEN
OKAY. DR FRANCIS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. CENTER DORADO. YES HI
SENATOR ALTHOUGH I SENATOR
CORTESE SENATOR CORTEZ III
CENTER NEWMAN ALL RIGHT SENATOR
NEWMAN AYE AND THEN JUST A NOTE
SENATOR GROVE IS ABSENT SO EYES
THREE NO. ZERO AND ONE MEMBER IS
ABSENT. THEY'RE GONNA FINAL VOTE
SEND- THANK ALL THE INDIVIDUALS
WHO PARTICIPATED IN OUR PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY THANK- MY
COLLEAGUES HERE ON THE COMMITTEE
IF YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US WE WANT
INCLUDE ALL OF YOUR TESTIMONY I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION WE HAVE CONCLUDED
THE AGENDA FOR TODAY'S HEARING.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU TO ALL THE
STAFF.